h
good morning everybody it's now 9:30 and
I shall resume this inquiry into the
appeal made by gladman development
limited against the decision of fic
District Council to refuse outline
planning permission for the erection of
up to 45 residential
dwellings at land on the northwest and
Southeast sides of sh and D Road
Margate now this is the F the third day
of the
inquiry
uh
yesterday we had a round table
discussion on
biodiversity and
Heritage and then Mr Hester started his
formal evidence on affordable housing
and planning and we got to Midway
through uh his cross-examination by Mr
Williams which we will revert to very
shortly I can see Mr Hester I'll just
check Mr Hester as a health check that
you're feeling okay and ready to
continue I assume you are from your your
presence thank you so I'm not as good in
the morning so I may we'll be coughing
more but I I'm fit and able so thank you
okay that's good to hear and yeah take
any time you need to to to cough that's
absolutely absolutely fine uh of course
uh just a few housekeeping matters
before we uh commence uh
just on conditions which we may or may
not get to later on I've been working
still on the list of conditions that
have been attached to the uh planning
offices committee report is that plus
the additional Suggestions by by the
rule six party is that still the uh most
up toate version that I need to
consider sir if I can assist at this
point and come in um there is an
alternative list that has been in
circulation between myself and Mr
Livingston um I sent one last query last
night it could be something that we
could simply deal with in the condition
session and I can provide you with a
list now um it was a minor Point um Mr
livson I don't know if you want to come
in at that that
point Mr
Livingstone oh you're on mute I think Mr
Livingstone
I still can't hear
you I think we're having difficulties
with Mr
Livingston's audio
uh did you did you say Mr B that it was
it was sort of minor changes to the list
that because I've already considered the
list in I went through it sort of
yesterday in a fair amount of detail are
there significant changes to those
conditions um it is within the committee
report um there is no reference to
design and access statement whereas
within the current schedule of
conditions there is a reference to
design and access statement being
included within a condition or three
conditions okay if it's as
straightforward as that I think that's
probably best dealt within the
conditions session but if we get to the
end of today and we haven't got yet to
conditions then if you could send a copy
Miss send it over anyway obviously what
I'm getting to is that obviously if we
considering conditions today I'm not
going to have a chance to really look in
any detail at any changes but if they're
minor we can deal with them in that
session if we do it tomorrow hoping we
can do it today so we can do it tomorrow
obvious I can look at those later on uh
Mr Livingston your hands up now have you
managed to read sorry you can probably
hear me now it's particularly
embarrassing that the council person
can't use the microphon is that um but
um the um yeah just to confirm what Mr B
was saying I I was literally drafting an
email to him now about this issue so it
may be a case that we can send something
to you this morning but indeed we can
deal with it in the session thank you
okay thank you for that clarification
that is helpful and similarly again I've
got the draft 106 from Tuesday I think I
received that I think yesterday it was
mentioned that there have been some
further discussions about that is there
is there a need for an updated version
of the draft 106 to be sent to me so I
can consider that before the relevant
planning obligation ation session yes
sir if I come back in at this point
sorry it's Mr B um the the unilateral
undertaking uh the district council has
no further comment um so that can be
provided there is a meeting going on
right now with Kent County Council to
discuss the final draft we hope of the
legal
agreement um we've had quite prolonged
discussions throughout the week with
them in the background um but think they
are culminating now um on that basis
what we are also going to do is provide
a planning obligation summary note which
sets out for you the the workings of the
legal obligation and all the
contributions that it
captures okay thank you that sounds
helpful particularly as from sort of a
brief look at it last night and looking
at the compliance the uh the still
compliance statement there didn't seem
to much detail on how the actual figures
have been calculated there was some
justification for them but not actual
detail of where the actual calculations
come from so obviously that's important
for me in terms of the the relevant
tests and as I mentioned on the first
day it would be very helpful to me to
have a some form of letter from Kent
County council with the if you like
final views on the 106 unilateral
undertakings whatever whatever bits that
is relevant to them so I can be sure of
the their views we have raised this with
Kent and they are they're fine to
provide the letter it may be in form of
email um but their principal solicor has
has confirmed that she's happy to do
that good okay thank you uh just a
couple of other things from me
yesterday uh on one of the speakers that
was meant to speak was a councelor candy
Gregory from uh the samon ward and she
was intending to speak but couldn't
speak when we were doing the session on
Tuesday because she was uh had work work
commitments uh
I think she's involved with vaccination
program so I think I might have said on
I did on Monday or maybe it was on
Tuesday and I probably should have
reference this on Tuesday that in the
given that she couldn't attend for what
seemed to me like good reasons if she
wanted to basically send a written
version of what she was going to speak
to then that would be fine uh in the
circumstances so that didn't come
through on Tuesday but that came through
I think yesterday and may or may not
have been sent to
I don't know that's made it through to
you Mr ball or Mr
Williams H right I thought it had H let
me just check my
email okay it was meant been sent to
both main parties Mr Livingstone have
you received a sort of a statement
from
councelor Gregory um we did there was an
email that came from uh Holly Dutton
yesterday I'm just trying to find it my
myself
um apologies I think we do have that be
with
me yes yes we do have that okay I wanted
to make sure you did have it because i'
I'm I've sort of minded to accept it in
the view of the circumstances of
councelor Gregory I.E she wasn't able to
attend the inquiry and so a written
statement of watch was going to say a
sensible Way Forward I was expecting it
on Tuesday so it was uh it obviously it
came through yesterday but obviously I
wanted to give uh the appellant any
opportunity to uh comment on that as you
see
fit um I'll be completely honest Sir
with all that's been going on I missed
this one yeah that's that's that's
absolutely fine I mean that's absolutely
fine I'm not uh yeah if I I mean I've
looked through it I don't think it
raises sort of wholly different points
to what have already been raised in some
detail by by
residents uh but I think it would be
yeah i' certainly want if you could have
a look at it and if there's any
obviously further comment you wish to
make then if you could do that in your
sort of Roundup when you ever you intend
to do that in your evidence in Chief I
assume okay that's fine I mean yeah as
as you say so it's many points that have
already been raised as part of the
inquiry
okay uh and finally I've also got an
email this
morning which has been passed to me I
think from counselor farence I don't
councelor farence is with us yet this
morning I think I might have seen your
name counselor yes there you are hello
uh and I've not seen this but you've
sent something in which is a a link to a
news article I think I'm afraid I'm
going to have to sort of put the
drawbridge down on this now because I
don't want to get into a situation where
we just getting more and more bits of
information
submitted uh particular at the stage of
the inquiry we are at I think it's a
link I've not seen it but I've been told
it's a link to a newspaper article I
think that's that's correct yeah it's a
quote about how many people we have
waiting for accommodation in thanet and
um the terrible situation that we're in
because we have so little affordable
housing given the nature of the
demographic of our population so it just
it just I just I just saw it and it just
Illustrated perfectly so I thought I'd
pass it on but I understand that and I
think I understand too the sort of the
representations that have been already
made in terms of the need for affordable
housing I'm not even sure the actual
need for affordable housing is a matter
of disagreement in principle between the
parties we can be clarified but I don't
want to accept this
because uh I think it's getting sort of
so late in the day that we really have
to sort of keep the deadlines of
submissions and I think if it was to
accept this I I'd sort of fear a sort
of other similar submissions which I
think at this stage is just too late to
accept so okay I'm sorry I can't accept
that uh but I I suspect what he saying
is is not really anything more than what
you've already said obviously M articles
too I have to consider what weight to
give to them because for you know where
they where the sources etc etc etc but I
suspect it doesn't sort of make I
suppose it reminded me that I haven't
hadn't actually given you the figures on
um right situation from the point of
view of how many people we have in need
in so um I've given you figures of
deprivation but not actually figures
about some housing so I suppose I felt
um that I I should have included that
before yeah I I no I I appreciate that
uh okay is that thank you those are my
uh housekeeping matters anybody anything
else anybody else wants to raise before
we move on with Mr
Hester
no
good over to you Mr Williams to continue
your cross- examination and before you
get into it I've opened several
documents and opened several paper
documents that you were referring to
yesterday could you just quickly go
through the list that you're intending
to refer
to in the remainder of your cross
examination so just so I can have them
ready and at
hand so the list I I give the same list
as I gave yesterday and you can check
which ones you still have open um it's
CD
5.2 which is the committee report and
its various appendices that's gladman CD
5.2 okay yeah we had the local plan
policies CD 5.1 got that one the PPG on
viability which is gladman CD
6.07 yeah got that one the various
proofs and dependencies and rebuttal of
Mr Hester Mr
culry um sanet statement of Common
Ground CD of the council
6.04 which was the committee
report relating to the other um
resolution of the council let me just
open that one that's the one I've not
opened uh
6.4 of the council's core documents
gladman core sorry okay right
uh
6.04 right
um
okay um CD in the gradman document CD
1.10
yeah the viability statement of Common
Ground okay and the council's CD
5.4 which was the 2021 local housing
need paper yeah I've got that one
already yeah okay
and we're going to start with CD
5.02 the officers
report okay thank you thank you morning
Mr
Hester um could you look please at CD
5.02
and
within that are you if you are you using
the the PDF numbers PDF numbers in the
hard copy at the top and bottom of the
page um I've got just the
paragraphs um that's the version I've
printed off so if we can use the
paragraphs that or some of them are
not okay which I've got the three
committee reports which one are you
particularly refering to we're going to
refer to all of them and a number of the
annexes okay well I've only I've I've
got the committee report some of which
have got
the paragraph numbers and some that
don't so you may well have to help me in
finding where you want me to be well yes
that's what I was going to do it's PDF
page
127 of which
report off the
document well I've printed could you let
me know what the date is anex six of the
committee
report anex
six so I I printed off the committer
report
but which sorry I'm just trying to
find this the my my uh I need to do my
refresh because it keeps knocking off
hang on a
second and the document reference
6 five
5.02 gladman core document
5.02 July 21 that was what I was asking
for at of the date but I've got that
okay so if you look please at PDF page
yes thank you towards the bottom half of
that page we see the response from the
council's planning Policy Department do
you see that yes and the council's
planning policy Department's position
was not to raise any
objection on the basis of the scheme
being for 450 units that's right isn't
it
the uh officer's response
um doesn't say categorically they raise
no objections uh in reference to the
450 they caveat their comments by saying
as long as there is no reasonable means
of increasing the level of hous and
provision
at the
site I do not consider this to be an
issue so on that point sir uh they did
raise the point uh for the officer to
deal with
this just my they raise no objection do
they Mr Hester well they don't support
or object so it's it's a commentary back
and if you look where the first point
they make in their response is that the
numbers set out in the plan are
necessarily
estimates and that they that will vary
over the plan period and will normally
balance out yes that that's fair because
we we agreed that yesterday yeah and
they also make the point that a primary
reason for the
[Music]
allocation is the delivery of the
highways infrastructure through this
allocation well it's one of the primary
reasons
yes
and that that impacts on the capacity of
the
site right yes it does but so in in in
allocating the site that was the road
through the site was considered so then
turn on please to PDF page
[Music]
yeah and and this is now in the
officer's
report and it's considering the
principle of development do you see
that yes and if you then turn on to page
yes there's a reference to the policy
team's consultation response do you see
that yes
and they summarized the two points that
refer to the numbers being illustrative
and the need for the inner relief Road
being one of the primary reasons for
allocation do you see
that yes and they then give the
development control analysis that
specific factors have been demonstrated
by the applicant to impact on the
capacity of the site due to the nature
ocracy of the site and the provision of
New Road Links and on this basis the
reduction in the number of proposed
dwellings from the allocation is
considered appropriate when balanced
against the delivery of critical Road
Links and the drainage requirements of
development on this site and so there is
no in principle objection to the
reduction of
dwellings so in answer to that that
question um firstly that is the
officer's view but I do not think it's
although variations from allocations in
plans are normally
expected I do not think that reducing
the number by
100 uh on a site that's been assessed to
be able to accommodate primary roads and
other
infrastructure is
uh is something that can be easily given
up in particular because this is a
strategic housing
allocation um and I go back to the we'll
probably come on to this but I mean it
was the committee's view that in the
round that they it seems that they
considered that because of the um need
for affordable housing on this strategic
site uh that was what made the scheme
unacceptable so while taking the
officer's recommendations into account
they still made a
decision to refuse the application and
so uh whilst the officer's view was that
there could be a reduction in the
numbers taking the number to below what
would be a strategic Asen sight
allocation to below
500 it seems to be that because of the
affordable housing issue that the
members felt that uh that was a
contribute a
contributory element
that the reduction in numbers on the
site was also a reduction in the
affordable housing numbers on the site
so it's an officer's view um but the
officer clearly set out to the members
how to address this particular issue at
the end of the report so
I I'd like to be taken there for us to
look at
that the specific point is Mr Hester
that the number of units was considered
justified by officers on the basis of
site specific figure site specific
issues and the need to deliver critical
Road link that's correct isn't it that's
correct yes they they set that out and
then please turn to par to page
yes where there's a heading design
layout and
density yes and do you see the paragraph
that begins the application site as a
whole
yes thank you in the middle of that
paragraph it's confirmed that it's not
considered that the proposal made makes
an inefficient use of
land that's right isn't it yes that's
what the officer advice was and the
particular approach in terms of leaving
certain areas
undeveloped is relied
upon in terms of the site and the
development being acceptable in terms of
its impact on character and
appearance uh yes sir I the the this is
the officer's view because he felt she
felt that the application was worthy of
being recommended for permission and so
this officer is supporting how she's
arrived at her
conclusion um that so yes in the report
I would expect to see uh commentary on
why he felt the proposal was acceptable
no but specific question again Mr Hester
please answer it the particular layout
and the leaving of spaces
undeveloped was relied upon in
concluding that the scheme was
acceptable in terms of its impact on the
character and appearance yes to to the
to the offic yes that's correct well
we've seen and we all know what the
reason for refusal says it relates
exclusively to the amount of affordable
housing provided doesn't
it it relates to affordable housing
balance to mix communities and
sustainable development from
memory so then please turn on to page
162 officers
conclusion
[Music]
just while you're doing that I'm going
to just pause for a second because the
sun shining from a window into my eyes
uh so give me one moment
[Music]
please
excuse
me right thank you so thank you because
I I I'm having trouble with my eyes and
my screen at the moment because they're
quite sensitive so that's why I'm trying
to read it from paperwork so apologies
for being slightly behind in in in
getting to the right paragraph
that's fine I appreciate with virtual
working it's not always as easy uh so
that's fine make sure you get to the
relevant
bit it's page 162 Under The Heading
conclusion yes I I have that thank you
and the third sentence concludes doesn't
it that adapting to site specific
requirements the scheme complies with
the principles of policy
sp21 uh yes it does
yeah and it also in the second
paragraph concludes that the
contribution of 450 dwellings to the
housing land Supply in the district
which is as is noted deficient is a
matter that should be given great weight
now I take it you agree that the
provision of 450 houses is a benefit
that should be given great weight
yes it makes a significant contribution
so U Mr cff I I just want to point out
is that this committee report wasn't or
the the determination of the application
wasn't based on this committee report it
was a based on the committee report that
followed um so I just want to flag that
up because the officer's conclusions in
that uh report where the members did
make the decision um balanced out the
harm versus the benefits we're going to
look at all the
reports can you just answer my question
there I think you did the provision of
450 houses is a benefit that attracts
great weight in the circumstances of
this District yes a significant
contribution are you disagreeing with
the officer's wording or just not
answering my question well the officers
wording said significant contribution so
it says this contribution to supply
should be given great weight at Le I'm
reading from the first line of the
second
paragraph it second sentence this
contribution to supply should be given
great weight yes that they then said
that after that and I'm asking whether
you agree with that yes
yes the third paragraph confirms that
the provision of the link rate
provides clear and demonstrable benefits
do you agree with
that yes but so I I I cave at my
response by saying that u a any other
scheme or another scheme could also
could also deliver the link own as well
what other scheme are you referring to
there please Mr Hester well a scheme
which would be more policy compliant and
which could bring forward the the site
um the
GL this sche won't come forward this is
an exercise of being able to get a
Planning Commission so what I'm saying
is is that another scheme could also
deliver the same links on the road well
take it in stages you agree that this
scheme in providing the Link Road
provides clear and demonstrable
benefits it it does yes but so in the in
in context um it's not the only game in
town and it does not outweigh the harm
that's been
identified by the decision or through
the decision you don't put forward any
other
scheme that delivers any housing let
alone more than 450 units and which
delivers the Link Road do you so the um
strategic housing allocation does put
forward uh
the allocation that the site could
deliver 550 units with the Link Road and
that has been tested and found sound
through the local plan and therefore in
my view a a scheme for the site could
deliver the elements that are set out in
the
policies we are half an hour in this
morning and I have covered less than one
page of 20 pages of notes
I have to ask you to answer my question
you don't put forward any other scheme
that delivers the Link Road and which
delivers more than 450 units do you in
my evidence I have not put forward
another scheme but I've not
been I've not been asked to do
that and the overall conclusion on page
163 is that the proposal
um delivers significant economic and
social benefits and I take it you agree
with that it does I've set that out in
my group of EV then let's go please to
your the second
report that was the second
report that was the first report the
first report was in
April if I want you turn to page
181 of the
PDF apologies
apologize June 2020 report now this was
where the
viability update um had been provided
and the offer
was now 15% affordable
housing that's
correct um the second report and then if
you look at the executive summary
please yes thank you that the second
paragraph officers assessment is that
the benefit benefits from the
application which includes but aren't
limited to the provision of housing new
road infrastructure contributions
towards Community infrastructure and 15%
affordable housing is considered to Dem
demonstrably outweigh any harm created
by the development that's what they said
yes and that we know that on this appeal
the development control test is the
Tilted balance don't we so the council's
case has to be
not only that the
benefits demonstratively outweigh the
harm but rather your case has to be that
the harm significantly and demonstrably
outweighs the benefits well that is the
view of the council uh and my view uh
that this where we are reading from is
the view of the officer which she is
entitled to take that opinion and make
that recommendation but I'm here to
defend the council's position which is
that the need for affordable housing out
outweighs the
benefits no that's not the right test is
it you see that's my point the point
that the off shorten my answer because
we covered this round no we haven't
covered this ground the point that the
officers are making here is that the
benefit demonstrably outweighs any harm
the test that you have to show is that
the harm sign iFly outweighs the benefit
that's how far you have to go to
substantiate any reason for refusal
isn't it yes and that's what I've said
is that the council's position is that
the council's position isn't the
officer's position the council's
position was considered which will come
to the next report in the conclusion how
that was set out by the officers and and
the Council planning committee made that
decision on the Bas on that basis and if
you then turn to page 182
please yes that the bottom in relation
to the corporate
implications the advices but the
delivery of new housing through the plan
supports the council's Strategic
priorities that's correct that's a
that's a standard
um position to take yes well you say
that's the standard position but of
course the reason for refusal suggests
that the grant of permission does not
Advance strategic priority 3 which is
the provision of
homes that's correct and and the
corporate uh implications I mean in most
uh circumstances these this table is
produced the corporate isn't
particularly um site specific neither is
the legal or the financial um the
delivery of new housing through the
local plan Etc supports the council's
priorities so that that that is a true
matter of fact it doesn't it's not
determining whether the merits of this
particular application and if you then
turn please to paragraph 4.3 on page
yes this says that following the
assessment of officers and the council's
appointed Consultants that's DSP and
RMC the sub mitted evidence has shown
that the development would be unviable
if the affordable housing on site was
increased above
15% without any evidence to the
contrary refusal on grounds of
insufficient affordable housing would be
untenable at appeal as policy sp23 of
the adopted local plan outlines the 30%
requirement only be reduced if meeting
them would demonstrably make the
proposed development
unviable therefore the reduced amount in
this specific case taking into account
the other contributions provided and the
review mechanisms to capture any uplifts
in values or grants would Accord with
local plan policy and any refusal on
this ground would be at a high risk of
being overturned at appeal with costs
awarded against the count
now as a matter of
fact the council had no additional
evidence relating to
viability to justify departing from that
position at the date of its decision did
it no I mean I I come you're correct I
come back to the point that we the
members deferred decision through on
this uh report for a further report come
back to them to see whether the officers
would be able to
suggest whether there would be a reason
for refusal so quite rightly they they
asked them to consider a reason for
refusal because you're correct they they
were not happy with the uh the
recommendation and they were not happy
with with where uh the level of
affordable housing
reached but my question which I think
you answered although I just want to
make sure as a matter of fact having
been advised that without any evidence
to the contrary on
viability any refusal would be
untenable as a matter of fact there was
no additional evidence contradicting the
viability position at the date of the
decision the that that's in answer to
that question sir that that is correct
but the members at the date of the
decision wanted to understand whether
there were reasons for refusal and if I
can can take you and refer you to the
officer's uh recommendations to the
planning committee in answer to that
question uh in the committee report of
the 21st of
July they they were asked to
consider they were asked asked officers
to provide them with what would be a
reason for refusal if they wanted to
refuse the application and in my
paragraph 2.6 which in the planning
committee paragraph 2.6 which starts the
key matter is what harm
results so the there advice is correct
um they say that if members consider
that they is substantial harm created by
not provided 30% hous affordable housing
on this site due to the specific housing
need and acute affordable affordability
issues in the district and that this
outweighs both the viability evidence
and clear benefits from the scheme then
they could refuse the application on the
following reasons
so the committee didn't decide the
application in the June planning
committee with all of the evidence that
had been provided on cost and values and
so I go back to the point I made
yesterday that DS were only advising on
cost and values not on uh other elements
of the uh proposal and the FBA that had
been submitted and it is for the
decision maker to apply the appropriate
weight to uh Financial viability
assessment and so I think in combination
and in with that
what I think is
correct recommendation to the members
who asked for this under the paragraph
2.6 they made their decision so yes they
did take into account they had to take
into account the officer's
recommendation and also the advice from
DS Dix and S on cost and
values uh
and their their conclusions but they
felt that they
considered the harm from the the
reduction in affordable hous and
outweighed those matters okay come back
please to page6 we were looking at
paragraph 4.3 and you confirmed that
there was no additional evidence on
viability to contradict that position I
now want you to look at paragraph
4.4 specific advice at
4.4 members should not apply the
rationale that ASA development can't
provide the target affordable housing
amount in the local plan that the site
is not suitable for development as a
housing site as this would fail to
adequately take into account the
guidance within the mppg regarding
viability and the provisions of policy
sd23 can I sorry Mr I I just want to
find it in paper
because I'm having difficulty with the
brightness of my eyes hang on a sec
um and the problem is the version I
printed off doesn't have paragraph on
it
right finally sorry Mr Williams would
you mind we got taking me back to the
paragraph please it's paragraph 4.4 on
page
sorry I I had
it okay I've got I'll read it from the
screen because I having
difficulty
yes I agree with that yeah thank you
okay and then we see the options at
paragraph
six on page 187 either approve or or
come up with something else I officers
simply can't think of any other option
that would be reasonable in the
circumstances and then we can go to the
third officer report
please which is on page one one of the P
of of CD
5.2 paragraph
2.2 first of all on page
three yes thank you got that the
specific concern that members had raised
was about the provision of affordable
housing under the 30% Target that's
correct so reflecting the 4.4 paragraph
4.4 advice that we just been looking at
yes and what paragraph 2.3
says first of all it refers to what sp23
says and then it says this the previous
reports at Annex 6 and nine and they are
the ones that we've been looking at
outlined the viability evidence
submitted with the application and the
independent assessment of the viability
appraisal by the council's appointed
Consultants which confirms that the
development would be unviable if more
than 15% affordable were provided on
site When taking into account all other
planning obligations stated following
the previous planning committee meeting
the viability information provided has
been
reviewed to assess whether a lower
percentage amount for different costs
could reasonably be identified which
would increase affordable housing
provision to 30% this has looked at
basee build costs external Works
professional fees disposal costs private
Revenue in developers return whilst the
lower developers profit figure at 15%
could be adopted this would not result
in a sufficient increase to allow for
30% affordable housing with the approach
of a 17 and a half% figure consistent
with the position of the Council on
other viability appraisals within the
identified government range the the
other assumptions reviewed in the
viability appraisal do not clearly show
any reasonable limits of
deviation which would increase the
viability of the scheme on the basis of
the evidence provided by the applicant
and independently assessed therefore
it's concluded that the development
would be in accordance with policy SP
23 so what happened was that in the
second report
officers said this has all been
independently appraised and the to
refuse without any additional evidence
to contradict it would be
untenable members had a debate and said
go away and review the basis of the
viability assessment and officers are
here reporting back to say that it's
been reviewed but there is no reasonable
deviation from the assumptions you used
that's what's happened isn't
it yes and and so as I agree with that
because the report makes it clear that
they had another look at base cost Works
Etc and as I said yesterday uh and I'll
repeat now so is that the the costs and
the values um were considered to be fair
and correct but
the Faba failed to actually
provide the any assessment of a policy
compliant proposal and therefore it's
got it has weaknesses it's not adequate
enough so on the basis of the costs and
values or the costs and the developers
return are set out there there is no
criticism
um but the but so so yes the the
officers are advised in that but the FDA
is has has been pointed out by me and
also with regards to the concern on
affordable housing isn't has not tested
the policy compliance scheme and looked
at those Alternatives so yes that it is
correct but members are entitled to come
to their own View and have an
understanding as to what their view is
um and they didn't they don't have to
agree with the the conclusions of the
offices and that that obious of this
particular case but just focus on this
please Mr Hester at the date of
determination members had before them no
viability evidence
whatsoever to support departing from the
independently
assessed fva and its
assumption well in answering to that
that the fbaa was not um was is clearly
shown what I in my view is
inadequate just because the FDA did not
take into account a policy compliant SM
position Mr Hester paragraph
2.3 is
very
clear it says in our second
report the FBA was endorsed you've asked
us to look at it again we've looked at
it again there is no reasonable
deviation from
it at the date of determination members
had no viability evidence before it to
justify departing
from the viability
appraisal position as assessed by
officers so I don't think that there is
a I'd like
toe present my answer a with a caveat I
mean that is
correct but the FBA is
inadequate and so members were not were
not advised that the FBA had not taken
into account what is effectively a basic
position to take to start with is what
is the policy compliant viability
assessment there there hasn't been one
hasn't been provided so they were being
asked to make a decision on an FBA which
basically assessed the scheme that been
submitted uh by the appellants the
applicants at the time which did not
deliver on uh policy compliance and at
the same time we're being told that by
the way this is unviable I think the
members have got or the planning
committee have gotten absolutely right
to come to a different conclusion if
they felt that
that the financial viability assessment
was inadequate and they clearly felt and
that's why they asked for uh the
officers to advise them as to whether
there are grounds to refuse the
application which they did and when you
go on
then please so thank you for answering
the question that there was no
contradictory evidence on
viability um in paragraph
2.6 officers
identify the need to find or demonstrate
substantial
harm to justify any refusal don't they
yes that's
[Music]
correct and in paragraph
2.7 they say it would be expected that
if a decision on the above bases was
appealed significant weight would be
given to the viability evidence provided
and independently assessed by the
council and
substantial
um weight would be afforded to housing
delivery on a strategically allocated
site when the council are in presumption
in favor of sustain able development as
well as the clear highway eological and
economic benefits of the proposed
development and the development also
complies with policy sp23 and there's no
conflict with policy
sp23 yes that's the offices of voice and
that is why you can understand the put
forward reason for refusal does not
assert any breach of
sp23 because it was the clear advis that
there was absolutely no
basis to find a breach of policy
sp23 well as I set out yesterday in my
answers that the Strategic priority uh
is is the the overarching approach on on
housing and affordable housing and the
policies come from that what the
officers view um was that policy P SP
sp23 was comp with but there is that
caveat in there with regard to the an
FDA demonstrating that a lower uh of the
fing housing number should be um be
reduced clearly members and they are
able to they're entitled to come to
their own planning committees in Char to
come to their own view providing that
can provide reasonable
justification and also the PPG sets out
that it's a matter of weight uh on on
fbas so it policy p sp23 is a is a
question of judgment
um why up the question of planning
judgment as to whether uh an
FBA overcomes
the the under provision of 4 at 30% but
we can agree any planning judgment must
be based on evidence wasn't
it yes yes that's correct but it's the
of the evidence and how adequate it is
which is important and we've already
agreed that members had no contradictory
evidence to depart from the assumptions
and inputs into fva and that's what
paragraph 2.3 is saying there is no
reasonable deviation from the submitted
and approved fbaa so in answer to that
report that that that's what to the
answer that question that um that that
is set out in the report but I I go back
to my point earlier that
if if a scheme isn't a policy compliance
scheme and it and it doesn't assess
viability on POL on on a policy
compliance scheme then the fdaa is is
inadequate in my view and therefore the
the planning committee were entitled to
come to a different opinion uh to the to
the officite for the officers
advice could you then take up please Mr
cry's proof of evidence
um I'm going to go to
that could you
um yes thank you got that
there
and in section
four of that evidence what Mr cry does
is apply exactly the same cost inputs
and valuation approach but updates it
for the purposes of the inquiry you
understand that yes and we can agree
that if you take that approach that is
take the same scheme and update it on
the taking the same input approaches
then that shows on page 11 that the
residual land value does not exceed The
Benchmark land
value yes that's how he concluded
yeah so if the same approach is taken to
costs and values but updated the the
scheme remains unviable at
15% that's how he's
concluded we don't take any issue with
his assessment of those inputs or
outputs because that's not a matter for
you is it that that's right and and and
cost and values apart from the one issue
about whether to use the than or the
Kent wide approach to costs we're not in
dispute with with these
inputs I'm going to come back to
that particular point
it's all if you take up the viability
PPG
please it's it's and this is
paragraph
I've got 10
um does it start with what are the
principles for pairing out of viability
assessment is that is that the one that
you want to go
to No it's it's giv get the PPG
reference number it's
[Music]
id10 yes I've I've got
that I had that
yes and it's paragraph eight it's a
simple Point really
that it
will always be the case that a more
detailed viability appraisal is prepared
and can be prepared at the time of the
planning application than at the time of
the local
plan so I now I've now missed where your
references are what what what is the
heading for the subheading for
the because it's the way I've printed
this off so how should viability
assessment be treated in decision making
oh yeah yeah yeah
that's but the questions a rather
simpler one that it will inevitably be
the case that a more detailed appraisal
can be prepared at application stage
than at the local plan
stage that that's
correct now if you could then take up
please Mr Ball's proof of
evidence
yeah and turn to section
four yes thank you what Mr ball has done
here is
summarize material that's elsewhere in
the application documents that explain
expains how the scheme has responded to
site constraints in consultation with
Council officers in order to arrive at
the parameter plan and the application
for 450
units it it it does that now you haven't
produced any rebuttal proof of evidence
relating to any of that material have
you that's
correct and your own proof Pro of
evidence does not make any reference
to site constraints or how they could be
overcome so my proof does not go to that
extent but what my proof sets out is and
as I said in my examination that that
there are opportunities within the
developable areas to
uh consider increasing the amount of
uh housing on the site and in also
not having to not the scheme not
providing an over 1.9 hectares of open
space when it's not necessary if the
number of units were going to stay where
they are so in answer to that question
so that that's correct I haven't done
that but I've set out where I think the
site can picking up in terms of
increasing the numbers on it so no no
for example know we heard in detail from
Mr Travis about flood issues and how
that had related to the need to leave
some areas undeveloped you just simply
haven't given any consideration to
points like that at all have you no
because they you don't develop on flood
areas
basically and when you say you've set
out in your evidence how a larger number
of houses could be developed on the
site where have you done that
please so I I under my um in my proof of
evidence I've set out my approach to the
scheme from paragraphs 3.7
onwards um and I've said
that if the
scheme did not use up so say that
again the requirement is for a minimum
of open space to 4.4 hectares The
Proposal provides for 6.3 hectares local
space which is 1.9 hectares more than
that the require the minimum requirement
and in the following paragraphs I set
out and provided a kind of a loose
example or high level example that if
you if if those if that 1.9 hectares for
example were to be developed out that
actually could apply the same density
bring bring the scheme to 518 new
homes um in theory but I mean in
practice that may vary from that but
I've also in my
um in my examination advised you sir
that uh because of the topography
because of the um where the proposed
three story developments are uh those
areas could be thickened out without in
my view or certainly could be looked at
to be thickened out and have more more
units without harming the scheme
impact without that scheme impacting
significantly on on its immediate
environment so so my evidence is is
basically saying well there is an
opportunity to uh provide a different
scheme with more units on the SES um and
that's why I've set that out uh in my
crew but in relation to the open space
when on a point of detail if you look at
Mr Ball's 5.69 19 the scheme actually
provides 5.22 hectares 5.22 hectares of
open space not 6.3 but the bigger point
is that you can't opine on the
appropriate level of open space without
considering the site constraints which
you accept you haven't
done well I can I I have to I have
considered the the the SES constraints
because I'm not suggesting that I don't
know where of all got that figure from
because that's not in the um in in the
developing framework or the parameter
plan but but I I I am I have suggested
that the sites the parts of the sites
which aren't constrained by um
flooding um and the other elements could
be thickened up and I've explained how
and why that could be the scheme put
forward and reflected in the development
framework and the development parameter
plan would worked up over a considerable
period of time with technical input and
with the approval of offices wasn't it
well it was certainly put together uh in
consultation with officers
um I I don't have I don't have an answer
to that question yes it probably was and
with considerable technical
input yes because there a number of
meetings I think with County Council and
and other offices it has never been
suggested
prior to your evidence in Chief that the
parameter
plan was in some way deficient has
it I don't know the answer to that
because I wasn't at the meetings but the
my my understanding is is that the
um the SK it's a scheme that was
iterated principally by
gladman um and I think at the very end
of that iteration they they said well we
can't get 30% affordable housing and I
think the the response was uh well you
need to provide a vinity appraisal to
demonstrate that so I think that's how
it's that's how it went but obviously Mr
ball who may have been at some of those
meetings will be able to answer that
question and if the council had wished
to put forward evidence that not
withstanding the technical constraints
of the
site the site could accommodate more
than 450 units it could have done so
couldn't
it the yes the officers could have said
you need to increase the the numbers and
and that particular officer did not feel
that uh or rather I don't know what they
said but clearly gladman produced their
own scheme so through the inquiry
process if the council had wanted to
demonstrate or show that the site with
all its technical constraints could
provide more than 450 units it could
have done so couldn't
it so that's correct but I I point to
the fact that there has been an
assessment of the site to that could
deliver
550 I've I've said and that was done
through the local plan process and that
was found sound the local plan
inspectors felt that that number of
units could be uh provided on the site
and that's why they uh that's why the
site was proposed or stepped up into the
Strategic allocation uh level of of the
with the six other strategic
allocation my view is is that because
there is a deficit of affordable
housing the appellant should be looking
at where where the where an increase of
affordable housing might be achieved and
in my view looking at the site again
with a different
scheme um not well a different set of
parameters uh will be able to increase
the number of units on the site and
therefore or thereby increasing the
amount of affordable housing the
specific conclusion of offices which we
saw in the offices
report was that the specific number
was entirely appropriate given the site
specifics and what had been demonstrated
through the application process we saw
that didn't we that that's that
particular officer's view yes and there
is absolutely nothing to suggest in the
reason for refusal that the council
takes any point at all in relation to
the appropriateness of the parameter
plan or the development
framework that's
correct
and even
if one were to amend parameter
plans to increase floor space for
example you wouldn't know the financial
effect of that without doing a financial
viability appraisal off that specific
scheme because of of course the costs
would go up alongside the floor space
and the value may not go up by more than
the costs go
up that that's correct and and this is
the problem with the the appellant
scheme we're at outline stage and very
small changes and deviations in inputs
can make a significant uh change to the
viability of the scheme B in both
directions I I admit because because of
the scale of the of the of the number of
units and and so yes I mean any
different input any different floor
space will have an impact so my my view
is that
the 30% should be applied at this stage
and once the detailed of details of the
scheme are drawn up then viability can
be looked at
again and in terms of
the alternative viability
appraisal as I understand it the council
doesn't put forward any alternative
viability
appraisal um to this
inquiry that that that's correct sir and
the reason for that is because as I've
just said is that if firstly if you
applied a policy compliance scheme you
would get a different set of outcomes
and in in view of the fact that it is an
outline stage everything is theoretical
at this stage um we're not we're not at
the detailed stage we're at least a year
off from that things change and and
therefore it it's in my view appropriate
to apply the 30% affordable housing at
this stage in order for uh a viability
if it's needed to come forward on a on a
fixed scheme because the scheme isn't
fixed M it's simply not correct cor to
say that everything is hypothetical at
the moment the
application seeks a
specific Grant of permission subject to
a range of detailed conditions and tied
into the parameters plan and the
development framework doesn't it but
what it's seeking to fix is affordable
housing at at this stage uh with with
all the variables uh and there is a it's
a high degree of theoretic Theory at the
moment because a house Builder will not
take the same approach that uh that the
uh FDA has so far so a house Builder
will put their floor spaces in a house
Builder will take a view they don't they
don't have their costs under the bcis
they they don't put their costs into the
bcis system they have their own View and
Market test of the of the floor space
and the types of units that they're
going to deliver so we we will get to
another stage where well that will be
will will be more detailed to enable us
to have a clearer
picture you're relied in considerations
that go to financial viability
assessment with considerations that go
to the planning permission the planning
permission if granted won't be entirely
theoretical will it it will be tied to
the numerous conditions relating to the
technical work for example the flood
risk the archaeology nature
conservation and also the parameter plan
and development framework worked up in
light of that
information corre that that is correct
and that isn't a theory but what I'm
saying is is that the that the
affordable housing level is
inappropriately being sought to be set
at this
stage now come back to the questions of
mix and type of units that that you
explained at the end of yesterday by
reference to paragraph 3.12 of the
statement of common ground on viability
this is something that's your domain
rather than Dixon
Cs and I would like you to look in a bit
more detail please at the Dixon cell
report now this is appendix B if
your to your
proof yes thank you and you asked Dixon
s to consider two alternative
scenarios to the gladman mix if I can
call it
that that was one based on the 2016
schar and the other based on the
2021 local housing needs
that's correct and Dix and sell make
clear at the top of the page that they
have run these because the council
requested
them yeah at the top of page
five yes I ask
consideration and as we saw
yesterday when you look at the outputs
on page
the gladman mix and
type produces the highest land value
doesn't
it yes it does so if you amended the mix
and
type to reflect more closely either of
those documents you would be reducing
the site to value and driving down the
amount of affordable that permission
could sustain compared to the gladman
appraised
mix no that's not that's not correct
because the gladman proposed mix is is
an
18.1%
profit now you're looking at the wrong
figure you see when you're working out
how valuable the development is you look
at the resid the rlv the residualized
land
value the
I mean it's
a the point of this ex yes you are
looking at the res residualized land
value on on the uh on the gladman scheme
I mean as I said in my proof of evidence
I mean that it at this stage it's too
it's too early and and and um Benchmark
land value is is a figure to encourage
the develop the land owner to bring
forward their land they will not be
that's that's the minimum amount that
they are expected to
get um so I have a caution on that um
but the
18.1% gives Gad on their scheme and
they're still sticking to 15% affordable
Mr H you're over complicating it I'm
just asking about the mix you see
effectively the residualized land value
is what the site is worth with a
particular planning permission in place
and what this shows is that the site is
worth the
most with the gladman mix and the least
with the 2016 schar
mix but the gladman mix provides an 18%
profit you're looking at wrong figure
the 18.1% figure is simply to take the
profit that is shamee to be made in the
residual appraisal and comparing it to
the gross development value it's not
telling you what the land is worth with
that assumed planning
permission so what what's your question
again my question is that if you do what
you say should be done and assess a mix
that's more close clly related to the
2016 schar or the 2021 lhn it drives
down the land value and would generate
less affordable housing than the gladman
assumed mix but it
doesn't it doesn't because the gladman
assume
mix is 18 has an 18.1% profit whereas
they were they were proposing 17.5 what
that shows me is that having updated the
figures Plum end up with or the
developer will end up with a greater
level of profit with the same amount of
affordable housing that they are
offering you're just misunderstanding
that the the figures which scheme I can
ask Mr culry to comment on this which
scheme do you think generates the
highest land value out of scenarios one
two and three well one
does 101 does and which scheme is that
that's the gladman scheme as they want
to so the highest land value is
generated by the gladman mix which
exceeds for 2016 or 20121 mix so that
that's correct but it doesn't increase
the level of affordable housing that on
offer you fundamentally misunderstood
this Mr no I've answered your question
so I've answered the question that that
the gladin their scheme their one and
only scheme will deliver uh a better
land rlv than the other schemes they
will but they will be at
18.1% profit and they will not increase
the level of affordable housing that
they've offered uh in
2021 M you're fundamentally
misunderstanding the point the point is
not what the actual rlv is because
that's a matter of dispute the point is
that however you do it what Dix and S
are showing is that the gladman mix
generates the highest land
value and that is correct isn't
it it is yeah on the on the gladin
scin but so that would not
that would be contrary to policy but the
gladman scheme would not be policy
compliant and therefore it's it would
not be something that the council would
ordinarily grant polition
for units were to come forward but Mr
all that would mean is that if a
different mix were imposed at Reserve
matters then the amount of affordable
housing secured through the 106 was more
than if the 26 or 2021 schar had been
assessed through the
fdaa at the end of the day the in in
answer the it's about whether a policy
compliant scheme can be delivered with
an appropriate uh an accepted range of
profit
for the
developer see if you go back please to
CD 5.2 the officers
report at go to PDF
page6 I just need to refresh what
um
sorry can me the C docum again because I
I need to look at this on on the refresh
again CD 5.02 using the um gladman core
documents excuse
me
sorry
thank you sorry for for the delay I've
now got the the document up but if you
could take me to where you want want me
to be PDF PDF
page6
okay thank you I'll back the page at the
bottom of the page do you see as the
application has been submitted in
outline
form
yes detailed values has been conducted
using an illustrative accommodation mix
for Market housing and affordable
housing this mix has an increased amount
of larger properties than the mix
recommended in the sh
ma for example providing 55% of Market
dwellings as three beds when the
recommended range is 30 to
35% this is considered to therefore be a
robust mix to assess the best case for
gdv yes it said yes it says that and and
I I agree with that
but the difficulty of the problem with
the FV is that it didn't assess a policy
compliant
position um and so it wouldn't be a
scheme that would been support by the
policy and would not follow the smart so
of course bigger units and more units is
going to produce the best case for gdv
but in the end it didn't actually
increase the level of Market housing uh
Beyond where the kind of committing into
it the the point that's being made by
officers there
is that by varying the mix from the 2016
schar in a way that's more in line with
what the market wants you're actually
going to provide a best
case I a very robust case so that if you
subsequently substituted in thear mix
that would reduce viability and justify
less affordable housing and that's the
point isn't it
that that is the point um but I go back
to my comment before is that the the
scheme that is put
forward failed to meet standards for
sizes for two-bedroom houses failed to
meet
smar um
and as I asked Dix and cell to carry out
if you put those inputs in you still end
up with um a percentage of profit within
the the the general 15 to 20% uh
range yes yes the scheme the gladman
scheme produces the best gdv but it
doesn't end up with with increasing the
amount of affordable housing and that's
the issue so I'm just at the moment
dealing with mix and
time officers said in the officers
report if you go back or if you went to
the schar mix it would produce a less
viable
scheme you've then asked Dix and S to
run figures based on the 2016 and 2021
mixes they've run the figures and that
evidence confirms what officers had
already said which is that the gladman
mix and type is more viable than the
2016 or 2021 mix and type we can agree
that can't we yes the
do
so that's mix and time thank you just
slightly conscious of the time Mr
Williams whether not Mr Hester
you're need a sort of a short break and
Mr Williams what how long do you think
you've got I'm afraid it has been slower
than I'd hope probably half an hour half
an hour Mr Hester are you sort of
conscious of your let's keep going
otherwise yeah are you sure conscious of
your health to make sure that you're not
uh as long as you don't mind me coughing
from time to time so okay okay we will
we will keep going on that basis in
light of the time there is a there's a
moot point under sp22 about whether or
not the lhn
2021 has superseded the
2016 lhn or schar I'm going to deal with
that with Mr ball sir rather than take
up more time in Cross examination if
that's if that's acceptable
um the mix and type we've dealt with
sizes in your evidence at
3.31 you do make a point about two
bedroom
units
and
um in Mr cry's rebuttal please if you
could turn to
that
paragraph
2.2.7 yeah what Mr cry has done as he
explains is he's re run the viability
operat keeping everything as in his
proof of
evidence apart from the point that you
make about the inclusion of a minimum of
70 me 70 square meter two bed houses
everything else has remained the
same um and what that shows that
appraisal on page four is that the
residual land value still exceed sorry
still fails to exceed The Benchmark land
value so that's correct um but so I I
point to the I point to the um position
of gladman in that day were able to
accept a deficit of
1.7 throughout the probability
assessments well that's a different
point which I'm happy to deal with and
I'll deal with momentarily I'm just at
the moment we started off with you
saying Dix and cell deal with all inputs
apart from mix type size we've dealt
with mix and type and we've shown that
altering those in the way that you
requested reduces
viability I'm now dealing with size and
we see that altering that in the way
that you've
suggested shows that the viability or it
remains unviable against Benchmark land
value at um residual value against
Benchmark land value yes as an exercise
and size yes and also what Mr cry says
and I don't know whether this is
something you can agree or whether it's
outside your expertise is that if you
start changing sizes you do actually
have to reconsider values because of
economies of scale and Quantum discounts
effectively yeah I agree with that to a
point um but because a house Builder
will that there will be a range that the
house Builder will want to build out
their their particular units so there'll
be the the bottom figure which is the 70
and there'll be an upper figure Beyond
which it doesn't it's not um viable for
them to do that so yes there'll be a
range between the two it it it it
generally follows that uh house builders
are looking to increase the D to the
floor space on their sites to as much as
they think is viable okay thank you then
turning to the question of
updating your proof please at paragraph
3.38 excuse
me thank
you
yes thank you 3.38 you
explain that you asked Dixon s not to
[Music]
change the gladman assumptions on costs
and
values yeah the inputs into abnormals
and and you know the base cost and
everything else like that
now if you take up the DSP report again
please
yeah at
the um bottom of page
five
assumptions used in current
review despite your
instruction not to change assumptions on
costs and
values um DSP provide updates on a
different cost base don't
they
uh yes uh I think think I set that out
in my proof of evidence but I just need
to um I've lost the
page in in effect what we asked Dion
Shel to do is to use the same cost input
and uh of the
um of the uh the Jon Landing the sales
um probability but to just look at
updating or refreshing I think the
inspector even asked for it at the case
management conference um to just to
update on on the current position in
terms of costs and values and so that's
what they they sort do not costs in
terms of abnormals and everything else
but the inflationary costs that have
taken place uh since the determination
of the application so I think there was
a November refresh uh that fitting in
with the quarterly information from
bcis that's what you ask them to do just
to update taking the same approach to
cost
and values but when you look at what
they've actually done they have changed
the cost
base because they've changed from using
the bcis 15 year sample for Kent yeah to
FID yes so I understand now yes they
they they did that and I asked them to
do that because that was consistent with
the approach in the local plan and the
guidance uh the PPG gued suggest uh that
would be the best starting point so that
was something you asked them to do
yes well that perhaps explains in their
report they don't provide any
justification as to why you would take
the thanet fiveyear costs given that
they had previously endorsed the Kent
15-year sample
basis do they because we wanted to be
consistent with how that approach was
undertaken through the local plan
position The The
J uh deviation from the local plan
viability high level viability was for
something for them to explain because
the guidance says suggests that we
should follow the the the um how it's
undertaken through the local plan with a
with a recently adopted local plan so
the alteration of the cost base was not
done on the advice of the quantity
surveyors retained by the
council well we in consultation with
them and they agreed that the best
position would be or the most accurate
information would be through the than
cost rather than through the Kent wide
cost as I explained
yesterday there's no evidence of that at
all is the Mr
Hester no evidence of what any
recommendation to take the thanet cost
base no no evidence so that the evidence
is I asked them to do that that's not
evidence well what evidence are you
speaking for a letter or something or I
mean that that that's in consultation
with with with Dix and cell we asked
them to be more
um complicit with the the local plan
approach okay
so we can agree can't we that the
selection of the appropriate cost base
is a matter of
expertise
yes it's a matter for a quantity
surveyor ideally if not a
surveyor yes
the fva was the subject of such
specialist review wasn't it
yes can you take out please again CD
5.02 the officer's
report page 7
one PDF
please yes thank you now just to get
your bearings this is appended to the
Dix and C review this is the specialist
quantity surveyor report if you look on
page PDF
70 introduction do you see it says
ermc yeah has been commissioned by Dixon
s to carry out an independent review of
the construction costs used in an fva
produced by James Lang Lal Etc so that's
what this is
doing if you then go back to page
71 and the cost
review Under The Heading proposed
development do you see that yeah
and it notes that what's been
used is the
bcis average for Kent which is taken
over a
15E
period the next paragraph notes that you
can do it on either a county or a local
area basis do you see that yes and then
it says at the end of the paragraph
given the level of design development of
the housing element of the scheme the
jll route sorry rate used is considered
reasonable yes that's that's correct and
I think they that's Dixon cell called it
fair well don't worry about what Dixon
cell called it we'll come to that the
position is that the cost
consultant endorsed the cost bases used
by James Lang lar
yes
if you then go in the same document
please to PDF page
54 thank
you you see the heading costs
assumptions
yeah
they refer at
3.8.0 to the ermc specialist
advice yes and they draw attention to
the fact that where there is any
disagreement ermc have put
forward this spoke
costs
yeah
and do you see they then provide their
estimate of construction cost
residential construction cost of being
52.7 two
million
yes
so that's the jll approach if you then
turn on
please to back to page
72 do you see page 72 yeah the
construction costs put forward by
eirmc are 52.7 24 million yes so the
cost consultant use used precisely the
same figure for the basis of their cost
plan as jll and it is based on the Kent
bcis figures
yeah and if you then go on in the same
document to page
157 yeah back in the officer's
report it says for costs assumptions the
use of the bcis service median rate
rebased for Kent has been considered
acceptable yes in answer that question I
I I think Dixon sales approach here was
that if if the figures had been
significantly further apart from the fic
fig that they would have raised that
matter but because they were close
enough that it wasn't something that
that that needed to be um
differentiated and so
um
the
position
isn't that well the position is very
clear isn't it that when asked to review
the cost spaces
the cost Consultants provided a cost
plan that took the same figure that
applied the same approach as James
langler
S yes I mean they yes they didn't they
they didn't see a need to
differentiate and Dix and S also
endorsed
that yes they didn't need see need to
differentiate officers also endorsed
that they accept the uh advice of DS and
there is nothing before this inquiry
from the
council in any
document that supports in this scheme
specific
appraisal taking anything other than the
bcis costs for Kent that have been
submitted and endorsed by those three
bodies well as I as I
I've pointed out earlier the the the
fact that the application has been
refused means that the planning
committee were not satisfied with the
FDA for a number of reasons and so to be
more accurate in how to look at the
scheme and how to look at the viability
of the scheme we felt it was more
appropriate to adopt the same uh planic
approach to costs than the local plan in
particular as that is referenced in the
PPG that if you have an upto-date local
plan or recent local plan then it would
be for the um Financial assessment to
follow that unless unless reasons are
provided I can't remember EXA wording of
the the paragraph So we felt a more
accurate approach would be to uh see how
the uh viability of the scheme compared
to how it was tested at the local plan
stage because at the local plan stage it
was found to be a sound approach and and
the local plan was found to be sound and
so therefore that's that's the reason
why uh we asked and and DS agreed that
the F sample size is is relevant enough
to be able to be used in this particular
case we have agreed haven't we Mr Hester
that the selection of the appropriate
cost base is a matter of of specialist
advice yes that's correct and I have
taken you to endorsements of the Kent
Base by
ermc by Dixon s and by Council
officers my question was there is
nothing that the council has
produced from a surveyor or a quantity
surveyor that justifies departing from
that position for the purposes of this
inquiry well the DS Dix and S agree that
an appropriate uh way of looking at this
at this stage would be to look at how it
Compares with the uh the fit approach
which is more accurate so we're looking
at more accurates because the there are
a number of assumptions that the
planning committee we're not satisfied
with and that's why we've undertaken
this exercise it's not I haven't ask
them to I mean as you you correct me say
and as I said I'm not I don't have any
expertise in the dark heart but what I
do know is that from a planning point of
view you you we should be looking at
some consistency in terms of the how the
local plan viability feeds into to this
viability and that was an exercise that
I asked them to undertake because at the
end of the day as i' I go back to the
point about this is an outline
application the scheme that will
eventually come forward on the site will
not be this one so um that's why we we
were looking at more specific detailed
information which is likely to change in
the next six months as well so um that's
why I think it's more accurate uh to to
that's why DS think it's more accurate
to use the
the come back to my question please can
you take me to any
documentary advice from DSP or ideally
ermc that justifies departing from the
endorsed position of the use of bcis
Kent the do the documentary advice is
that the PPG that that seems to be the
starting position to take so that's all
that you rely
upon I rely on the fact that it's a more
accurate sample to use the thanet one
because the thanet is more local whereas
the Kent wide one as I said yesterday in
includes West Kent which is a very
affluent area and a very has a very
different character so if we can get the
sample size if we can can get enough
sample in the stats then it's it's it's
a better and more accurate uh look at
the the likely cost of development in
this particular area but we've agreed
that's not it's about finessing the the
costs because I'm uh positive that
the that the house Builder will have
their own uh
approach to costs and than the
bcis we've agreed that the selection of
the rate isn't a matter for you that's
why I'm asking you to take me to
documentary advice from the Specialists
that justifies departing from the
endorsed position in the documents that
I have taken I'm not I haven't got
documentary advice to to give to this
inquiry because in their
note Dix and S on page six are very
careful
they don't
recommend fet they just say that they've
applied it and that's because as you've
told us you asked them
to yes we did ask and so the only
documentary advice or it's not advised
you wanted to refer to the PPG which
part of the PPG did you want to refer me
to please well I I referred to it
yesterday and I think you picked it up
so
um yes paragraph 008 I think we we went
to this earlier today uh so where of
viability assessment submitted to a
company a planning application this
should be based upon a refer back to the
viability assessment that informed the
plan and the applicant should provide
evidence of what has changed since then
though it was it's trying to be more
accurate and More in terms of firstly
it's TR to be more consistent with the
plan in accordance with that advice and
more accurate in terms of the um the
thanet factor rather than the K
Factor the difficulty I have have with
that is
that the Dixon s and
ermc gave their
advice that Kent was appropriate in the
context of a site specific appraisal
didn't they yes they didn't think that
the difference was that significant to
to pick that point up or to to make that
differentiation okay thank you I'm going
to move on to developers profit in the
interest of time developers profit the
selection of the developers profit is
also a matter of a surveyor's expertise
isn't
it yes I mean it's a it's a sausage
machine in terms of inputs and outputs
as I understand
it and Dix and S were happy with
17.5% yes that that's the normal
approach
uh across the district and in CD 5.2 as
we
saw
um the council noted at 2.3 the third
report that to depart from
17.5% would be to take an inconsistent
approach from other applications across
the
district yeah I mean you have to take a
site specific site cir ances approach um
but 17.5 is the mid-range and that's and
that's usually the starting point but
the point that officers made is that the
17.5% is consistent with the position of
the Council on other viability of prais
yes it is um I mean there is one
different one which I think we're going
to look at later on on soundon but the
circumstances around that um were
specifically Justified so yes 17.5 is
this is the normal starting decision and
of course we know from the PPG on costs
that determining for a council to
determine cases in an inconsistent
manner is an example of unreasonable
behavior isn't
it well I don't know what what you mean
by that one of the examples of
unreasonable behavior given in the PPG
on
costs is determining cases in an
inconsistent
manner yeah you if you've got identical
circumstances
um there is a case for that each one
needs to be looked at on its own merits
and in CD
6.4 which is
the excuse me is the
um committee report relating to Salon
gra which core document number was that
again CD
6.04
please
sorry I need to refresh for me again
[Music]
sorry
thank
you it's this was this was an outline
application wasn't
it yes for
um and the council has no difficulty
in
considering viability at the outline
stage subject to a 106 being imposed to
reflect the viability
appraisal so just to give you some
understanding of this um
the this is the planning committee
report fifth of
August there are three planning
committee reports
um on this particular application this
is the middle one that's on 6.
04 don't know if there are others are on
the core
documents but the the starting position
to for the first the application which
was first reported was that the full SM
mix and full 30% affordable housing was
uh
posed there wasn't a financial viability
assessment required uh at that
stage and then as this report this this
fifth of August report says is that the
is an issue with
viability uh because in drawing up a
more
detailed part of The Proposal which was
to do with the road and also some other
small some other changes there was a
difference of four million pounds um in
in in the viability they came back
uh which say set out in this report the
the they came back to say that they
couldn't deliver more than
18%
affordable um on a split of 70 to 30
rent of shared
ownership the members uh asked the
officers to go back to see what more
could be done and in the report of the
11th of
November she it there
the applicants came back and said well
we
can give you still give you a fully
compliant smarm
mix we can give you 30% but for the
housing but it would be on the basis of
shared ownership
only or we can offer 18% on the basis of
70% of that would be holdable rent and
30% would be shared ownership uh
officers then gave the the members the
opportunity to pick their preferred
option and they pick the option of the
70 to 30 with the
18% um affordable housing level so I I I
do want to make a point about
this uh and that is that the salmeron
decision in my view can be capable of
being a material consider ation that you
should take into account but there are
material diff differences between that
scheme and the appeal scheme to the
extent that that scheme still is
offering a fully compliant smart on
housing in terms of type sizes
Etc that scheme is for 250
units is not a strategic site identified
through assisting creating the mixed and
balance Community step change and
housing
as I said it originally offered 30% so
there's no Financial viability involved
and they still offered
30% with full shared ownership and
members planning committee decided they
would accept
18% for 7030
split the housing strategy encourages
negotiations some policy compliance
schemes where a policy compliance scheme
is offered subject to viability of the
Council will consider a different tenure
SP but in in addition the report sets
out that at the time of the decision the
current market
uncertainty Justified accepting a 20%
profit and so in those
circumstances the planning
committee uh decided to grant planning
permission or resolved to Grant planning
permission subject to
section 106 agreement so I think so in
covering this
point the appeal scheme is for
450 uh and offering
15% that scheme at salmeron is for 250
offering 18% or 30% depending on the
10um
mix and that case needs to be considered
on its own merits and I think it's it's
not directly comparable to carry
significant weight and you're weighing
up as to how much weight to get it in as
a material
consideration short Point actually Mr
Hester was if you look at paragraph
3.10 in that case the council considered
it appropriate to endorse a 20%
developers
profit that's right isn't
it and and it is set out as to why that
is um if I can find the
ref paragraph 3.10 it's what I gave you
no the the
the the officers um
stated why they thought 20% was
acceptable in these circumstances and
I'm just going to find that for the
inspector
because I just I've realized that you
haven't got all the reports here you've
only got you've only got
one I mean I'm sure Mr Upton can help me
in re examinations to find where it is
but basically sir the the officers said
in view of the because of coid in view
of the uncertainty in the market and the
particular circumstances uh we would we
suggest 20% because of that level un of
uncertainty that's how officers
surprised the
members move on can we get if you go to
the Dix and C
report page
12 yes thank you um you L didn't ask vix
and cell to run a sensitivity at
20% no which would have shown
considerably reduced
viability well it would have been more
viable for the uh it would be more
viable for gladman but not not actually
deliver anything in ter deliver anything
more for the MC Authority so why would
it have been more viable for gladman I
don't understand if they had 20% profit
or the developer no no that's not not
how it works the developer profit is an
input into the appraisal that reflects
the reward for the risk of a developer
in undertaking the development it's
entirely applicant
unspecific yes had you not appreciated
that of course because gladman isn't
building out this scheme yeah so this
has got nothing to do with whether it's
gladman or anyone else who applies for
planning permission no standardized
input it's actual profit I mean that
that that's the level that we I think
we're talking about actual profit so my
question was Please Mr Hester if you had
run a sensitivity at 20% developers
profit it would have shown worse
viability yes and what Dix and S say on
page 11 and 12 sorry is that you asked
them to do a sensitivity at 15% but they
go to the trouble of pointing out on
page 13
that their review on a site specific
basis was that
17.5% was suitable in this
case yes that's right but what I the
reason why I asked them to look at 15%
this is because the so us as
Inspector are going to probably look at
the 15 to 20% range so 15% is at the
bottom end of the range
17 and a half is the midrange but the
purpose of of of putting the 15% to you
is for you to to be able to see what
that looks like in terms of whether more
affordable housing can be delivered to
the scheme so the purpose of that is to
provide a
um not a worst case scenario but a
scenario
where a profit level which is deemed
acceptable in the PPG could still be
reached in terms of
15% but that would that would enable
more housing more affordable housing to
be provided on the
site but if you were presenting a range
it would be fair to present both ends of
the range wouldn't
it well I think I yes I see that point
but at the same time it it wouldn't the
other end of the range we still we know
we wouldn't get more than 15% affordable
housing so um it was purely to see what
the lower end of the profit range might
be able to bring forward in terms of
affordable housing and the only
specialist advice that the council
relies upon in relation to developers
profit is that 17.5% is
suitable yes that's the starting
position um in most local authorities
but it's it's all it's all dependent on
S
circumstances um and the level of
affordable hous that's coming out
through the sausage machine of of inputs
and
outputs come come back come back to the
question there is no specialist advice
that the council relies upon in relation
to the input of developers profit other
than that it should be
17.5% in these sites specific
circumstances that's the starting
position of the advice uh from DS um but
my input was that I felt the it was
important to look at the lower range uh
for the benefit of the inspector to be
able to see what level of affordable
housing could be achieved or rather what
the position the change position would
be from 15% but you say starting point
it's the end point on the basis of
specialist advice isn't
it the the specialist advice is to start
at 17.5%
no The Specialist advice is to take
17.5% yes take yes to start that as the
to take that as the starting point okay
now final question I'm we gone over
again
um if you look at
the
DSP outputs on page
11 there's an
exercise at the bot botom of the
page and over the page which takes into
account a deficit of 1.7 million do you
see
that yes I do sorry I noded sorry I say
sorry
DSP do not provide any assessment at
all of what affordable housing could be
provided as Against The Benchmark land
value do they that's
correct if we look at the PPG on
viability again
please thank you have
that at paragraph 10
10 yeah what are the principles for
carrying out a viability viability
assessment is a process of assessing
whether recite is financially viable by
looking at whether the value generated
by development is more than the cost of
developing it this includes looking at
key elements of Grace development value
cost land value land ear a premium and
developer return so that
includes Benchmark land value and that's
what we're told in 10113 isn't
it
yes and so it's by comparing the
residualized land value against
Benchmark land value that one is under
the PPG to assess
viability yes providing that um a policy
compliant scheme has been
tested now the
council as far as I can see doesn't put
forward any Financial viability
appraisal at all of any scheme is that
right that's that's
correct and the council doesn't assess
what amount of affordable housing it
says this scheme could generate as
against the Benchmark land
value that's correct and and and so the
reason why that is is because we wanted
to uh demonstrate to you that this is
we're so early on in the scheme in terms
of
outline the applicant the the appellant
is seeking you to fix the affordable
housing percentage at
15% and they haven't applied the policy
compliant approach or some of the other
elements that are set out in the work
that we ask the DS to do and our point
is is that you you can give the weight
that you determine that's applicable to
the financial viability assessment but
the assessment fails in a number of ways
and therefore the point of these
exercises is just is to show you that
15% is the position fixed by gladman but
it's not not a position that should be
fixed because of the different inputs
and changes that could and should be
made to the V the final viability
appraisal uh in particular just while
we're on that paragraph the advice is
that any viability assessment should be
supported by evidence with engagement
with
developers and bable housing providers
or RPS as many people call them but
there's no evidence of that and clearly
that didn't happen anyway because no
developer no house builder in my in my
experience and no toal housing provider
in my experience would start off with a
scheme that provided less than the the
minimum level of floor
space um and they would also have a
scheme which complied with the SM
because they in particular the RPS input
into that
exercise so the reason for the Reas
reason for uh doing the work that we did
was just to show you at high level
stages that we are so early on in the
outline application the scheme will
change and
therefore I don't think you should be
putting a significant level of weight to
the FDA to demonstrate why the
affordable housing should be
15% just take up the correction note
please
and you variously refer in your evidence
to the DSP work as being high level
examples not viability appraisals I
recognize all that just taking it at
face
value if you go to the
updated
table
yes
um the 2016 schar
scheme that generates a very substantial
loss as Against The Benchmark land value
doesn't it uh yes
102 version 102
yeah and so if the inspector considers
it relevant to have regard to the 2016
schar by contrast to the
gladman mix that would suggest it's
heavily
unviable even with
15%
affordable well so and answer that
question the profit level comes out at
14.5% we've just which is under the
range we've just been through the PPG
you need to compare the residualized
land value Against The Benchmark land
value if you do that by reference to to
the 2016
schar which is What sp22 suggests it's
heavily unviable isn't
it it's unviable sir can I go back to
the points I made in my group of
evidence is that the bench land
Benchmark land value at this stage is an
exercise but it's not actually
um it's an exercise to encourage the
land owner to bring their site forward
so that they know what the minimum
amount of money they could get from a
scheme that came forward but at the end
of the day the way that the uh this this
is likely to work is that the um the
house Builder will
pay the value of the site with Planning
Commission gladman will take their
20% or what whatever it is 15 to 20% and
the land owner will end up with
the remainder or 80% of the value of the
S Planning Commission so in reality
although The Benchmark land value is an
exercised that's part of the appraisals
in reality the land owner will do quite
nicely out of this and I think it's I
think it's totally right for the um that
information to be out there because the
public have a right to know where the
public subsidy is going to be going if
it's not going to be going to affordable
housing and therefore the bench The
Benchmark land value is an exercise but
it's not the position that will win
which will be ended we will end up with
when it comes to selling the
site but Mr presumably you agree that
the viability appraisal and assessment
ought to be undertaken consistently with
the pp G yes and and I I'm not I'm not
saying that the BL the bench land land
value is is not important of course it's
important and the and the residual land
value is important if you provide if you
actually input the policy compliant
elements to it which haven't been
undertaken but sorry I interrupt you
this is the analysis that you asked them
to do on the policy what you call the
policy compliant basis this is your case
not
that's right and it shows let me finish
this shows that the 2016 schar miix is
very heavily unviable at
15% it's unviable uh in that there is a
deficit of
2.3 very heavily unviable on the mix
based on the 2016 schar the the um it is
unviable the the reason why that's left
in there and not seeking to hide it is
that also so that um the the appellant
accepted uh a deficit of1 1.7
million um which goes to show why in
reality and mean this is so early on in
the process although it's an important
part in reality this is going to change
over time and even if you took V103
which is obviously still subject of of
consultation and everything else that
you want to take all the other
assumptions that we dispute there's only
a surplus against Benchmark land value
of 600 odd
th000 yes now using the proxy put
forward by Dixon cell that might on
these very high level uh examples and
all of the assumptions that you've added
in generate an additional four
units
1% It goes to show that if you do if you
do yes you're right it goes to show that
different inputs produce different
outcomes um and going back to the point
that the the outcome of 30% the outcome
of 15% is seeking to be fixed now with
such an outline application with with a
proposal which isn't the end
result with a proposal which which will
not be coming into the local Authority
as that detailed Matter St but you see
you must see the point Mr Hester surely
officers totally endorsed the FBA and
said there's no reasonable limits of
viability you've come in at the appeal
stage and said well I want you to relook
at mix type
um and size also I want to depart from
the agreed cost position and go to
thanet when you do that it doesn't
actually demonstrate any improved
viability what it does demonstrate is
that uh fixing viability fixing
affordable housing at this stage is
inappropriate because we haven't
actually got a scheme that is detailed
and is is proposed so my my view as I
expressed earlier and I think more
appropriately uh as a as an opinion is
that 30% should be fixed at this stage
and to enable a scheme that's fully
compliant to be submitted and then
viability if
necessary uh and a scheme which also
would deliver more
units uh might be considered at that
stage it's too early to to to
to allow 15% as the fixed position when
everything else isn't so is the end of
all of this is your
position that despite all of the
evidence showing that the scheme can't
afford
30% that you
can't assess the appropriate percentage
of affordable housing on an outline
scheme I I haven't
assessed that uh no but because the
planning committee were not happy with
the uh justification for Department than
30% I think it's important to be to look
at every other aspect to see whether uh
within reason 30% could be achieved uh
with a scheme a scheme that might
involve more units different inputs and
policy assumptions Etc was that was
tested at the local plan stage to be
considered sound we're we're a year away
from the local plan being adopted and
therefore I think it's quite appropriate
that that because of the High pressing
need for local housing uh I think that
that needs that's an an exercise that
needs to be undertaken it wasn't we the
council is presenting with the gladman
scheme uh and the gladman viability and
that and that's it is it your position
that it's
appropriate to fix a percentage of
affordable housing based on viability on
an outline app application or do you say
that simply inappropriate you can do
that yes and on the evidence
here based on actual viability evidence
you don't put forward any evidence that
reflects any viability sorry any
percentage that reflects any viability
evidence do you no and but I think the
starting point has to be
30% Thank you very much there are all of
my questions thank you Mr Hester thank
you sir
thank you Mr Hester thank you
both now as we've got no supporters of
the
scheme then there's uh I don't there's a
need for me to ask any interested
parties if they got any questions for
you and I think because of
the evidence that you've given I was
going to leave it open in terms of
whether not to ask interested parties if
they had any questions of you but I
don't think because of the evidence
you've given in terms of any differences
between the opposing parties in you that
it's necessary for me to ask anybody
else at this stage if they've got
questions of you I hope that's okay for
everybody but there will be an
opportunity for interested parties of
course to question the appellants
witnesses later
on so that takes us
to reexamination now just in terms of
timing m Mr up Mr Hester rather you've
uh been on for sort of an hour and a
half or so or is it longer uh no it's an
hour and a half or so do you want a
short break before reexamination I
suppose it might depend too on how how
long you think it you will require Mr
uon can I actually ask for a short break
anyway actually I
just um but no in terms of my timing I
we're probably 10 minutes it's just that
it' be helpful to have a break okay I
probably I probably was hoping that
answer as well from my own point of view
so let's let's have a break will uh
let's
see will 10 will 10 minutes be
sufficient is that okay okay yes we will
we will return at uh just past 5 past uh
12 thank
you
right welcome back
everybody it's only you and me at
I did say just passed 1205
so uh okay um thank you everybody
um Mr Upton it is now uh you to U
reexamine Mr Hester
please thanks so just as I said just a
few points obiously very extensive
answers um Mr Hester you're being asked
about the work done by Dixon cell
partnership
um could we go back to their append
their report which is your appendix
B
um and obviously the tables that they
produce towards the end come I think
it's page 11 and
12 there's a section that talks about
latest trial iteration appraisal results
is the is the The Heading yeah um now
you were asked about um the measur US
was against the residual land value
against Benchmark land value um
and I just wanted to check your
understanding about what's had been put
forward by um I was going to say jll
Jason um sort of the the gan's valuation
um because there's a comment here in the
DSP report about the applicants June 21
appraisal uh
2021 including 50% affordable housing um
offer and indicating a residual land
value of of about 3
million uh which would lead to a deficit
Against The Benchmark land value of 1.7
million uh can you help us if if we were
purely looking at that in terms of the
PPG
test um is 15% justifiable well that
that's in the following sentence um that
it would fall within the
15.2% gdv so in the lower end of the
range that's accepted or or suggested as
the norm for um viability Assessments in
the
PG right so um I know in a sense you
covered this but when one looks at what
the three tables then produ three
different scenarios produced what being
called 101 102
103 um
the indicative residual value we can see
there and then the column say Surplus
deficit Against The Benchmark land value
is it the same exercise or anything
different we need to apply to
that
um I really ask you sort of to what
extent is this 1.7 million deficit still
relevant I would be asking
well it's offered isn't it
um I'm not sure whether
that's that figure includes that
um
kind I didn't get the opportunity to
read it when I was being crosson so
um so that that's that's the deficit of
that's that's the difference between
bench lock land value and and residual
land value
2.24 but a profit of
14.6 but but the residual land value is
is 3 million isn't it or it should
be
um sorry
I asked a compound question which is
always a difficulty but it's really
because if if inspector was wanting to
look at the the simple comparison
between Benchmark land value and
residual land value yeah to what extent
is this minus 1.7 million still relevant
to
that um the
result I don't know I don't know what
what you're asking um oh sorry don't
worry it's
it's um what do it say often The Perils
of reexamination that it may be obvious
to me but not to others um can I pick up
the this point about developers profit
then we move aside the well I think the
answer to the that question is that
there's more scope for there's more
money in the pot that's the answer to to
try and deliver more affordable housing
that's how I read it but
um anyway sorry so what was your next
question yeah that's fine thank you um
you may a call your after about um in
terms of what the level of developers
profit that um has been used and we're
taken to the um Samson Grange um
report uh and you may recall you were
looking for a reference as to why the
officers had recommended a the 20% was
used um do you have that bought to hand
yeah well it's the document that we were
taken to was on the but the reason I
keep bending out the way is because my
microphone's on to my screen um which is
where I put it to to optimize you being
able to hear me um yeah so if we go to
that
uh the core document
604 thank
you you were taken to the as was the
blunt point about it saying
3.10 uh the 20% and then he said there
was a reference and explanation that the
officers gave us to why is it later down
the at
312 yeah I I I paraphrased it because I
couldn't find the sentence when under
cross examination but there it is um so
the the last sentence at the bottom of
seven page seven whilst The Profit level
20% is higher than that adopted on other
closes in the district it's important to
consider the current uncertainty around
the property and house building Market
in response to the pandemic um um as
well as the requirements bring
significant strategic Highway
infrastructure forward Kent's position
changed between the initial resolution
to Grant uh and that they would they
their design scheme added another 4
million pounds to the costs so the
officers felt to accept the 20% um on
profit of gdv because of the certain
uncertainty around the the market at the
time so it doesn't it doesn't although
we've still got Co I think it was a
different position a year ago in terms
of not mainly political but you know in
terms of what was known and what wasn't
known about coid and and the impact it
was having uh on the uncertainty as to
as to development and property and the
house house building Market but
certainly since the house builders
weren't were I think at the beginning of
Co in 2020 the house builders weren't
even developing until May I think they
sto between March and May from memory um
my involvement with them um so yeah I
think I think that is a particular
justification for 20% because of the
circumstances at the
time thank you
um was question comes to what extent I
think you partly answered it but as we
stand here in January
um is it just the pandemic that's
changed or is anything else that you
want to
highlight about the
uncertainty well I think I think we're I
think I mean there'll always be an
uncertainy in and um but I think
um I think we're kind we're back to
normal in terms of how we approach this
in terms of the starting position in
17.5
sent um but I think there's such a I
think there's such a pressing need for
affordable housing in the district and
this strategic site is uh is highlighted
to deliver its contribution towards that
um I I think the bar is significantly
high in my view for the for the the
justification on that's required under
sp23
yeah thank you
um and I think then's just a fun point
about this um I suppose the updating
question and you were asked about the
the approach to be taken to the I
suppose construction cost and what um
evidencebased to use from the bics
data
um not necessary to turn up a document
in terms of though the updating that's
occurred uh it's been both in terms of
Revenue and in terms of
costs um to the extent you're able to
help us I mean in terms of the revenue
side what's what's the evidence base
that's used there is it is it medk or is
it something
else that's more local that's AIC that's
athic theyve been using it the sales
values of local and I think DSS set out
in there in my pendent be that they used
local sales uh and I think they also did
a sense check with with the land
registry as well so it makes sense if
you're looking at local sales it equally
makes sense to look at um local cost as
well
right I think that's
um what I need to ask on on that point
um in which case I think uh Mr T there's
nothing fur I wanted to to come back on
and thank
you
sorry I don't know if you have any
further points
um no I don't thank you
um thank you Mr Hester thank you for
your commitment I know it's uh can't be
easy doing cross examination in any
situation but when you're feeling under
the weather it can be more difficult so
thank you for your commitment and
perseverance
right we are now it's quarter past
12 uh so it is
now the turn of where are we uh Mr Mr
cry isn't it uh Mr Williams in terms of
timings
it's quarter 12 I was thinking how long
is
your uh examination chief going to be
and is it sort of probably preferable to
do that before lunch and then we break
for lunch before cross examination after
lunch is that a I think that sensible so
given we've just had a a long first
session but we have just had a
relatively recent break it will keep
things moving if we try and get Mr cter
done before lunch and I think we said
about 45
minutes okay well that sounds like it'll
take us to one o'clock there or there
about so I'm I'm happy with that and
that seems
a a sensible way forward to me and I'm
not sure whether it's just my screen but
I'm not sure whether Mr cry's Yet
presented himself I can see him and good
good morning or good afternoon Mr cry
good afternoon sir right you've appeared
online thank you very much so I think in
terms of documents and for those people
following it as well if it will mostly
be based upon Mr C's proof appendic es
rebuttal and rebuttal
appendices I think helpful to have Mr
Hester's appendices in particular the
Dixon
C material that we've been looking at
this
morning and the
PPG on
liability as well
please
and there may be one or two other
documents but I think they're the ones
that we should take out
now
and
um I should say Mr C I haven't had had a
chance to speak to you obviously since
I've begun cross-examining Mr Hester say
there may be some points you want to add
in in light of um what you've heard
through the cross examination this
morning but can we start please by
looking at your main proof of
evidence in section
two you set out at 2 point
one that this is report prepared by you
you're a charted surveyor and a
registered value uh you're a member of
the Royal Institution of Chartered
Surveyors a director in the affordable
consultancy team at
jll and in
2.2 you set out your experience in
private and public sector and that after
completing your Masters in international
real estate you went to what was Drew at
neat uh you joined the VA in London
thereafter and you set out over the
following paragraphs details of your
experience in this field is that all
correct yes sir
yes for an overview could you turn to
section8
please
and read through your
conclusions certainly in summary jll
undertook a detailed Financial viability
assessment to accompany the planning
application for the scheme this was
reviewed by um tdcs experts DSP and
EMC following discussions it was
accepted that the pred provision of 10%
affordable housing was the maximum
reasonable amount in response to members
concerns the viability was updated in
June 21 to reflect changes in values and
costs on this basis the provision was
increased to 15% affordable housing this
was accepted but the scheme was refused
permission as per the inspector's
directive I've considered the viability
of the scheme of today's values and
costs likewise in order to minimum
minimize the issues to be considered at
the inquiry I've adopted the assumptions
proposed by TDC with the exception of
appropriate Bild cost rate I've
considered this in detail and provided
my opinion as to why I consider the rate
proposed to be unreasonable and my own
opinion having reflected these matters
I've updated the viability assessment
this results in a deficit when
considered against the agreed Benchmark
land value TDC have asserted that the
viil assessment should have been
undertaken by adopting a 2016 sh
compliant mix sham compliant mix in in
response I have considered this which
also results in a deficit against the
agreed Benchmark land value with either
affordable housing mix therefore
provisional 15% affordable housing
Remains the maximum viable level finally
I've also considered the comments uh set
out by S SW their experts PDC and CPR
Kent uh in conclusion I consider the
provision of 15% for to be the maximum
viable thank you and over the page
you've completed a statement of Truth um
in accordance with the RCs code can you
just confirm that the evidence you've
given and will give represents your true
professional opinions that is correct
yes thank you turn back then please to
section three of your
proof and we're not going to we're going
to take the proof as read if that's
acceptable and just Identify some key
points that relate to the various
sections of the proof and I thought in
light Mr Cry of some of Mr Hester's
comments about the extent to which
Common Ground was established through
the application process be helpful if
you just explained the nature of
the um iterative process and the nature
of the reviews that were undertaken by
the council and their advisor through
the course of the
application yes um so jll undertook a um
Financial viability assessment in dated
June
2020 um I think it's been referred to as
sort of the dark arts which which may be
light humored but um it essentially
follows uh standardized inputs of stand
um traditional residual valuation
approach um that's very normal for the
valuation of development land um this
was reviewed by DSP who adopted the same
methodology approach and the vast
majority of assumptions were considered
acceptable um that was in their report
October I believe um 2020 yes um and
that's CD 5.2 Annex 2 which we've been
taken to
previously there at that point they
outlined some some differences of
opinion these were predominantly
accepted so the inclusion of gram rents
for example um and the there was a a
difference in some of the construction
costs the abnormal costs these were
discussed between uh quantity swayers
and later agreed so at the stage of
their report there were some outlying
issues but subsequent to that all
matters were
agreed an update was um later provided
to to uh me Members um looking to
address sort of changes in in values and
costs since the original um assessment
um sort of affected by that time nearly
well pretty much a year later and on
that basis uh the fal housing was
increased to 15% as as I set out my
conclusion thank you and then if we just
look at page
five of your
report um you set out there the analyses
that was presented to members and
um you describe it there as the
previously
agreed
position and then in section four you
present an updated viability
assessment could you just explain
please what you've done by way of
updating and what this exercise now
shows yeah yes so at the um case uh
conference the in inspector asked that
the viable assessment be updated um and
that it we seek to agree both parties
seek to agree that wherever possible and
I've I've endeavored to do that um it
was we proposed to update the values by
by
indexation and cost as well um and um
TDC proposed those which have been in a
draft at the time a draft statement of
Common Ground that's now
signed um and that was accept adopted in
my in my proof um essentially all other
assumptions remain as per the original
agreed as per the agreed position um
they've just been updated um there's
been no changes so I I I run through
each section in my proof setting out
what what the results of those those are
part by part so for example private
housing revenues adopted the agreed
value of 315 pound a square foot 87 P um
and the revenue that that results in um
do do you want me to go through each
each no that's necessary that's not
necessary I think just um asked you sir
to put an asterisk next to
4.5 in the report which deals with build
cost because we'll come back to that
when we're dealing with the rebuttal um
but otherwise you've explained that
effectively the approach is exactly the
same as it was as before the council
it's just been updated and other than
the cost point is what's is there
disagreement as to how such points
should be
updated no those are agreed the the
costs um in in the original final viy
assessment um BCS median cost for State
housing generally default 15E sample
rebase to Kent that's the full um
description um was adopted and I've just
taken the latest position of that it's
DSP or or TDC um I think they've
instructed DSP to do this um have
changed that and adopted a different
cost bases as as other than that there's
no disagreement as to how no appraisal
should be updated from the previous one
and then what I don't want you to go
through the individual assumptions I
would just like you and so you might
tell us this is unnecessary but on page
11 I'd just like you
to take us fairly quickly um
through how you read an appraisal like
this and what does it
show of course so um as I said before
this this um this is standard residual
valuation approach um that's done for
any valuation of of land um you can see
here the the various inputs and outputs
um so the the values have been agreed um
then you so those that leads to the sort
of the total revenue uh you then um move
on to the the various costs um things
like acquisition construction
costs majority of these are all agreed
the only bit being the base cost as we
discussed one of the key key costs will
be the um profit margin that is a in a
residual valuation that is a cost that's
the amount that the developer would seek
to retain um for the risk of undertaking
the scheme that's been been agreed and
that is a cost and then once all those
costs have been deducted from the
revenue one gets to a um residual land
value and and in this case it's 4.3
million and for a viability assessment
one sets that out uh judges that against
The Benchmark land value and that's the
minimum value that a land owner would
accept having regard to existing use
value policy Etc so just a couple of
points arising from that when you refer
to the profit that's towards the bottom
the line that says profit Stoke risk
return Yes um in the appraisal is minus
21 million because it it's a cost is
that an input or an output that's an
input that's a cost deducted as other
cost are
adopted thank you and The Benchmark land
value at
4.74
million is there any disagreement as to
that no that's that's agreed that was
accepted by um Dixon so in the original
in the original assessment it's it's
also very similar I think it's about
8,000 less than the the figure adopted
in the local plan um that that's
accepted and as you can see there
there's a there's a deficit there and at
a very basic level why does comparing
the residual land value Against The
Benchmark land value result in an
assessment of
viability because it shows the the the
value of the proposed scheme with with
all the contributions that that are
proposed against a minimum land price
and if the value of the scheme is not
sufficient to meet that minimum land
price then then it may not be
viable thank you
um so that's your updated position and
just again to be
clear the percentage of affordable
housing in these appraisals is that an
input or an output effectively
um well I suppose it's an iterative
approach it is a it is currently um in
this appraisal it's an input um where
were it lead to lead to a surplus then
then that money those monies would be
reinvested effectively um as and lead to
an increase in affordable housing and
and the up the upset is is true so um
you know D DSP I think refer to sort of
for every additional 400 sorry £140,000
in land value that would pay for an
additional unit so to reach a policy
compliance scheme I think you would need
an additional approximately 9.4 million
in additional land value over and above
the
Benchmark okay thank you very
much um section five was you
anticipating certain alternative
viability assumptions which again I
think we can pass over that um and come
back to those in the context of the
rebuttal if that makes sense yes just
just to say I think following at the
case conference it was requested that we
have the alternative assumptions that we
need test obviously one could test any
number of um theoretical mixes you know
a 4y story Tower block or something you
know which would obviously never get
permission but what one could test it um
and so we requested that that be
provided the only reference we received
was to the shmar in relation to
affordable housing
um the 2016 Shar for the housing um that
that's what what I've done I think there
may have been a reference to 21 local
housing needs assessment um which I
think at the time hadn't been published
I'm not it may have been since um so but
yes that that was my understanding of
what needed to to be assessed from um
the council's position and so just
having made that point on page 16
where we
see the residual appraisal there just
confirm what scheme is that effectively
appraising well it's an alternative mix
assumptions having regard to the the the
2016 schar but only in relation to
affordable housing given the officers uh
clear endorsement of the mix and
specifically relation to maximizing
gdv um and and the the reference to the
affordable housing in relation to schar
I had erroneously mistakenly assumed
that it was only the affordable housing
mix was disputed uh and therefore this
appraisal reflects that um and the
values and results costs Etc flow
through one gets a residual L value of
approximately 4.5 million again a
deficit Against The Benchmark land value
of
4.74 thank you then section six of
your
report you have gone through the
statement of case produced by S
SW and the various points
raised um since then we've had Mr
A's proof of
evidence were there major differences
between Mr R's proof of evidence and the
statement of
case no um no that the they were
essentially the same in the points
they're making I
um the only matter I I noted that was
that Mr or stated in his experience that
he um that he or his firm sells
affordable housing he said in his um
reports that one shouldn't include a fee
for the sale of affordable housing uh
and that seemed to be inconsistent with
his own work um that's the only sort of
particular difference I
noted and it was said I think yesterday
that um you know Mr Rost his view was
that his assumptions were consistent
with appraisals that were routinely
taken that was said by Mr Hans I think
rather than Mr a can you just give us
your view please on
um on that point and whether you agree
that the points put forward by Mr Rost
are points that you would view as being
assumptions routinely made in these
assumptions no I I've gone through each
one um and explain why I disagree
obviously these all items were
considered signif detailed by both
ourselves myself and Dixon so and and
the case of the the cost um
emrc um I think there is some dare I say
SE selective use of no evidence is
presented apart from the evidence that
that we used there is some selective use
of that they REM um s remov certain
evidence because it's in a lower value
location which we noted and considered
and and state as much and then relies
upon evidence it's in higher Valley
location um I I I've set out you where I
disagree and and the reasons
why thank you and so we're in your hands
I mean
obviously Mr or isn't giving evidence I
can't cross-examine him but here is
where Mr cry has effectively presented
his case in response I don't think
there's any point going through it in
any more detail we'll leave it for you
to
assess equally then in section seven
please Mr
culry am I right that you've effective
and done the same in relation to points
made by CPR CPR which again we don't
have a uh specialist proof of evidence
on that matter is there anything you
would like to emphasize in relation to
your
response
um no I I think um you know the matter
of profit sort of is is there and and
we'll come on to again um has has been
disputed as as we know we've heard
that's been been agreed with DSP um
hav't been considered in detail I set
out some further reasoning on on that um
I think in where it's mentioned by a
number of parties everyone has sort of
assumed that one can apply the lowest
profit margin that
automatically um rather than considering
it in the rounds um and Mr H's evidence
didn't he didn't ask DSP to test a 20%
profit margin for example as as I think
was brought up in in evidence
um I think there's also some commentary
against the the review mechanism which
might be dealt with at a later
time okay thank you so can we then put
that document to one side and take up
your rebuttal proof of
evidence
and but go through this in a little bit
more detail you start at well in section
two on page two you raise the question
of
the um planning practice guidance and
the relevance that Mr Hester sees in the
fact that the applicant is gladman who
is known to be a land or site promoter
rather than
a
developer could you just explain please
in in relation to undertaking viability
appraisals um and what the ppj sorry the
PPG says about inputs what's the role of
the identity of the or nature of the
applicant none essentially um what one
on the takes as I described a sort of
applicant blind assessment um the
planning permission runs with the and
whoever owns it um and you know whe
indeed the applican I believe is not the
land land owner um and the you know any
party could come along assuming the site
was to get permission um and deliver the
scheme not just the applicant and
therefore one um does
not you know reflect any sort of special
benefit or or hindrance because of who
the applicant may or may not be these
are stand uh PPG sort of requires
essentially standardized inputs
standardized
approach which which I've done and and
DSP have done as
well and any issues that would bear upon
um how or whether the land is
sold would they fall under the umbrella
of The Benchmark land value or the
residual land
value the the land Val The Benchmark
land value I said represents the minimum
price um that that would that a land
owner would would accept and and it it's
um it sort of therefore reflects the the
land owner's position um it's the
minimum having in regard to existing use
Etc um it is it is applicant blind um I
I don't know the landowner they may
personally be in die financial situation
and would therefore personally May set
to lower figure they may be incredibly
wealthy and personally require a much
larger figure that viability is are
blind to those those issues okay thank
you and the second heading types and
sizes of of
dwellings um I wanted to take out
the DSP note at that stage please within
Mr Hester's
appendices
and you obviously were
listening earlier when I asked a number
of questions of um Mr Hester that
related to these three scenarios so on
page five of the note there's
effectively in terms of mix size and
type we've got the gladman mix size and
type and then there's an S 2016mar based
mix and a 2021 schar based mix with a
adjustment in relation to the size of
some of the two bedroom houses is that
right that's correct yes I think I think
the adjustments to the size has only
been made to uh v102 V103 that's right
yeah like I deal with that later yeah
very shortly but I just wanted
you to help
explain um in terms of the value
consequences changing the mix I'm not so
interested at the moment in the pounds
and Pence outcome but just if we look at
dsp's own
material in terms of mix and tip how do
we ascertain which is the most valuable
planning permission to obtain
yes that's I think that's in my own
proof I included the table but limit it
just to the residual land value to to
make this point the the whether it's
viable or not the most viable scheme
sorry the most valuable scheme is the um
what DSP referred to is the glandon
appraisal um the sort of appellant mix
um that results in the highest residual
land value that is therefore the most
valuable scheme it is there for the the
the scheme that would provide the most
amount of affordable housing
contributions to infrastructure etc etc
um irrespective of viability viability
dictates how much all three mixes
schemes Etc assume the same um
contributions terms of infrastructure
same levels of affordable housing so the
only difference is the is the mix um and
as I say it's the appellant mix is the
most valuable and therefore would Pro
provides the highest provision of
affordable
housing put another way if you put um
the 2016 schar mix or the 2021 schar mix
assessed by DSP into your
appraisals would they justify more than
15% affordable have no I I deal with
that um in my in my reply in detail
thank you and just explain to us on page
11 in the table the final column is
described as being actual
profit but test
against
gdv yes so the profit is a um percentage
of G gdv um the what what they've done
here is they've not set out the profit
used in the appra appraisal itself um
those are the the agreed in inputs at
least in these appraisals there are some
tests that are done at 15% not at 20% as
we've discussed so um they those are at
the agreed um fixed levels what they've
done here is they've taken the Surplus
that they identify and then say well
combining the fixed profit and the
Surplus what is the effective profit
being achieved here and as you can the
results speak for themselves um that's
it's just a sort of matter of
presentation really I I think they call
actual profit what might call it Surplus
total profit Surplus profit super profit
um that sort of thing but it's it's the
Surplus if what the Nick sort of
approach would be to do and and they've
done it in sort of high level ter take
that Surplus provide additional
affordable housing um and then the the
actual profit would go back to the the
the the figures that have been agreed
essentially as that Surplus is is
reinvested um on on the basis of my
figures the the only reason these there
is a surplus is because the change in
Bill cost which true Comm onity okay
thank you so then that deals with the
relative value of different
mixes I want you to deal next with any
alteration in size of units and you deal
with that I think from paragraph
2.2.6 to
2.2.7 of your rebuttal and in table
two can you just explain that exercise
and what it
CHS yes I've I've um adopted the
um size of 70 square meters for the two
beds that were identified as as being
below the a certain level
um I I should say I'm not a qualified
planner therefore whether that's
appropriate or not is beyond my my
expertise but that's what I've done um
the and this essent essentially is the
results the same cost assumptions same
um value assumptions at this stage and
as a result one sees a residual land
value and again again second against
Benchmark land and again a deficit um I
I go on to say and I think I think this
came up in in Mr H's examination that
the relative
value is differs depending on the size
of of a property and the blend the
Blended sales values in per square meter
or per square foot tones those those are
a result of the individual values of
differing units they're not sort of the
value itself and by increasing the the
the size of units that the relative
value in per square foot terms would
would be discounted and and I deal with
that further in tables sort of three and
four um to show that actually in reality
the value would be would be less and
that would have a further impact on the
residual land value I haven't run an
appraisal because I've tried to um
maintain the agreements that have been
essentially reached um tried to minimize
errors of dispute but as a sense check
I've I've done that
thank you very much um
and then if we move
into um well on that point can you just
explain how in case inspector wants to
understand how do your tables three and
four help illustrate the point that you
make that by varying the square meterage
it can lead to a variation in the price
per square meter so in in the um there
are number number of types of three and
four bed homes in the in the appellant
mix and I've and you can see that
they're all in table three they're
ordered in size and these are
effectively the greed unit values and
you can see that the rate per square
foot generally as the total value goes
up because the home is bigger it's worth
more it it's worth more in total um the
agreed unit values are are more but the
relative value in per square foot terms
comes down um and and that sort of
illustrates the points you know but as
as size goes up the value goes up but in
when analyzing in square foot terms it
comes down I've then tried to consider
what the and this obviously isn't isn't
agreed but um but I've then tried to
consider what the value of the two
bedroom houses would be at that size um
and then I've then applied that value to
the mix um the app mix with all the
other agreed values to show what the
total sales value would be and how that
compares to the figure just using the
rate per square foot um before it before
it's
adjusted thank you and just on a point
of detail I'm not sure whether this is
the best point to to pick it up but
there was a suggestion from Mr Hester
that you hadn't actually appraised the
units that were in the
um the
mix because there were for example
houses of more than two stories and you
hadn't assessed those do you remember
that point being made yes there there
are um I think it's 76 three um two are
they three bed houses that are are three
story in the
mix but is it correct that you haven't
appraised the the mix that was actually
put forward have you omitted some of the
larger
properties no we we I we have included
ined the mix I I I think what um M I
don't know if you're referring to the
the size of units that were used in the
local plan assessment and the mix that
we that the appellant is assum I think
it was a specific point that you hadn't
assessed for three story houses within
your appraisal so therefore there might
be some missing Square meterage no we
have there are three there are 76 three
story they described I think I just in
our report them as 2.5 because the third
story well the floor space is there I
think it's the this assumtion would be
it's actually under the eaves um and use
of Dormers Etc so there there are three
story there are three story properties
um with with the larger floor space um I
think that's type I and you can see
there that they're
um2 square meters um 1095 square foot so
those have been done WEA whether 76 is
enough too
many okay thank you very much can turn
then
please sorry I think I blocked out there
can you hear me they just to answer your
question yes three story H houses are
included in the mix okay thank you can
you then turn on to page six of your
rebuttal where you've considered some
additional
considerations yep and the point I
wanted you to pick up really is is first
the point at
2.3.2 which is a general
point I think can you just explain the
point that you're you're making in
paragraph
2.3.2 Yes I think um it's Mr H sort of
assertion that
the that the vi shouldn't be given any
weight that's obviously a planning
matter and be beyond my brief but
because that there's only um because of
the mix that's been assumed and it's
it's not policy compliant it's um I
think as he he describes it um I think
the I think it's uh you know my own
evidence shows that it's not possible to
increase the level of affordable housing
and DSP referred to numbers and I said
earlier the amount that would be needed
um guidance says that one doesn't need
to undertake appraisals just for the
sake of it it's it's quite evident that
one can't achieve 30% um despite dsp's
own evidence saying that they say what
they consider the absolute maximum to be
um they don't reach 30% yet Mr huster is
still maintaining that um the other
point sort of to to make there is that
they and I think this came up in Cross
examination is that they um the maximum
that they say is an additional 5% so
that would take us to 20 but that's only
possible if if you maintain a deficit
that was apparent um when the scheme
went to committee it's not viable it's
it's not the Surplus Over The Benchmark
and and established guidance set out in
the PPG RCS guidance Etc is that one has
to test it against the Benchmark land
value which is agreed and indeed DSP
have done that um and they don't I think
dispute that so so as I as as I say and
I think you brought up in examination
that it's it would only provide using
dsps figures the Surplus would only
result in in you know a couple of units
one to 30 133% something in that order
okay thank you on page seven of your
rebuttal paragraph
2.3.6 there's a point
about
um whether or not increasing floor space
increases value I think this relates
partly to the point that you were making
earlier but can you just explain again
the point that you wanted to make in
relation to um the approach a house
Builder might take yes um Mr Hester said
that one would a house Builder would
seek to sort of Max the size of units um
and and actually that's not true that's
that's quite the opposite in fact they
would certainly seek to increase the
number of un increase the number of
units as much as possible obviously
planning permission where planning
permission allows it I mean this is up
to up to 450 units and has been assessed
as such um but in terms of the size they
would seek to maintain what's the most
efficient size and that's generally the
the smallest as we've discussed the the
highest value higher the larger unit
sizes have a lower rate per square foot
and inversely the smaller units have the
highest rate per square foot and
therefore you'll find that actually most
house builders will seek to to keep the
the sizes as efficient as possible
possible thank you 237 was there
anything else you wanted to say in
relation to Benchmark land
value and profits I I think we generally
covered it I think the only other thing
to say is that it was based on the local
plan you know arguably with the
significant value increases that applied
here you know one could consider is
probably arguably conservative at that
level but but it's an agreed position
and I I don't dispute it so leave it
thank you and
the next heading please local plan
viability
assumptions um this perhaps slightly
more significance following the
questions I asked this morning than when
you wrote your rebuttal when I asked
um Mr
Hester as to we'll come back to the cost
point
but for justification that relate or
documentary justification that relating
to changing the cost bases the only docu
doent that Mr Hester wished to refer to
was the
PPG um at paragraph 8 which refers
to um local plan viability
appraisals and I just wanted you to
explain really um the relationship
between those and what you would expect
to see by way of level of assessment at
a site application
stage certainly um I suppose there's
there's two things here
um one um the as DSP stat in their their
own uh note the um local plan assessment
was done before the explicit link um
that links sort of viability
specifically back to the local plan um
so it wasn't undertaken on that basis
and there is no effectively no direct
well as Master planner but um I'm just
trying to find the relevant bit of their
the Lo was PR examined under the
previous mppf in related to PPG which
did not create the current link
mppf um and so so there wasn't the the
direct link there um obviously
the the FAA submitted seted out the
evidence and and the cost adopted and
and the reasons for those and and
therefore the de departures from the
local plan and those were were accepted
I mean evidently there has been number
of changes the number of units is is
obviously one of those significant costs
Etc um that those were clearly
demonstrated at and accepted at the um
application
stage
um yes I think I think that's and and
and I've maintained those those
assumptions um I think the other thing
is that in in those costs they a number
of different cost bases were used and
considered um at the local plan stage
rather than sort of one at the cost of
all others and I've considered the costs
in some detail but we we'll come back to
that I think the other thing I I go on
to is that in terms of sort of this the
starting point as it were the local plan
there are a number of other differences
um between the local plan assumptions
and the vi and the viability assessment
the agreed position um in particular I
think we've heard mentioned of the
profit margin the local plan assessment
adopted 20% profit margin um that would
increase the cost by approximately 2.9
Million um and professional fees were
also higher at 10% versus the 8% that
was adopted in the viability assessment
agreed and that would also increase the
cost by approximately one and a half
million so I think if one was to take a
purely local plan assessment based appr
appraisal and ignore fva one would have
to be consistent on that basis and apply
all the assumptions rather than
effectively pick and choose is okay
thank you and then on the local plan
assumptions your tables five and six
please on page
nine what do they
demonstrate so um as well as the sort of
minimum size um M as we as we heard as I
said before Mr Hester assumes that the
larger size would lead to a more
valuable scheme a more viable scheme um
and
I I seek to address that here DSP sort
of go into the different sizes of of
units that were used in the local plan
which are generally larger helpfully
there are a number of housing types that
meet those local that's those local plan
um assumptions and therefore what I've
done is I've extracted those and used
those otherwise of the same mix so all
three beds are now you know for the PS
of this exercise are now at the minimum
102 Square meters as was was adopted as
part of the previous mix and this shows
that with those values and you get a
much larger gdv much larger sales
revenue nearly 121 million but you also
get bigger costs because the houses are
a lot bigger and as we just um as a
result in Table Six you can see the
appraisal the land value actually falls
to 2.3 million and there's a significant
deficit of 2.4 million so the there's
a you know uh uh it's it's you know not
viable it's much less viable if you
adopt the much bigger unit sizes that
were adopted in in the local plan okay
thank you and then I just want to move
on to the
DSP um note please and in your
rebuttal at
3.4.1 you introduced the question of of
costs and the change between the BC is
estate
housing um for Kent versus mixed
developments for thanet and that refers
back to your proof of evidence at
paragraph
4.5 and could you first of all just give
us
um if you could just explain really why
um
originally um it was agreed that the
bcis for kemp was the appropriate basis
and what evidence there is of
change so um as I I said earlier the the
original assessment um adopted costs in
line with bcis that's the building cost
information service um which collects
data on on construction of various
different property types um the median
for um the State housing generally and
the sample is based on a default 15-year
sample size rebase to Kent that was
considered by specialist quantity
surveyors along with the costs for
garages abnormals externals etc etc um
emrc that um on behalf of the council
and they they say was it was considered
reasonable and they've adopted that um
and I've maintained that I've now just
adopted the latest the latest version at
the date dat of my
proof
um as as we've sort of heard TDC has
changed that to the five years sample
rebased of thanet um and in um because
that was in the that was discussed
before proof i' I've considered that um
in my proof of evidence so perhaps I
should go go through that just the main
point really yeah okay
um
fine um so I mean I think well first of
all that it was accepted by specialist
quantity surveyors are surveyors who are
experienced in the cost of
constructing properties you know new
build developments you know um they're
their own specialist advisors and
they've accept accepted and adopted that
um the the evidence based for local plan
shows that they DSP as you know assumed
assess considered number of different
cost bases not only the one adopted I
mean specifically with um some other
points
the um I suppose one of the Bigg
differences is the Lo is the location
factor uh the point that the
location the the cost for sort thanet
are comprised of only 15 schemes which
is a very very small sample size and and
any sort of one issue with one it would
greatly distort those figures um whereas
for K it's 257 and therefore I can I
consider that to be a much more reliable
basis on which to to base the costs um
I've also had a look at neighboring um
districts of can Mar Dover which are 111
110 location factors as opposed to 109
so they're actually higher than than
than the Kent figures but they're much
closer to it and I think that that's a
useful sense check um than it has a
location fact of
106 um they also have quite small um
sample sizes obviously in their 25 and
20 schemes respectively uh so again I
think the Kent is more useful than say
just adopting you know a neighboring
sort of an average of the the three for
example um but it's a useful sense check
um some other bits um just um yes so the
previously agreed rate um as we as is
agreed the other costs have been inp up
if one were to adopt the higher the the
cost rate previously agreed and apply
the same indexation to that one would
result in a cost of
13460 per square foot much higher than
TDC now Advocate um and uh higher than
I've main adopted and based on the
previously agreed
position um I set out in a table of
comparison between all the different
cost bases
um and which is on page nine of my my
proof you've got the median cost the
mean cost and you'll see that that the
cost of do of firmly in in the middle
well lower middle when you consider the
mean um yes the RS go on to describe
sort of the use of mean and median and
indeed actually recommend the mean in
all cases the mean is actually high but
again I've tried to be consistent with
what was done before and I've maintained
the previously greed basis I've not
departed from that so this is my costs
are just an
update
um yeah and you'll recall when I asked
um Mr Hester for you written suggestion
that the Kent faces was was
inappropriate the document he referred
to was the
PPG just for completeness is there
anything that you're aware of in the PPG
that would suggest taking the thanet
crost base rather than the Kent cost
base no it it doesn't go into that level
of detail they just it's what's most
appropriate most reasonable and I
consider the cost that the previously
been considered by specials quantities
of a it's based on a better sample size
to to be more
appropriate thank you and final point
back to your rebuttal please at
paragraph
3.7 and your take La
eight can you just
explain what exercise has there been
undertaken and what it
shows so I've taken the um so the sort
of the first line appellant mix V and
I've I've I've compared it to the dsps
appraisals free so that's that their
referen is v101 I've updated the
appraisal I've shown the residual land
value and then the Surplus or deficit
Against The Benchmark as may be the case
um we've already discussed that one
that's that's early odd in my reply um
I've also then tested the the mixes um
and and it's no surprise that they have
lower values as they did dsps appraisal
they have lower values in mind um they
result in a residual land value in the
case of um the 2016 Sharma mix a
negative land value so the land land
owner would have to pay the developer to
to take on the site um and which
obviously wouldn't happen it wouldn't be
delivered and the 2021 schar mix which
results in a land value of 2.5 million
and a deficit of 2.2 million and so when
you look at the appraisals in the round
uh what in your view does it say as to
the ability of the scheme on the comp
having regard to the iterative mix is
put forward by Mr Hester what does it
say to the ability of the scheme to
carry more than 15% affordable housing
there's no evidence that's been
presented that any scheme can provide
more than 15% affordable housing and
that's the maximum reason when indeed
that the mix assumed and relied upon is
the most viable most valuable and
therefore would provide um the most
affordable housing and and if one were
to be it will be doubt reserved matters
I appreciate but if if a Shar compliant
sort of only mix
was forced then then it might result in
a lower
provision thank you you have your
conclusions on section four I don't ask
you to read them out but is there
anything you would like to add by way of
evidence in
Chief um I I think the
only I think the only thing um sort of
couple points I think some some St have
been that only one appraisal has been
presented that that's not the case with
we present there was a um obviously a
scheme appraisal in in the submission
we've we've asked for what other scheme
what the appraisal should be tested and
tried best to um you know I've
considered that in my proof in my reply
I've considered a number of different
appraisals so we have tested a number of
different I have tested a number of
different assumptions Etc so that that's
not the case that there is only one
um dealt with the provision of um
policy compliant it's it's it's evident
that the 15% is the maximum there's no
need to provide a 30%
appraisal and guidance says one doesn't
need
to just take appraisals for the sake of
them when when the evidence is is
clear thank you very much Mr G thank you
very much
sir thank you um thank you Mr cry just
aware of the time we are of
probably time but just one question from
me and I mate in terms of profit margins
I probably it's probably is somewhere in
the evidence what is the specific has
been discussion or evidence given on the
margins being between generally between
15 and 20% what's the specific reasons
for the choice of
17.5% for this scheme so I think there's
that was considered in in my original um
report and it was considered by DSP at
some length um you know it it reflects
sort of the balance of risk in relation
to the private housing if FW housing is
a much lower 6% of forw housing on the
on the basis that that would be sold to
a registered provider Housing
Association and therefore as much it's
less risky um and and it sort of
reflects the level of risk of a scheme
of this nature there are you know
significant abnormal cost issues with
site topography Etc which do make it
challenging it's it's it may not be at
the largest scheme in terms of strategic
sits but it is a large large scheme um
and and therefore has complications
likely to go go through ups and downs in
terms of the market and and a developer
will want a sufficient return to take
all those those risks into account so
that that's been considered and and as a
result of of those issues considered
that 7 half% that sits within an
appropriate range neither the the
highest figure that was adopted in the
local plan assessment or or as we heard
in relation to
gra an application I think Samson gra
think it was or indeed the lowest figure
um because that would be considered too
low as DSP quite clearly
State okay thank you uh that's my only
question at this stage so I think it's
now time to adjourn for lunch after
lunch we will continue on with obviously
cross- examination of yourself by Mr
Upton Mr Upton just sort of without
obviously pinning you down to it how
long do you expect
require for your cross
examination thanks so I'm I'm hoping we
can get through it at about an hour
obviously depends how things go
unsurprisingly cord and I may not agree
on many things um but uh I think it's
that's that's just a rough estimate
um okay um so if
we just thinking forward after that
there'll then be reexamination and then
Mr B ball which will obviously we'll get
we'll get the opportunity to get to Mr
ball this afternoon and hopefully with a
good wind complete with Mr Ball but
we'll have to see how that that goes um
okay we will adjourn for lunch it's
given we're sort of given this sort of
time constraint is everyone going to be
happy with a slightly shorter lunch
break 45 minutes I don't normally like
breaking my one hour rule but maybe just
to save some time in this case is that
okay for all the
parties that's fine with me
sir okay good okay in that case we'll
adjourn for lunch and we will return at
2 o'clock thank
you
good after afternoon it's 2:00 and it's
time to
recommence looks as though
everybody is back from lunch so before
we move on with the cross
examination of Mr cry is there any
housekeeping matters anybody wishes to
raise I've got
none nothing from us thank you
sir no okay in that case uh it's over to
you Mr Upton to cross-examine Mr cry do
you want to also introduce your uh
drawings and things not drawings
documents rather that you want to refer
to I've hopefully this all be um what
what's going to cover the obviously I
have the proof and the the rustal
hopefully to hand um and I was thinking
I wanted to look at the um June 2020
initial report which we have cd 110 it
was the first um assessment there's then
the update which uh I think best
reference is CD 222 which is a June 2021
document uh and obviously the DSP um
report in the pendic beard Mr Hester's
evidence and um terms of plans um like
has to the parameter plan and
development framework plan I think be
useful um right what are the uh remind
me of the core document number if you've
got it for
the plan yeah the
um
the sorry I've got an A4 version but
it's just too small so that I printed
off of my limited printer but I think if
I can get it on my screen it'll be a lot
bigger yeah it's the one that where we
have unfortunately the website got it as
a version B where actually it's version
C when you go through um and is that um
it's I think you'll find it as
cd28 208 parameter plan okay yeah and
what was the other
plan and then the other one is the I
suppose I think for our purpose is um
probably doesn't matter which version um
because I know there's an update but the
development framework plan um oh yeah
it's a
207 yes let's see if
that's yeah it's the revision J which
is hopefully um sufficient in that in
those purposes
um yes I should remember they're next
door to each other
the committee reports you refer to just
to make sure I've got all those I've got
the committee report
[Music]
from July
2020 so it's the appraisal assessments
um that jll had done
so going back to there so it's part of
the appellant documentation so 1.10 is
the 2020 initial assessment with its
appendices and then we have I think is
2.22 the June 2021 update I think people
may have obviously in different places
but that's those are the
references hopefully
they'll will'll all end up in the same
document when needed and the core
document number for the update one again
sorry I'm just bit 222
there entirely clear the difference
between 21 and 22 but
um right
um that's say ah so it's probably 20
maybe it's 21 because that's the jll
letter with appendices is that what you
were referring to yeah sorry
unfortunately the the CD reference has
all the twos in it but the actual date
of the document is uh 26 of May
2021 but our core document reference is
2.22 just
um is that not dat to 7th of June sorry
7th of June what I'm talking about I've
exactly what it is I've that's okay um
oh 7th of June 21 uh letter starting
dear
Robert yes yeah okay thank you that's I
I've got that I'm the I think
yeah sorry to
inter no no thank you um for some reason
I've managed to print off what I thought
was a copy which has a 26 of May date on
it but um I think it's the same document
I will
just I don't think there's
any change anyway long as we have that I
was going to start with that document
fortunately so now we've identified it
uh so good afternoon Mr C could can I
just check your involvement with um
obviously the viability side in in this
matter because uh this is the letter um
as we know it's June of
2021 um signed by you yes uh addressed
to Robert black of gladman yes um and as
you say you you had provided just at the
beginning of this this letter
introduction background a financial
viability assessment dated in June
2020 um and obviously summarize what's
in that and then as you say updated
assumptions um have Arisen after the
April 2021
committee uh and you then set out the
obvious the consequences but as I said
just wanted to check your
um as status in in the debate so to
speak um
the recommendations about what the
particular provision of affordable
housing percentage can be um very much
sort of in your name you don't seem to
be saying I advise you to consider so
was it was it essentially your decision
what to offer or or how does it work no
that that was um by by the applicant um
I just set out sort of what what's been
done um right thank you um because
obviously as we can see here it's a
useful
summary um that the initial assessment
in June of
2020 the second paragraph is you
record um a scheme with 10%
provision uh was assessed and the
residual land value was below the
Benchmark land value um
now and then we get
the um the update assumptions so this is
now looking at it in June
2021 uh and it's obviously you've looked
at it again but I just want to go to the
second page in the top of bit because
this sort of particularly deals with the
point so based upon the above we have
calculated the scheme would provide an
additional 5% affordable housing 15%
overall while maintaining a similar rlv
which equates to about 67 as you know 68
I think in the end of full units and
we've appended a summary um that's what
I want to check is that maintaining a
similar residual land value basically
and I think your dependency show that
the residual land value figure in um
June 2021 is basically the same sort of
minus 1.7 million that it was in um June
of 2020 isn't it it's sort of that's
correct yeah so when you talk about a
similar residual land value that's the
sort of figure you had in mind yeah yes
yeah what I want to check is um in terms
of the policy test and what the
inspector needs to look at we're meant
to look at the bench the residual land
residual land value as it compares to
the Benchmark land value yes uh and it
normally should sort of Break Even to be
able to justify a percentage of
housing but here and I don't know if
it's on your Authority or glam's
authority but certainly clearly what put
forward there is a percentage all
housing put forward on the basis that
um a residual land value 1.7 million
less than the Benchmark land value uh
provides the level of affordable housing
that um can be
justified now can we just unpack that a
couple of questions right first thing
that that's not the PPG test is it nor
sort of is the residual land value
greater than the Benchmark land value
yes and I think I mean going going to
your point in my experience there's nor
your deficit because if there's a
surplus then then there'd be more
affordable housing um or or there would
be no viability because you'd be there'
been an Neal one um so so in my
experience there is is always a deficit
but but yes it is against the benar land
value that's whether this whether the
scheme is is can viably provide
additional
contributions because just this may not
be for you but on the basis of these
figures uh it would have been
plausible to say we can't provide 10%
that's that's the logic of it isn't
it I I think I I don't recall when I cut
um I'd have to look but I think on the
basis of those
figures the 10% yes would still fall
below the
Benchmark um however the the applicant
you know wish to increase their offer to
15% on the basis of the
improvements to say comes in stages
because as of June
2020 it's minus 1.7 million in terms of
the
comparison but they prepared to offer
10% come to uh June
2021 yeah the with the
same similar I suppose you say similar
residual land value difference of one
minus 1.7 million they're offering
15% um but a matter of the time
difference because you say that the 10%
calculation becomes much more positive
in 2021 but that wasn't relied upon that
fair yes it becomes it become it's it's
it's certainly improved um with the
passage of time um and and that's what
that se the appellant seek to address
but I
think sorry you momentarily froze there
just be sorry and and I think that's
what the appellant sort of um well the
applican as they then were um sought to
sort to address and they increased the
affordable
provision by similar Amounts is it gone
on but is it it's a point that um Dix s
pick up in their latest
report that with a sort of negative
comparison of 1.7
million that's still within the range of
15 to 20 20% if one does sort of the
backward calculation almost and as they
say it's just inside the
15% uh and and would be about 15.2%
compared to C
value
uh that's that's correct isn't it I mean
I need no I think on their figures it
may be but of course they've reduced
sorry just so you have the source it's
page 11 before they go into their
figures they just do an analysis all
minus 1.7 million
and say that that would actually be the
equivalent of assuming a developers
profit of
15.2% on the gross development
value sorry yes if you want sorry the
table I see now thank you yeah sorry
just so just so you know I suppose it is
fair just to go to the document itself
in appendix B of mrpr the Dixon cell
partnership document and then at page 11
just before you get to the tables this
this paragraph about how one might
approach the residual land value and and
highlighted in red is the minus 1.7
million and how that relates if you were
to do a relationship to the profit as
they have done obviously later on as
well that it would be equiv to
15.2% so that's the refence they say
that I don't I don't quite know how they
how they get to that I've not tested
that I don't okay well well thank you um
if you haven't it's lower than the
profit that's been agreed and is
considered viable but yes no I mean this
is what I obviously there two issues
arising here one is the level of profit
I'll come back to that because as you
know that's an issue but in terms of
what is the fundamental comparison
that's prepared to be accepted on this
site both in June 2020 and in June
2021 a negative figure of 1.7 million
was accepted
as acceptable to I say the owner and the
planning consultants and the
experts for this
site well it was the test was whether um
you know the the offer was um or the
offer is the right the the submitted
level of affordable housing was 10% at
that time whether it was viable or not
you know was considered in my my
assessment and dsp's report and and at
that stage it was shown that there was a
deficit and therefore was not viable to
increase the provision of affordable
housing above the above I mean it might
be this is I
say a planning question but obviously
relevant to the work you do and how the
RCs advises you that if you're to to
assess viability you're
assessing B value uh and it doesn't say
in the guidance um you can be minus 1.7
million unless as an owner you're you're
prepared to accept a lesser profit I
mean that's that's the logic isn't it I
I think that's I mean I suppose that's
the the logic but we're there to to
provide an assessment not to dictate
what the owner does or doesn't do um you
know that that's the applicant because
they may not be the same um the you know
that as I say there are it's quite
common for there to be a deficit against
the thing I mean it'd be rather unusual
and I've I mean maybe I I've never done
this but perhaps I I ought to say this
is the technical level at which it's
viable you know and drop it but I I
don't you know I'm not sure if that's
what you're suggesting I should have
done should have lower you know the
application was for what it was for and
that was I was exploring what what your
role was here in the sense yeah because
um if you were just following well I
supposed kind of unpack it if you were
just following the RS guidance you would
just do the residual land value against
Benchmark land value and leave the
planners to draw the conclusions from it
but you didn't stop did you you said and
with that similar residual and value an
additional 5% is possible so so I did do
that you've got the appraisal with the
um with the 10% FAL housing and then and
then said you know what what we then did
I then did um which is you know increase
the level affordable housing similar
amount that gone up so that's those were
the sort of the mechanics of what I'd
done just in the same way that DSP have
been instru to to test 15% even though
they're quite categorical they don't
believe that's the right answer you know
ESS essentially you know I'm presenting
that or at that in that
letter can I put it this way we look at
your letter um and that paragraph it
says I'll just read it again and then
ask the questions based upon the above
we have calculated that the scheme would
provide an additional 5% FAL housing
whil maintaining a similar residual land
value yes um
now it appears
that that those are your instructions
that a similar residual land value is
what should be
you yes okay so it's fair isn't it that
that's how the inspector should approach
this particular site that that residual
land value figure is is the so to speak
The Benchmark for what's fair here well
no the The Benchmark has been clearly
established
uh sorry I've used the wrong word
Benchmark sorry um because you're quite
right Benchmark land valy is a different
thing can I ask the question without
using the word
Benchmark um so just one moment the text
I suppose just let me ask the question
because I realized I MBL It Up by using
the word Benchmark when I I shouldn't do
um the question is this is that in terms
of this site and what is seen as
acceptable in terms of assessing what
level of affordable housing could be
provided the level of residual land
value is it's taken as a similar figure
of minus 1.7 million that's the the
figure that one should bear in
mind no the um guidance planning
guidance is is quite clear RCS guidance
is quite clear that The Benchmark land
value is the relevant test against which
the residual land value is compared um
when undertaking an independent
assessment as I've done I mean my
but but you see you don't make the point
do you in your any of your reports that
this similar residual land value is the
wrong figure to use so one assumes don't
you that you've put it forward as that
is the reasonable figure to use and to
bear in mind uh no my reports Clearly
say one test it against the Benchmark
land Valley we went through my evidence
and I I tested all the appraises Against
The Benchmark land valy so I was quite
clear that that's that's the approach
that should be adopted that was the
approach that was adopted at the
application stage in the viability
assessment Dix and sales review um all
subsequent uh you know appraisals have
been tested against bench land valy
that's the correct approach is
established in in guidance not not a
previous
result but I'll ask it one more time in
a slight different way if if another
group of Consultants came forward on
this site and the council said to them
are actually
the residual land value should be one
you should use is minus 1.7 million they
will turn around and say what you're
saying well that's not what the guidance
says but um that's not what your team
have done is it you you've put forward a
scheme on the basis to be
considered with residual land value that
can be
accepted of being 1.7 million below
Benchmark land value we we've shown what
the at the time the viability of that
scheme with
15% um and and sort of targeting I
suppose the pre previous level as we as
instructed um but that's but the the
viability guidance is quite clear that
one tests The Benchmark land value con
considers whether there's any additional
you know Improvement to be made the
offer the the um provision of affordable
housing The Proposal was in was
increased at that stage to 15% and
that's what I was asked to to to show
and to
test indeed
but sorry and and I'm aware of earlier
you put forward 10% as as the initial
assessment but I understand see if I got
this right in terms of making these
assessments it's a slightly iterative
process and that you're testing the
level of affordable housing and if you
put in 10% that changes certain of the
other figures whereas you put in 15 so
you you have to obviously check back um
but if you're right about the guidance
there was no justification for offering
10% was
there well I think the the viab assment
just shows what the level is viable not
what there are many proposals that
provide above um VI technical viable
levels of affordable housing and in fact
it' be hard pressed to to not do that
because as I said before if there was a
surplus that would be need to be
reinvested into provide more affordable
housing so you know I think I think the
contrary is is quite the case um you
know you're right there is an iterative
process we we did test that I can't I
can't remember what the technical at the
application stage would have been based
on you know um the fbaa that was
undertaken it would have been below 10%
I don't think it would have been been
zero but a decision was taken by the
applicant on the base of those numbers
to to provide 10% at that time do do you
know
why um
no not explicitly I mean I imagine
because sort of
88.7% you know I I presume a question of
balance I'm not sure it's I think it's
beyond beyond me I'm not
sure okay I say may be a question for
you and maybe others can pick it up um
but in terms then of what one does uh
can I just check in the June
2021 document um
the work that you were doing then to
compare I suppose the figures one year
on yeah the updated assumption section
of this letter is a useful
summary um you do in terms of heist
prices you weren't doing the exercise of
looking at values uh within the sanit
area you basically took an in index and
applied that is that so we we took an
index that
um yeah I took an index um that's based
on Nationwide um in in the latest um
that I think was proposed back and in
the um proposed to use the local the
land registry index post to Nationwide
um which which we've you know adopted
and accepted that was in relation to
the the evidence now before us but yes
at that stage it was it was an index and
in relation to the bill cost it was um
yes also indexed as as has been the case
in relation to
the infrastructure etc etc yeah and it's
fair to say one can see I think it was
it's plus 6% in terms of value and plus
3% in terms of cost um yep
and that's obviously reflects your
figures but then when we move from June
2021 to November so a matter of a few
months quite a dramatic change again hav
we in terms of uh let's I could use the
word inflation but that be wrong in
terms of increase um both in terms of
the highest prices and in terms of build
cost yes I suppose an unprecedented time
I mean in relation to the values we the
indices has changed the Nationwide index
think similar sort of period so June to
um to I think it be yeah Q Q2 to Q3 was
um was more like two something but but
um s you know adopted the like um local
land registry rates and and and in order
to to try and reach agreement as as
director B inspector to minimize areas
of disagreement have adopted those um
the build cost the same indices has been
used um and that is much higher I think
that is just reflective of the
unprecedented nature of cost inflation
construction cost inflation particularly
mean obviously the we all know about
inflation generally and you know gas
prices Etc but the construction cost
inflation is is unprecedented at the
moment um and and that's reflected in
the industries
yeah but and I I'll put this in the
broad way to start with the um increase
in Bild costs for thanet have not been
they would be for somewhere like 7even o
or midkent have they I mean the if
you're seeking to build something in
thanet you're not faced with that level
of cost increase you would be for
midkent no I think they're they're on a
like for light basis so they they are
the same that that's a good point
because by changing it I mean actually
um DSP effectively applied a reduction
in Bill cost at a time of great
inflation and that's the point I'm
making my in my evidence no but this
this is this is a scene across the
market of all schemes I mean obviously
some schemes will be differently
affected depending on the on on what
elements are are you know Timber I'm not
quantity survey but I think Timber is
quite quite badly affected quite high
cost um labor you know these costs are
you know applied acoss the ball um um
whether it's 7 Oaks whether it's London
whether it's
Yorkshire um the private housing index
you know that there a big big increase
in construction
costs but it's if one is to assess as on
a more sight specific
bases um if we're taking values from the
thanet
area proba we should be taking build
costs from the thanet area as well we're
not applying mid
increases in val you know that you have
in say 7 eggs to the revenue side so why
are you increasing it on the cost side
well well as I say that they um you know
we we did we did we use the outer I use
the outer Southeast index at that stage
and I consider that again when and that
shows a lower increase than than ther
have adopted um as I say I mean the
difference there is the sample size for
land registry um I think is about 3,000
sales a month so it's it's vast uh in
comparison to 15 uh schemes that BCS has
for for thanet um I think that you know
I've gone into that in some detail my
evidence so I think they're very
different I mean also you know
construction terms that a house Builder
doesn't operates at least a regional
level if not in some cases a national
level and so their costs are you
procurement may be probably outside of
Ken necessarily so um I think you're
unlikely to see significant
differences can I just go back to this
it's not how big your sample is it's
whether you have a is number question
first and you okay sorry do apologize in
terms of looking at the statistics you
can have 3,000 results of actually all
the same level it doesn't and after
you've had the first 15 it doesn't tell
you anymore does it as long as you've
got sufficient basic information you can
draw conclusions from the 15 schemes
can't
you but the the the
the point problem with 15 schemes is any
variation in that will be greatly
distorted by any one party it will have
a and and by having a larger sample size
you you deal with that issue that it's
it's significantly more reliable and
it's a basic Tenon of statistic so the
you know is a key key the S size is a
key element um
so yeah before but sorry I suppose I I
made it clear that in terms of trying to
draw conclusions from a set of data you
need to satisfy that it's sufficiently
significant or there are enough
results and in C like put it as in
theory in 1 second 15 results of schemes
such as this you other housing schemes
would be sufficient wouldn't it well I I
think when using a broad sort of data
set and without analyzing it in depth
you know that and I'm not qualified to
do that I'm not con of there then and
and making appropriate adjustment you
know one could get into that level of
detail but when you using a broad data
set you know one has to therefore use
the the one with the the
some and applying it in the way that it
has been I I just think it's not
reliable and is not consistent with what
was done what was agreed what was
considered by um the council's quantity
surveyors um at you know at some depth
and indeed you know we talked about the
cost increases and the cost now reported
to be you know there's no step back and
look the costs that now reported to be
appropriate are less than what was you
know previously agreed
so yeah I just failed to sorry but
looking at the sort of price increase
isn't it that um in increasing as time
goes on though we though you may be able
to receive more Revenue the cost will
also change yes and that comparative
figure is important isn't it you ought
to really be comparing like would like
if revenues in thanet have increased
then cost for thanet going to be the
most relevant set of data aren't they no
I think the relevance is about getting
the right set of data um and and I don't
believe that the BCS you know rate
restricted to a fiveyear sample for
thanner is is appropriate yeah can I can
I just I understand the difference um
but can I just check uh it's a matter of
detail really in the June 2021 you
referred to using indices for the outer
Southeast yes in most recent robust we
talk about midkent figures
um now maybe not comparing like with
like here but could could you just
explain the difference between those two
terminologies what is out of Southeast
and what is midkent or is it so out of
Southeast is the um Nationwide um index
it has a sort of inner Southeast which
um sort of the areas of effectively sort
of London commut about type location so
you know I think sevenos might be an
example sari you know those sort of
locations which um and and then you've
got the out out Southeast still
Southeast England but you know slightly
further out um in ter I don't recall
referring to Mid Kent explicitly um not
in my evidence um I mean there is a
location factor for for Kent um there is
I don't there is no location factor in
BCS terms for midkent or there's
location factors for different districts
and I go on to
consider thanet and then the neighboring
districts of um you know can in DOA
which are which are higher than than
even the Kent location F yeah so be a
Mis Mis grafting or or mis phras
phraseology from myself I do no it was
helpful to have you just to explain when
was referring to the different sets of
data what how they use it and thank you
for clarifying it uh because I it is
just I suppose the one question that
arises from Mr A's work that he clearly
has also used um is the relevant cost
base um given his experience of the
thanet area um and also looked at areas
highest pricing values within thanis I
mean he's he's comparing like with like
isn't he well he's comparing those he's
well one isn't comparing the the two one
doesn't use one again against the other
the the cost basis isn't derived that
because values have increased and the
values have been increased because the
costs have increased they are um I
suppose they are somewhat one could
argue in a wider economic sense inter
related you know if if yeah but but
they're not they are their their own
things you know values go up and cost
can come down and the inverse can also
happen so so he using thanet a you know
data from the thanet but I've I've
addressed that I think it's the right
where it comes from is obviously
material but it's the it's whether it's
you know sufficient or not and and as
I've explained the the sample size of
local land registry data is is 3,000
sales I think a month when I looked at
it um you know versus 15 units on the
cost side if there were 3,000 schemes in
planet that were being you know assessed
you know i' I take a very different line
yeah they I understand your point but
just on this point about 3,000 sales
across Kent you're going to then be no
in thanet sorry the sales in thanet yeah
I'm talking about thanet right okay
thank you there's sufficient there's
sufficient data within land land reg I
mean land Reg has the benefit that
legally every sale has to go to to them
and therefore they have the benefit of
of collecting that
data yes we have a wider a very good
data sample size
but it's the same point in a way but the
you don't then take you don't expand
your sample of the revenue um side in
terms of increase in high prices to
include places like 7x do well I well I
did because I I I I considered the um
the Nationwide alter uh uh Southeast as
we used before that showed a lower um
increase in in values over over the
period since this letter and and the
evidence but as I said before the in we
we put I put that industy forward um
thanet came back with the land registry
considered that a good you know data set
Etc and considered that that was
appropriate and wanted to reach reach
agreement minimize the area of dispute
um and and therefore you know accepted
that adopted done okay but in terms then
of what the figures produced in um the
DSP um appendix uh and and your
appraisals the difference is that though
you have both used the same increase in
Revenue they have used a lesser increase
in the bics costs compared to you that's
essentially the why you've come up with
different they've actually reduced the
bill bill cost but I believe yes but yes
that that that is um it in in relation
to the first apprais or the appellant
mix then that's the only difference yes
yeah I that's the same it's it's
although I think that I mean to in my
I've now addressed the 70 square meters
unit size which I don't believe gladman
did being that being the appellant mix
the important thing is trying to have
like for like in what is we've called
v101 just to try and keep the variables
differ limited and in my evidence my
proof as opposed to my reply sorry then
then that they are like for like and the
only difference is is the bill cost yes
yeah no because I wanted to ask about
the
um I suppose the assumptions we make
about the scheme that you are asked to
assess and for these purposes could we
go to your um assessment uh report the
first one that was done uh and that's I
think for our reference Co document 1.10
but it's the June 202
um
report uh and let's just make sure I've
got the right document in front of me as
well
um turns out it's going to be easier to
go through
the the hazards of working from home
someone's trying to answer the do I'm
going to have to ignore um
the report starts off and
the um initial sections about your
assumptions and I want to just start
there and it's the beginning therefore
of the main report
introduction do do you have a page
number um page number it will be page
three on the on yes on the bottom y sir
in overview report structure and they
say key information relied upon
yeah uh and here you say we have been
provided with and relied upon the
following key information yeah and first
thing is accommodation schedule so the
accommodation schedule is not your work
is that
right that that's correct that's not my
work that was provided to so okay and
then you're also provided with bcis cost
estimates um costs about additional
costs in section
106 um and then just checking on the
plans one's a location plan that's just
simply where the site is I presume it's
not more than that but the develop
framework plan you've given a July
date do you know what revision of that
document you were looking at I I don't
sorry
um because obviously the early days July
199 2019 um for the different on to
revision M I think now but uh okay not
worry because that's obviously the
starting point can I then go through the
report um
to your
appendices uh if people have got
electronic
copies uh I wanted to go to appendix 2
and
electronically oh damn I'm on the
website so that doesn't help I should
get it down
um this is the hazard of doing things
electronic my nice electronic copy
marked up is disappeared into what
screen I do not know but appendix 2 will
be page 37 electronically it says
accommodation schedule
yeah and then there's a blank page and
then there's a table which is
electronically uh page 39 and I'm hoping
we've then got a table that says
schedule of accommodation Land north and
south of shoton Road Margate dated June
2020 yeah yes y now from what I
understand this is what you were handed
it's not something you you had a input
into is that right U yes it was I that's
what we were provided we we asked for
you know is there is there a scheme
accommodation details um yep yeah
um one of the points made in I think
it's the RS guidance that one she seek
to optimize the value on a
site you're not the right person to ask
about that then because you've been
given this schedule you haven't said Con
considered it I mean
I've had another scheme where um been
told we just Ed the schar in that
district and I've said well that's not
an optimized scheme it's going to you
know massively underd deliver the
affordable housing that's going to be
pointed out by the other side and
they'll say you wouldn't deliver that
scheme in that location you should do
something else but this scheme is
optimized and and that's you know
evident from dsp's appraisals it's the
most valuable scheme it's EV from my
appraisals it's the most valuable scheme
so
you know it is
optimized that's what I want to unpack
because you didn't when you received it
in June 2020 say is this the optimized
scheme you just assumed it was that I
assume no we did we did consider
consider it in the sense of you know
look at it and then run values against
it and consider you know obviously
there's a balance between and and when
you considered it you came up with a
negative residual land value so what
Earth did you do
then I no I think we still had a
positive land value I think we just had
a may have had a deficit which which as
I say is not unusual but as I say this
is you know that there's a balance
between what is the most valuable um you
know one can't just deliver 450 studio
apartments I don't think the local
Authority would would give permission
for that um you know that might have the
highest value but it may not be um in
planning terms so there's a balance
between that and the mix but as I say
this was you know looking against the
the mix and other things this is the you
know optimal yeah but just to be in
terms of the sequence you
didn't Point sorry you were not asked to
assess a scheme that would comply with
the studio housing market assessment the
schar 2016 that's not that wasn't part
of your
role U no we were not not explicitly no
we weren't asked to adopt the the Shar
mix and in June 2020 you didn't look at
it no I think we we I I we didn't
include it in the assessment that's
that's for certain yeah yeah because one
thing starkly missing is any one-bedroom
units at all even for affable housing
why why is that well I think in this you
know this location it's not sort of
considered appropriate you know smaller
apartment sizes are generally sort of
inner urban consider more appropriate in
in urban areas and that family housing
is considered more appropriate in in
this sort of position
location
but that I mean that's a planning issue
I'm this because I don't want to take me
into things you in a sense it's better
for me to ask the planning witness about
and but I did want to understand what
your when you were looking at it from
the point of view of of
valuation how much you explored the
accommodation schedule and I think my
initial answer was this is what you were
given um and it it didn't change is is
that it didn't change this was what we
were given though that's both correct we
did we did consider it where where it's
not and and and as i' gave an example
whether um you know we would go back and
say you know that's not appropriate um
you know may need to consider something
else we we do raise questions um you
know but obviously it's only one aspect
as I said the most valuable scheme is
not necessarily the scheme that would be
acceptable in planning terms so it's not
for me or indeed any value I think to
dictate what the the mix should be I
think that's beyond beyond our expertise
REM
Etc no but what you can okay sorry I
went I suppose I'm ask question I should
be asking Mr Bull um one thing you did
say though was that oh but there are
three story properties within what I was
asked to assess we look at the schedule
clearly not are they no three story
properties yeah 2 2.5 as I explains the
Cass is 2.5 because you
have because that's just the way that
weed it maybe it's not clear but it's
sort of because that room is not a full
box as it were the the the floor of that
height is sort of um has have a better
way of describing it where you where the
the pitch of the roofs come in and
you've got
um you see you the whole the floor space
is is is there and you've got an extra
floor I mean obviously there's different
housing designs one could have a mansard
roof and a you know sort of more
Georgian townhouse like you might see in
central London I think it'd be out of
odds in in but but yeah that's what was
done it's three stories there are three
levels ground first and second of of
floor space so three stories well this
is why I want to have no that's why I
did try to clarify that in in
my yes you see this why I it's why my
eyes is pricked up because I didn't
understand your answer yeah no no I'm
very happy to clarify again did we go to
the parameter plan yes now um This was
um 116 as a cool
documents um
now H sorry 116 is the revision B I knew
I was going to fall into that trap of
going for the ones rather than the twos
sry more it so so we go to the the
correct one which is the um revision c
um
and can you can you direct that to me
sorry I've got CD
2.08 but I think yes I think 2.08 do you
have in the bottom right hand corner
revision
C I'm gonna have to zoom in
sorry just bear with me uh yes revision
C yes sorry and and you can see up above
the dates of when things were amended so
just above the emblem CSA environmental
you've got rision a is 21st of May 2020
B is 3rd of June 20 20 and C is 28th of
October 2020
now um think part of the reason I gone
to B is that June is when your report
goes in um but for these
purposes it's it's the same um notation
but ask a plary question
this is not listed as one of the plans
that you were asked to consider is that
the
case um we
were I do recognize this we were
certainly provided it whether we listed
it in our report um well can you take it
in stages because I can understand as
these things progress you get to see a
lot more documents but your report as
I'm sure you would want to confirm is
meant to record all the information
you're relying
upon and at that stage in June 2020 you
had been given an accommodation schedule
been given the development framework but
it doesn't list parameter plan even
though actually it was
available um
well it doesn't L the report doesn't L
the parameter plan no yeah uh and the
thing I wanted to
um pick up and it's a distinction that's
drawn certainly by the planners and I
seem by you as well
that in the notation you see the sort of
yellow areas marked so the top right
this is where it's recording
there's a overall bracket saying 11.73
hectares and within that bracket you'll
see different shades of yellow yes and
it goes proposed developer area
predominantly two and two and a half
story with a limited number of three
then it goes developer area two story
with two and a half story dwellings at
key locations and then it goes two story
so it draws distinction between two two
and a half and three so you might have
looked at two and a half you were given
that combination you were you were not
asked to consider three that way
well I I I can consider the I think the
the point was about floor space rather
than design um I think the I presume and
I don't know but the there's a
difference in certainly design as to
whether the the volume of airspace
within a within a floor has sort of the
RO the roof is effectively or part of
the roof is you know in is horizontal
sorry I'm not I'm not an architect so I
don't may not be out to describe this
but that's sort of a two and a half I
think that's what that's only what I
understood to be and is in the errors is
two and a half and and three would
effectively be you know more a vertical
box so I don't think it
really yeah I I don't see the distin I
can see the distinction from Z purposes
how one how it looks but the sizes
reflect in terms of floor space reflects
a three story two and a half I'm not I'm
not sure of the difference I think it
would mostly be in the
design because
comination sh you'll given the only ones
at two and a half story mentioned in the
list are the three bedroom semi so no
four bed property at all is going to be
any higher than two stories I mean
that's a limit that one obviously it's
particular choice but that's not how the
parameter plan would limit them is
it well it wouldn't necessarily um limit
them but I mean as I think we sort of
said additional floor space doesn't
doesn't add value in in fact you know
often often not the case particularly
when one goes up people prer lateral
space if they if at all possible so it
it sort of adds cost it adds some you
know limited it does add value but
limited
um yes but but um I mean I don't know
against this um you know
whether I mean they are there the three
beds and they're and they're in there
whether it's a sufficient number is is a
matter Beyond you that goes to to mix
planning policy Etc that's that's beyond
me I think no fair enough I I obviously
want to put tape don't need to take it
further it's just there strange
distinction can I then go through
to um the another appendix in this
report um where these um
accommodation sorry the accommodation
schedule has been given some values
appendix 5 now electronically that
starts at page
59 and then the table itself is on
electronic page
61 this is 61 of my so we're still
hopefully in the same June 2020
report
yes and the pendic 2 had the
accommodation schedule and then appendix
5 um uses
those different typologies and then puts
a value on them that's essentially what
the valuation schedule as far as I can
see is doing yeah
yes and in terms
of um I think you did say you there
might be some greater value to higher
properties but just wanted to pick it
out the the garages um is that something
that you determined whether they were
going to be or was it is it again
something you were given that that was
something that was yeah provided in the
in the accommodation schedule yeah
because I think it add up to 77 but it's
only for the four bedroom
properties uh again that's not a fixed
factor is it or not something you can't
answer my understanding with the per
permission is that it's not fixed I mean
in real I think in reality and it' be
addressed by Mr Bull that physically
there is a you know a limit one even if
plan permission was given for 10,000
units it you know they evidently
couldn't
be can be delivered on the site
physically um but there's no my
understanding is there's no limit to the
number of garages within the permission
yeah but as you've caned it and as it
comes across garages are just seen as a
cost there doesn't really seem to be any
added value no no there is an there is
an additional value and I think that is
addressed in in my report certainly
something we considered they do they do
add
value
right um but in this case only to the
four stories sorry the four bedroom no
other property has a look in so it's
it's a variation that's possible
I well I mean in theory you could have a
garage you know with a one-bedroom flat
I mean I think it's
just you see them on larger properties
the larger property gets you know in
some cases they you even have double
garages as we do here with the larger
properties so I think that's a really
you know that's a reasonable um you know
assumption as I say this wasn't
undertaken by by
myself yeah because that's what I
understand you said it wasn't downt by
myself but the the square meterage or d
square Foo is same sense that again is
something that was given to you not that
you
checked that that that yeah the
accommodation schedule was provided in
including the
areas so as you know the the point has
been raised that the um National um
standards for space would be expected to
be be
applied was that a was that news to
you um it's I think it's beyond my
expertise it's a it's a planning matter
um you know have heard of it um so yeah
and and I think my my understanding is
that all of the units do apply apart
from the two-bedroom um houses and I can
only assume that there was a a yeah I
don't know
what's happened there but and indeed
whether or not that's unacceptable I
mean that's a planning matter okay so do
say if it's if it's sort of appropriate
but but it just something obviously I'm
trying I'm trying to help where I where
I can and I apologize if I Stray
into in in into areas of so I'm just but
it's important to to draw distinction
about where you are able to comment and
where sense it's just your general
knowledge but so please do stick to WIS
that you're comfortable talking about
because the the other thing that could
AR and it is relevant to General factors
is the number of people that might be
expected to be in any property uh
because that then will affect the size
you would expect it to be you you aware
of that point that um a three-bedroom
property expected to accommodate um a
larger family will expected to be a
larger property than if it was a smaller
number of people Ian is that again
something for planners not for you well
I I think so they the I know that it
does say number of Habitual rooms for
example bedrooms um and it does talk
about number of persons um but I think
doesn't one lead to the
other the number of persons doesn't
dictate the property I don't know that's
that's is certainly Beyond me okay fine
because it it does affect the minimum
sizes but that's again if it's not for
you then I W to ask you that further
it's fine um the
I think we can then leave the uh
appendices
and um move to your um proof of evidence
if you could please
um
and now I'm just going to pick up uh
some of the updates that you've done the
um first thing where you have obviously
looked to
update
figures as I understand it is the um
what we then find at
your page 11 I think it is is that
right yes yeah and as you know this is
seeking to update revenue and also costs
um we end up here with a difference ofus
457 uh
obviously well within the
residual land value that was used in
your previous
assessments um why are you not using the
same standard that you did in June 2020
and June
2021 and now I thought we I'd addressed
that at the time the
Benchmark land value is the test against
which viability is done that's
established in planning practice um
guidance on viability on RCS guidance on
viability and
planning I
suppose but you are applying a different
standard now aren't you in your approved
the two earlier
reports no my report was always
considered the Benchmark land value um I
was just saying what the mechanics are
um one could set out just as GSP have
done they've tested against the
benchmark value they then said this is
what the extra increase sort of would
equate to but the the test is against
The Benchmark land value that's
consistent um and can I then put it this
way if you were using the similar
residual land value there would then be
a surplus that could be interpreted as
additional affordable Hing
units if that was the if that was The
Benchmark L value say let's put it in
those terms and that was the correct
figure to adopt then then yes evidently
that would be right just in the same way
that you know if a higher Surplus that
DSP came to they come to figures and
that was the land value you should use
then there would be a deficit but that's
just a a matter
of you know math essentially you know
one minus the
other no but I need to ask you because
there might have been more complication
to I'm glad as you say it is it is a
matter of uh simply looking at the
figures and then and analyzing that and
as I understand it just taking a point
about the maths you you don't take issue
with the maths of DS P's sort of high
level appraisals it's the it's it's the
assumptions behind it that where the
issues lie uh yes I've not examined
their appraisals in in in detail but but
I don't I well I um I think there are
some issues around the some of the other
appraisals which perhaps we'll go we'll
go on to but but the in terms of their
assessment of of this appraisal the only
differences the um the costs yeah um but
yeah the the maths I suppose the
calculation the appraiser itself we both
use the same software for example yeah
and just picking up in terms of the
maths the and you've made the point
about St land but the where you end up
with a fraction of a unit in in this
instance it's not of significance is it
we sort of point one of a unit is not
going to really change the figures
overall it's you're talking about one or
two either way oh in terms of their mix
in the the 2016 schar and 2021 schar
that they adopt yeah I mean I addressed
that I I do the same because uh because
I just made the point that in reality
you wouldn't have seven of a four
bedroom house being delivered it
couldn't happen but but it means to an
end and and it would and I think it
would all work out in the in the ram but
once you rounded it back to the the
nearest numbers and worked itself out
yeah thank you I just like understand
the criticism but equ the consequence of
it as you say is not really in the round
no and that's why I've not sought to
change it or or dispute it I've I've
adopted the the mix that they've adopted
it's it's their mix that's helpful saves
a few questions but um the can I then
check in your proof you talk about the
alternative mix you did look at yes so
that's section five yeah your section
five and I think you've explained when
you were giving evidence in Chief that
you had originally thought the
alternative mix was just going to be for
affordable housing and that's therefore
what your work reflects yes um and
therefore you hadn't looked at the uh
potential alternative mix for the
private housing that's correct at that
stage yeah I obviously I go on to do
that in my reply but yes but at this
stage the alternative mix and we can see
it at
5.2 um looks at the
um jused full housing 68 units um and
the sort of type of unit number of beds
it would be and then uh you talk about
the tenure in the next table at 5 2.2
but when we look through to your
um I your valuation ASE the
consequence um just trying to see how
the math fits together because obviously
there's a change in two bedroom units um
of 22 but when we get to your is the
table just under
5.4.2 you'll see
the number of units
that is yeah so be 88 so it's it's not
as if it's simple maths of taking away
the affable housing units and left with
the private it looks like you've changed
some of the no I have had to change the
the private um to accommodate the um
affordable mix and and I and I explained
that in in the report so I think the um
the mix required more I think it was
four beds that um in order to provide
sufficient number of four-bedroom homes
in the in the affordable um some private
units have effectively in the mix been
been changed um
and uh to main yeah so so there's been
sort of some toing and throwing I
suppose um between the sort of private
allocation and the affordable allocation
but the what I I suppose the the
affordable mix is compliant as a result
of that with the 2016 schar the price
private mix is is not a direct copy of
it may be compliant that's a matter for
others but um does that does that
follow just shows that there is some
variation to be made but it just shows I
wanted obviously it's it's the headline
isn't it that's most important it's what
then happens in terms yeah so so as a
result of the change in the mix both the
affordable and the private accommodation
the values change because the values
that have been agreed are built up by
you know the component parts and so
you're changing the component parts and
the you know the the buildup changes the
values changes and that's what I've done
there so so saying well if we've lost
four bedroom units from the private but
we've you know increased the number of
twos and threes the mixed changes you
know here's the number of number of
units so um you know in that case I
think the um the value per square foot
actually goes up in the priv the private
accommodation and that's because you've
got smaller private
accommodation um higher values and
squarefit because when we look at what
the consequence for this particular VAR
for 5.9 appraisal results yeah the
difference here isus
22,7 75 rather than what would have been
Theus 437 that you originally had so
there's a increase in the the revenue
Side by doing this
change yes yes it's still yes it is um
it's still below the Benchmark but it
the the value is yeah approximately 4.5
as opposed to 4.3 on the the sort of
submited
Mi
yeah um now
this but I obviously looked at the
change to the full housing could you
just tell me which is the equivalent
appraisal in your reustle that
does this change for private housing as
well locate it the
equivalent well let in here we have um
your alternative in your proof was just
looking at well if we we change some of
the assumptions about the affordable
housing side yeah but we don't change
assumptions about the private yeah um
and as you said that was because you're
understanding at the time uh that it was
just to be looking at forall housing but
I now it's the equivalent of where you
could do you could change the mix on on
both and have a you know smaller units
for the private as well where is that
assessment I wasn't sure I could locate
it in your rebuttal proof so in my so we
having had both parties obviously
exchange proof at that point I'm
informed that one should adopt the schar
for the private as well as the
affordable and I've considered that in
my proof so I assume at that
point the the the alternative I think
what do I call I think I call it the in
SE heading of section five or or
alternative where you know that's not
acceptable so I then consider what is
considered acceptable which is the
um is that is that what you yeah just
and I suppose I know I'm sort of you may
have multiple documents if one goes to
battle let's see if I can get this
perhaps land in the right place in your
rebuttal proof yeah is the so to speak a
equivalent to what we've just been
looking at as the alternative but just
for full housing is the equivalent your
table to is that where we get
to sorry my in the rebuttal in the
rebuttal what page am I meant to be
looking at yes I knew I'd have to take a
bit slower um sorry p no I appreciate
we're having a lot of documents to to
juggle um in the
um updates that you have
done we end up with
um table two yes that's on page four you
call updated appraisal summary
um and you've done the amendment for the
two-bedroom
um but I just trying to explow is your
table to updated proposal
summary is that the one where we see the
um as so we speak the update to your
table that we have under 5.9 or is it a
different one no I think I believe it's
the it's what would be called the the
pal mix it's the equant to dsp's
v101 so thank you and and SE four of my
report page
11 because what I then have is Table Six
in your
reustle yeah mhm
appears you say um let's assume larger
unit
sizes
um and you've increased the size of the
market homes because of that assessment
and that's what Table Six is but that
table six doesn't appear to
be um a refinement of your table at 5.9
in your proof it seems to be something
different is that correct it's a
refinement
of um the the table two appraisal the
the with 70 square meters I suppose um
it's so it's meeting that minimum
standard 70 square meters um and then
it's saying well
actually um let's go on the three and
four beds let's go larger um as as was
the local plan assessment figures yeah
so yes so sorry thanks for confirming it
because then it it's it's looking at at
that
um scenario yes scenario that you had
assessed in your proof at paragraph
5.9 hasn't been
redone for the private haes has it
you um that
scenario no because I was seeking to to
reply to the uh points made and and I'm
told that the policy compliant mix you
other words the council's case the
policy comp mix is the the the schar mix
and and so
obviously yeah that's what I've that's
what I've tested and and go on to
test in table seven well I did wonder if
you might have worked the figures
through but not produce them because you
say what you're focusing on because 5.9
when one changes the affordable housing
side produces greater income uh more the
units being assumed surely it would do
the the same for the market housing side
if you were small assuming some smaller
units there would be an increased
Revenue but not such a great increase in
costs and
therefore um the residual land value
would be even more
positive well it would
um sorry wait um sorry can you up which
praise am I am I meant to be meant to
have updated the f
I've
used short hand in your proof where
you've just updated the affordable
housing part of the yeah and shown there
was greater Revenue
available and I was asking and I don't
I'm not sure if you'd have done it the
question was if you do it for the market
housing as well as for the affordable
housing that exercise and changing the
mix does that not also also produce
further Revenue no it makes it worse
that's the that's the 26 16 schar mix
and that's the um and that I mean in my
figures it leads to a negative land
value but I think sorry I I may have
misunderstood and obviously if you're
increasing this is why one has to be
Solly careful in terms of I haven't won
that this appraisal evidently but I'm
happy to try
and consider what the results would
be yeah because your section five goes
through an alternative mix and just does
it in terms of the affordable housing
and and increases therefore suddenly we
have some one-bedroom units for instance
yes yes but they're all on the
affordable housing side yes and
affordable housing gives you less
Revenue as we know as opposed to private
housing would that's that's how it works
so if you had some private units at one
bedroom value you'd surely have greater
value from them and it wouldn't cost as
much to build so well problem is one one
one doesn't build one bedroom houses one
builds one bedroom apartment so you've
then got the extra area which is not
Revenue ging I think in this location
you would you know they wouldn't have
much value from a private sales area and
you know that's obviously not something
was considered at length and there would
be quite a risk to do it in fact I can
understand the reasons
why I was really asking for expert view
for having shown if you change the
Assumption add in some of the smaller
units on the affordable
side no if you do to the private worse
that's what that's what the
2016 appraisal shows that you know the
v102 is dear de referred to it so that's
why it was limited to the affordable
because I assumed that's what they meant
that that's where the need and obviously
I appreciate I was I was wrong in that
but I was just trying to assist the the
inspector the inquiry into doing an
alternative appraisal I assumed it was
the affordable mix that needed changing
on the basis that that's where the need
of house that was needed for for that
and therefore I tested that D you know
in in the council's proof they then test
the whole of the 2016 Shar makes that's
significantly worse so so as I say would
it is it is
worse uh if I I'm not 100% certain I've
understood stood you correctly uh the
the
appraisal but but if I have then that
then that's the
results right no say I had to ask to
sort of slightly theoretical because I I
didn't find that exercise within your
um well the 206 mix includes includes
the mix and
I yeah um now in terms I think one then
has a a clear feeling for what the the
figures come out with and and you've
already commented on the DSP work as the
as terms of the math so I'm not going to
seek to go back on that but um can I
just understand when ter terms of the
the local plan appraisal that was
done um just a general question to start
with that's not something you looked at
specifically yourself you is it
something you just left to one side
you've not looked at no I I certainly
considered it at the time um but you
know I I deal with it in the Benchmark
in my report considering that I also
look at other local plan Assessments in
relation to the
Benchmark um and and come to you know
the figure that I do and that's that's
assessed accept ETA I looked at the
other assumptions but you know this is
my assessment this wasn't a carbon copy
of the local plan assessment this
allocation was for 550 units this
allocation for four this sorry this
planning permission so should it be
granted this appeal is for 450 units and
I and I assessed I assumptions I
considered were reasonable and some of
those were you know favorable to to the
outcome in terms of viability affordable
housing um as as I've outlined in my
report lower cost for professional fees
a lower profit
margin but it included doesn't it so in
terms of sort of margin for error or
buffering there's sort of 10 million
pounds for planning contributions for
instance so plan assessment
yes so much larger Alliance factors
that well that's the
like yeah that there is a 10 million
pound I'm not sure what you're asking me
though that's just identifying it
hopefully having me to go to it because
obviously familiar with it but the one
thing you were referring to was that it
used a 20% profit margin you may recall
that point um that of course builds in
doesn't it a greater margin for error if
I can use that so a greater sort of pot
of money if you're if you're showing
something is sound and deliverable with
a 20% profit margin then if someone
comes along we using 17 and a half
there's a sort of there some margin to
be used to to accommodate sort of
Greater cost isn't it that you you
should come out um ahead if I put it
that way if you that's change you made
then that's right I don't know whether
um and
I the 20% is adopted as on the basis
that it's a you know a buffer in itself
um I mean local they local plans test
different typographies they include
sensitivities Etc but they essentially
meant to be done on the same basis that
that a scheme is assumed to have
planning for which it is tested
um yeah and the sensitivity had CHS plus
or minus in terms of the revenue or in
terms of build yeah but the the point
really is that that 20% used at the
local plan level is not forward at the
the development management level because
you're being I suppose you have much
greater certainty about what's being
looked at don't you
um well no I considered I adopted
because I considered it was appropriate
there are many schemes where 20% profit
margin is adopted and considered
appropriate and and um I don't you know
as I say the scheme assumes that
the the whatever's been tested whether
it's at the local plan typography or the
SCH that has planning permission there
you know we're at reserved we're at a
outline planning permission there's
still a reserved matters application to
go through there is still you know
planning risk even once this appeal is
you know
resolved one way or the other if it were
to be um you know granted they would
still be planning R but the viability
assessment doesn't shouldn't distinguish
between that one wouldn't reduce the
profit margin at the res you know if
there was a reserved matter application
stage it's deemed you know and in fact
the side doesn't have planning
permission so one doesn't amend the
profit margins uh you know as a result
of that
so yeah I I don't I don't think it sort
of works in in in that way as as you've
described well what does appear to be
the case you've not previously relied
upon the local plan 20% for your to to
argue for 20% here I mean that's not no
no I'm not arguing for 20% I consider 17
half% to be reasonable it's it's you
know I've considered set out why it's
within in the range I'm I'm just sort of
noting that when parties have have said
one should adopt the assumptions in the
local plan you if that's the case then
one should also consider the other
assumptions in the local plan and you
know want to take a balanced you know
view one one shouldn't
just yeah but the um other issue where
20% was used was Samson Grange I is that
something you looked at
before uh was it only risen as part of
the inquiry for for your it's only risen
as part of the inquiry but one can see
that from the report there's a reference
to I suppose greater level of
uncertainty um yeah
it still applies with you know the cost
increases we're seeing Etc and one you
know I'm sure one might argue and other
part maybe other parties would argue for
that you know but those those points
were available for people to argue a
year ago or two years ago and and it
hasn't Arisen here has
it no well no some parties are now
arguing for lower profit profit margin
um but but um that bit I was just trying
to say for the 20% point that it's not
been argued that similar considerations
that might have applied at sson Grange
now apply in January 2022 to this site
well I think they may um and I think
that go do you do you or do you not say
it should I mean well I think it goes
into the round I'm not saying that 20 C
should be adopted but those issues are
still prent you know we there is a still
you know considerable uncertainty into
both the you know revenue and you know
but consider might be strong but there
is you know there are are risks around
that can can I put it this way that you
saying that similar issues arise but
even with those bear bearing those in
mind we still you would recommend 17 and
a half% yes yes I do yes that's what I
understood but the the point I just want
to understand is that obviously in terms
of um this range of 15 to 20% that's
mentioned in the
PPG um that if one looks at the
um residual land value that was
previously used by um
by you indeed um in 2021 or 2020 um it's
still within the margin of 15 to 20% I
mean
it's um that
results yes but it wouldn't well it
maybe I don't know I haven't I haven't
done that um but it's it's not it's not
what's considered by either party to be
by DSP or other and and myself to be the
appropriate level
well within the recommended you know
within the guidance but that's the the
range of which it should be considered
it's been considered you know some and
and the adopted you know margin is 17
and a half percent on the private
Revenue 6% on the
affordable
um I think just a this just a short
point in terms though comparing to the
local plan I know it's you say this is
for 450 rather than
why was it that you you didn't sort of
use that as your starting point I mean
just to understand it that you seem to
come in a
new
um well the the well the scheme is you
know assess the scheme that's be before
me the proposed um you know as
application um and I provided the you
know there's 450 units well how is you
know how have you got to 450 units I was
provided this accommod accommodation
schedule there's obviously been plotting
work behind it um you know and that's
what I've what I've assessed and that's
you know the starting point I've looked
at the local plan you know appraise
assessment assumptions um they you know
they admittedly as DSP say high level um
they predate the you know changes the
mppf in terms of detailed Lo plan
assessments the you know so I have I had
considered it um but I considered the
appropriate
assumptions um and those have been you
know considered by DSP some of those
were you know a couple of them were
disputed and and result and then
agreed
okay
um I think
I may have covered the points I need to
as the
rest
um can I just go quickly to your
rebuttal um yes
and just to check a point on table two
where you come up with the you having
looked at the
um revenue and cost updates that that um
might
apply there's a difference of minus
37,7 yeah yeah now just see if I got
this right that's um means that on this
particular
layout it would achieve 99% of the
Benchmark land
value well that's adopting the agreed
rate per square foot rate per square
meter as I go on to say um you know
actually it wouldn't because the value
the build up to that was on the basis of
the smaller unit sizes and and if had
one had a larger unit size you'd
certainly have a larger unit value but
the but it wouldn't be um as big prata
um there would be a Quantum discount and
I go want to sort of consider that as as
a sense check and and that sort of the
revenues sort of 570,000 low which would
feed you know which would obviously feed
through to the residual land value by a
similar amount so actually it may may
actually be
worse know yeah but the terms of the
math it's about 99% which suggests that
if it was to sort of speak be a zero
some game it would be um looking at a
17.36% profit and get to the figures
matching is that a fair way of doing the
maths 99% of 17 and a
half% I'm not I'm not I don't think it
is quite as as simple as that
unfortunately but but
I well you can see my sentiment I I can
see a sentiment yes I can I can see
trying to get a feel for how far off it
is or you know within the range it is
okay that that's very helpful look thank
you Mr Gold um that's what I wanted to
ask
thank
you
now are there
any
questions from any uh interested
party opposing the scheme as I think all
the interested parties are of Mr
cry if so if Mr C you happy if you happy
just to continue now without breaking or
how long have we been going for
just just over hour I'm happy to
continue in depending on the length that
it'll be obviously someone if it's going
to be another hour of cross examination
I might I might ask for a short break
absolutely yeah absolutely I I'll see
what the appetites for questions and
before I I do it's purely for questions
to be asked not for comments or further
submissions to be to be made so is there
any interested party who would like to
ask a question of Mr
cry
okay I don't think the
is
uh I've got nothing further
to to ask um I think over to Mr Williams
just Mr Williams in terms of your re
examination how long do you
expect 15 20 minutes perhaps okay
uh do you want a short break Mr cry or
do you want to go straight into that
it's we'll break out now or after that
it might be want to get it just get it
completed it's up to you I I'm here at
your up to you sir so I think it might
if I may suggest it might be easier to
complete Mr cry while we've got all the
documents out and then we can use the
break partly to yeah re reset theable
yeah refresh before Mr ball yeah and
yeah yeah okay that's fine prer to
continue
okay thank you m I'm going to go back
and start go through from the beginning
as it were so my questions will relate
to the first few questions you were
asked okay um and can you and this the
first topic is the question
of
comparing the residual land value
against Benchmark land value or some
targeted
deficit if I can call it that yeah so
first of all can I look at CD 1.10 which
is your original
appraisal and I think for this purpose
just go
to the executive summary actually at the
beginning on page
one sorry I'm bit behind you I didn't
didn't have that I close that
one yes um and in the table in which you
set out your your
figures yes and in your concluding well
on page one the penultimate paragraph
what is the basis of your
assessment of viability of the
scheme it it's the residual land value
compared to the Benchmark land
value and thank you and what do you say
is the correct approach by reference to
whether you consider an identified
deficit or a benchmark land value as a
surveyor assessing
viability Benchmark land values and
where does that come from it's in the
planning practice guidance on viability
it's in the RSS gu guidance note on on
viability and planning which has been
endorsed by what suddenly been drafted
in consultation with the rtpo
believe and in terms of should we just
look please at The Benchmark that's
right at the PPG on viability
momentarily
please recharge my glass
sry water I is this the extract Mr
Williams or is this the actual PPG
itself it's the extract that we had
earlier I'm afraid I've actually got a
paper copy of the the whole thing but
it's it's
ppg1
okay yes
paragraph 10
that yes
10 and there were a number of questions
about this and I just wanted you to talk
us through by reference to paragraphs 10
and
13 of
the um
PPG why you say one uses the Benchmark
land value and also what the Benchmark
land value
represents yes um so it's I set in
paragraph 10 it's sort of I suppose the
starting point um vity assessment price
assessing of the site is financially
viable but looking at the value
generated um is more than the cost of
developing it this includes looking at
key elements gross development value
cost land value landowner premium and
developer
return
um it sort of you know goes on to deal
with sort of different m Ms the um if I
move on I think it will
be oh dear um my next page is
blank
um I don't know if that's an issue with
my computer
or or the print out that I have um I
think my page is as well so you're it
must be the document in the core
document yeah am I okay to look you you
look it up online
it is readily available if I
just sorry so I'm just going to the
government.gov guidance viability
which this is where this is taken from
um sorry now right
paragraph 11 how should gra valid be
defined we dealt with with
that cost be
defined um
with what is I think I can't remember
how should and then sorry paragraph 13
deals explicitly with how should land
value be defined to Define land value
for any vir assessment a benchmark land
value should be established on the basis
of existing use value of the land plus a
premium to the land owner the premium
should reflect the minimum return which
considered to be a reasonable land that
be will to sell their land and I think
that's been discussed and and and and
both part I think Mr H referred to it on
that basis the minimum
return thank you and if you assess
against not the Benchmark land value but
a deficit of say 1.7 million what does
that actually say about whether or not
the proposal is
viable well it it wouldn't be because
the land wouldn't come forward it
wouldn't be the minimum return that a
land owner would accept and and would
therefore deliver the land for the
scheme okay thank you you can put that
away please the next question relates to
increas in build
costs and I want
you
um it was put to you that it you ought
to consider increases in cost and sales
values on a like for like
basis and you said that um
if you considered the cost position as
approved by DSP and the cost position
taken now there would actually have been
a
reduction and I just wanted you to
explain what you meant by by that um yes
if I I think that's in my expert report
so the
costs
[Applause]
sorry bear with me while I find the
relevant section in there I think it's
section
four
um yeah so the um so the TDC uh
paragraph 5 point sorry
4.5.10 um which is page eight as printed
I'm not sure the PDF number um TDC is
revised rate of 126.2 is lower than the
ratees set out in the accepted June
appraisal updates which has not been
challenged at any state indeed blah blah
blah um and then I go on to consider
that they've accepted a they've they
well they've advocated and and we've
accepted a 6% I think technically
5.99% based on the bcis private housing
construction index rate and applying
that rate would um would to the previous
League's um position would lead result
on a rate of 134 but as I say their rate
is
is lower than that set out in the
previous agreed appraisal and how does
that sit against the evidence that
you've seen about the general pattern in
cost movement as between June 2021 and
your updated assessment well the counter
position that the
um the the current position is that
costs are are going up significantly
that's that's basic you know the
experience that I'm having on schemes
that I'm dealing with um and and is and
is also there evident in the bcis index
data as is included my
report you made the point that um costs
and values in an area aren't like for
like because you could have costs going
down for extraneous factors in a period
when values were going were going up can
you just expand upon that in the context
of the submission As I understood it
that you ought to look for an
appropriate geographical area for an
assessment of cost and value yeah yes
once you look at an appropriate
geographical area you know as I've done
and I've considered the data and
evidence in that basis but I think what
um I think what Mr rton was saying in
his cross- examination is that I should
adopt the the thanet cost
because it's the same as the value cost
and that they are essentially
extrinsically linked and that's and
that's not the case they are two
differing items um as I said costs can
go down values can go up or the inverse
Can Can Happen the build costs do not
dictate house sales values and house
sales values do not dictate build costs
that's that's dictated by
labor um materials you know the elements
that are that go into constructing a
house and what was the position of er
ermc sorry as the cost consultants in in
relation to this
issue they adopted the cost that that we
that we adopted the the thet sorry the
um the the Kent um Estate General 15year
um sample okay thank you the next
question relates to the accommodation
schedule
and you identified that you were
provided with the accommodation schedule
that you considered it as to whether or
not it represented a good value optimal
value
scheme
um have you seen or been asked to
undertake by the council any appraisal
based upon a different mix or being
provided with an appraisal that shows a
higher value value mix no the only mixes
that we've been asked to consider are
the um I've been asked to test is the
2016 schar and the 2021 I think it's now
referred to as schar but it might be
local needs assessment um and those both
show a lower value so there's not been
any mix that provides a higher value
just on a point of detail on on that
point could you go back to cd1 .10
please that's your appraisal and you
were taken
to appendix
two I'm afraid I don't have the PDF
page uh 38 I think of the PDF 39 is a
blank page 39 of the PDF the
actual I don't think yeah and
the you were talking about the two and a
half
story type um which is a
three-bedroom
house and it's house type I do you see
that yes if we just take as another
example um house Type e which is a
twostory three-bedroom detached house
yeah see that yeah the square footage is
lower yes and I then want you to take up
your rebuttal report
please yeah
yes and go to table
four
yes and here's you've set out the unit
values M and if we look at the taller
unit type
I there's a unit value of
281 pound per square
foot do you see that yes and house Type
e which was the two twostory three
bed unit priced
£337 yes
um and can you just
explain the relevance of those sorts of
relationships in the context of an
argument implied argument that by
assessing taller buildings higher
buildings you might have increased value
um across the
ski well there's there's a number of
factors here there's the element of um
Quantum discount as I described so as
the buildings get um as the units get
bigger and that's sort of better shown
by table three
the value the actual sales value
generally increases but the the rate per
square foot drops um in this case
because it's a you know the amount of
floor space is spread over three floors
a lot of that usable space is lost by
staircase people purchases generally and
obviously not everyone but the market
generally prefers sort of two-story um
and and floor space spread over
laterally rather than than vertically
and and that's you know demonstrable in
value
um in in in evidence that you'll see you
know a townhouse a three story house set
that's the same size as the two story
house sell for
Less thank you very
much
um similarly in relation to
garages you'll
recall the appellant offering to run
appraisals but prior to the
CMC on any assumptions that the council
wished to put forward
has any appraisal ever be any criticism
of any appraisal ever been raised by
reference to the treatment of garages in
relation to value or
cost um the so in terms of the sort of
the mix um certainly not the officers in
Endor the mix um in in their committee
report as I think has already been
referred to um in terms of value sorry
in terms of cost in terms of value I
believe not in terms of costs I do
recall that uh Mr a criticized the cost
um and in his uh note reports and that
that was dealt with in my
proof um if it's helpful to turn to he's
desperately trying to find
it section
six
um so yeah Garage Cross uh
6.9 um it's page 21 as a print out I
don't have the PDFs open so I don't know
what that is
apologies um so yeah they they say it
should um is it helpful if I just deal
with yeah yeah um so PDC consider the
cost eight and a half th000 per garage
should have been applied no evidence
been provided no consideration of the
type of garages have been applied we um
the costs assume different costs given
the size whether it's a double a single
or an integral garage um so these were
um um the costs were provided by that
was considered by the council's quantity
surveyors um cons they were did not
consider reasonable um I've also
received a a cost plan from another
party um which set out the cost at equ
to sort of 14 to
23,000 and and had also been provided
the internal costs um from both a
regional and National house Builder and
in all cases there are significant
higher than the costs adopted by Mr OST
um and indeed supports the costs adopted
in the assessment or or suggest actually
that they're rather conservative and
could be
higher thank
you next question I'd like to ask you
about is you were asked in your proof
you were asked
questions
about page
16 Pro yeah
which was where you had
varied the gladman mix in order to
incorporate affordable units um more in
line with 2016
schar um and there were various
questions about what would have happened
if you had updated in order to reflect
private and affordable units in line
with the
schar and I just wanted you to look at
your robust
evidence please yes I didn't I didn't
quite follow the question at the time
but as I as I think I later got on to I
have tested that explicitly but if we go
to
3.7.1 and table 8
yeah what's the can you just tell us
what are what are what is the 2016 schar
mix there that you've been testing that
that's the mix that was provided in
dsp's note I've adopted it verbatim is
that the right word I think and is that
in relation to private and affordable
yes in relation to both yeah
yeah so the mix isn't identical to to
theirs thank
you and
finally you were asked questions by
reference to your rebuttal table
to
you'll recall the minus
37,000 deficit Against The Benchmark
land value being
99% of the Benchmark land value do you
recall yes I just want to be clear as to
the role of table two in relation to the
size changes and the paragraphs that
follow table two 2.2 dat to 2.
2.14 can we just be clear please as
to the role of those paragraphs and as
to whether or not table two is put
forward as the concluded Financial
viability appraisal in relation to a
specific
scheme uh no I I I don't suppose it
should well the the DAT appraisal adopts
the the value that reflects the mix with
the smaller unit size and what the
subscri and that results in the figure
that it results in and that results in a
deficit of only of
37,000 my those were those Figures were
agreed in relation to the the appellant
mix with the smaller twoed size 63 or 64
square meters I believe um I've then
just applied that rate to the extra
floor area I then go on to consider the
issue of of sort of quantum discounting
as it's referred to in fres
um and actually consider the the value
of that unit in more detail obviously
that Val that all other units are
effectively agreed as a value but but
that unit isn't because there was never
a 70 met Square tub 70 square meter two
bed house originally assessed so that's
why I've separated it out um and as you
as you can see it sort of paragraph
2.24 actually the revenues would be much
less much lower than that's in the
appraisal summary and that would affect
the residual land value and I know that
you can't
do an exercise without changing all the
variables and rerunning the software but
the figure in your
2.2.4 you suggest the revenue side would
come would have to come down by
$571,000 yeah do you provide that figure
as a an indication of the materiality of
the point or can we read anything into
that
well
um yes that the deficit would be bigger
than than £37,000 I suppose I don't know
what the precise figure would be without
um doing it it would
be you know it would be in that order by
a similar amount because effectively
that loss of Revenue just comes off the
the land value as I've previously
explained that it's Revenue l cost so if
the revenue reduces by 570,000 then then
broadly speaking the the land value does
and so the land value would reduce the
deficit would by a similar amount the
the um deficit would would increase by a
similar amount so you would get to a
deficit of sort of you know broadly
600,000 pounds or just
below now there are there are some
variances and details and I can't I
can't do a precise number in in my head
no that's fine just wanted to understand
the role of that figure that's all I
wanted to ask thank you very much I'm
happy to Pro to run that and provide it
as a supplemental if if if the ins
inspector say if you need that figure or
any
other thank you very much sir thank you
Mr
cry thank you Mr Williams and thank you
Mr CRA for your evidence today and
another quite a long shift for your as
well so thank you for persevering
through that
uh we're going to have a break now I'll
just come to Mr Dickman in a second but
we're gonna have a a break and after
that we'll be moving on to Mr ball and I
will uh Mr Williams how long
approximately do you think it will be
for
your evidence in Chief with Mr
ball I haven't had a chance to catch up
with Mr ball at all today I would say
about 45 minutes okay so that is I think
given my sort
of five o'clock sort of finish time I
think that's probably as far as we're
going to get today uh so cross-
examination of Mr ball will be left till
tomorrow uh so maybe after uh after the
evidence after the cross after the
evidence Chief ball if again we can have
a little bit discussion about the
timetable for for tomorrow that would be
helpful for me uh Mr Dickman you've got
your hand up oh thank you sir um would
it be appropriate for me to ask Mr cauri
just one question um I'm not sure the
proc I'm afraid that sort of chance has
has passed by to be honest because it
was no problem the I've got to sort
because this is a formal part of the the
meeting I've got to uh obviously sort of
stick to the the program and the
opportunity for questions was after
cross examination so unfortunately not
I'm afraid uh but
uh I just was going to say actually at
the end of today or tomorrow morning
when it comes to closing submissions of
which one is normally expected from the
the rule six
party um mrman are you still
there yes I am sir yeah sorry you
disappeared so I am obviously it's up to
you but uh you will be sort of you know
fully expected to make a rule closing
submissions along with the other two
parties as well so just to let you know
that but it's important there's no new
evidence in that you no it's just one of
Cl it's just one of clarity sir but I'm
happy to ask it tomorrow
okay good okay let's break for uh
afternoon tea or
whatever uh let's
have I think based on the sort of
timings we can probably afford to come
back at 5 4 and that will still give Mr
Williams a chance for do his evidence in
Chief with Mr ball and then we can clear
up any sort of timetable matters at the
end so we'll break now we journ now
until uh 5 past 4 thank
you thank
you
right it's five past five
uh good afternoon Mr ball good afternoon
time to
continue with uh evidence and chief for
Mr ball over to you Mr
Williams I think you're on mute Mr
Williams thank you could I ask you to
take out your proof of evidence Please
Mr
Paul I have that and turn to section
1.1 that you set out in 1.1
your qualifications being a Bachelor of
Science degree in geography and geology
from University of Manchester master's
degree in urban and Regional planning
with distinction from the University of
Sydney a master of science degree in
Town and Country planning with Merit
from the University of West of England
is that all correct that's all correct
yes and then you set out your experience
and um employment history and your
current
responsibilities at gladman and is that
all correct it's is yes and you provide
a statement of Truth at paragraph 1.2
and can you confirm that the evidence
you've given and will give represents
your true professional opinions yes I
can
confirm so again I don't want to go
through the proof or summary in we'll
take that as readed if that's acceptable
just highlight some some main
points um section two of
your proof
please you introduce the planning
application you
explain some of the pre-submission
history alongside how it was handled by
the committee at the various
stages um and I just wanted you to give
an overview please of the ex
how
the uh application was handled and the
approach that gladman took with officers
with a view to arriving at um a scheme
to be put forward for Planning
Commission sure um as outlined at um
paragraph
2.2.2 um I provide an introduction to uh
the pre-application process that we went
through as part of our uh involvement in
the sites um I've not referenced dates
so it may be of assistance um just for
your notes and and hopefully mron won't
uh take umage with this but um our first
pre-application meeting with the council
was on the 25th of July
2019 um I referen a planning performance
agreement that was signed in October um
2019 um our submission Then followed in
July
2020 um for that period uh in the year
up to submission the planning
performance agreement um secured us four
pre-application meetings with officers
from than District Council um officers
from Kent County Council were also
involved throughout that process um we
were involved in carrying out what we
call site due diligence work so by that
point um we had instructed our entire
Consulting team um they were looking
into the background work and feeding
through results and the team was
coordinating together behind the scenes
to look at the sites the constraints the
policy requirements and the overall site
master
plan okay thank you was there anything
else you wanted to say by reference to
section
two um I think most broadly um that the
preparation of the application was an
in-depth and detailed process that
involved officers from County and
District um informed by our Consulting
team
um I think moving forward through my
evidence um what I then do is talk more
about the scheme's
evolution should we turn is that in
section four that you you have in mind
that's correct yes and in relation to
that section
could you just explain because obviously
you heard my discussion with Mr
Hester uh We've also heard from Mr
Travis um it's
cwell um M Nera about how that the
scheme was arrived at and there seems to
be this suggestion that more could have
been done to provide additional housing
and that 450 is a compromise could you
just explain as you did in section for
why the scheme is as it is of course um
for this part sir it may be helpful if
we um turn up and I'll go a bit slower
just for benefit of uh people watching
my
appendix appendix
and also a plan which we may be familiar
with um which is in
cd58 which is the flood risk
assessment and its PDF page
75 which we may recall is the um overlay
with the surface water
flows
which uh page PDF page of the flood risk
assessment
it's 75
set
I've got it thank
you um so OB is this drawing
11 yes that's
correct thank you carry on um so
obviously when you're looking at the
site you have to bear in mind
constraints um you also have to of
course take into account policy um in
this instance the the local plan
allocation
designates um the requirement to
provide uh a distributor Link Road
through the site in providing that road
it has to include a roundabout on shot
andan Road a roundabout on manston road
and a a junction on hars down
Road there are also other policy
requirements which have been referred to
elsewhere um by the parties as part of
this inquiry which refers to the
requirements to deliver on-site public
open space
um also within the policy is a
requirement to carry out Heritage impact
assessments um and to take into account
mitigation where
necessary
um when preparing the scheme um the
surface water flow pathway that's
already been referred to as part of this
inquiry is is a fairly big constraint
that runs through the northern parcel um
we're aware that we can't build within
those surface water flows
so that in effect excludes where that
surface waterf flow pathway is um
identified on plan
11 the requirement to provide a link
Road um has to be built to distribut the
standard in accordance with Kent um
County Council guidance that limits
access for private driveways onto the
road um so when you put in relation to
the northern parcel um you have to have
that requirement to veride the junction
onto Hearts down Road um you when you're
putting the road down you have to avoid
the surface water uh flow path um we
obviously have to cross that flow path
um best practice guidance stipulates
that you cross that once um but not
withstanding that um this feeds into
part of the sites abnormal costs um
because you have to maintain free
conance and flows under it um the the
proposals are
that section of the the road which sits
over the moderate um Hazard area would
have to go under a box
hbert um as you exit that site you
obviously have to provide the
roundabout um which has a bearing on
site design and master
planning um so just focusing on that
Northern section of the the application
site in general it does really quite
restrict how you can plan around those
constraints and around those policy
requirements now just focusing on not
just drawing the 11 but also the
framework plan in my um
appendix also another factor that has to
be borne in mind is the safeguarded land
area which um Kent County Council
require which is at the Western end of
the
site and is is marked by a lighter shade
of beige I suppose you would call it um
which Kent County Council required
deliver an offline Road solution for
shot and D
Road So within this Northern Parcels
that we we have to bear in mind the
constraints policy requirements and what
that really does on delivering a form of
development that meets policy and deals
with site
constraints um as we move into the
southern parcel between shoton D road
and manston road um the extent of the
distributor Road has to go up into
manston road we know that through policy
um that has to have a
roundabout
um if one was to say consider move the
roundabouts location for let's say an
alternative design you're going to have
to take into account the safeguarded
land
area this part of the site is the area
of the site that rises with the highest
topography um the Link Road itself has
to be an acceptable gradient
um so on the basis of our design we
looked at how to optimize providing the
Link Road um at an acceptable gradient
without having unacceptable land sake on
loss of developable land the
road um so a potential alternative
option for example is you could try and
snake the um distributor Link Road
through the sites but that's going to
have more land take and it's not going
to work as a as as a link Road um so so
the option we chose in in preparing this
design um alongside our engineers and
our highways Consultants was the the
scheme before you um as you come into
the rear of the site um or the southern
end of the site adjacent to manston Road
um you have to take into account
Heritage buffers with the cemetery and
led assets there's also the
archaeological exclusion
Zone um and centrally within the site
you'll notice there's um an area of um
green open space pocket park um that's
there because that's a Ridge Point
within the it and required as part of
the lvia to break up the massing of the
development from long range
views um so all up as part of our pres
submission work and the year that we
spent at pres submission stage preparing
this design in consultation with
planners at the council County Council
alongside our team um we work to
optimize the site and deliver the most
dwellings that we we could around the
site constraints
thank you very much was there anything
else you wanted to say by reference to
the plans or section four of your proof
of
evidence lot at this point now thank you
okay can we turn then
please to the development plan and for
this it would be helpful to have cd
5.1 available which is the extracted
policies of the 2020 local
plan
CD
5.1 it's in the council's core documents
ah
okay yeah thank you and so in section
five Mr ball has set out quite a
detailed analysis by reference to the
development plan we're not going to go
through all of that but I think it would
be
helpful um if you could just give a bit
of History to the
allocation Mr B and its its role within
the local plan in providing the relief
Road or the link
road so the site is obviously being
identified for housing within the local
plan the relevant policy as SP sp21
um the history of that site as part of
the local plan process I believe it was
originally gladman weren't the promoters
at that time um I think the northern
parcel has set out in the evidence of Mr
Hester was identified by Council and
subsequently a different pass came
forward um by the the
landowner um in terms of its its or its
purpose within the plan um it is quite
an important allocation in Safar it
provides residential developments on a
strategic housing site and also a
distributor Link Road um if I could ask
you sir to turn
to CD
6.02 which is on
the planet District transport
strategy and it should be uh a plan
dated July 2018
thank you I've got that yeah so what
this plan shows is the draft
infrastructure plan and what's called
the inner Circuit Road improvements uh
schemes um it's it's quite a low scale
so if you zoom in you can see the the
function of the distributor Link Road um
which is at points 35 through 30 sorry
30 5 8 9
10 and what that does effectively is um
12 within the site is local known
locally as coffin house Corner um that's
a junction that's over capacity at the
moment and the purpose of the allocation
um is to provide a bypass Route Around
um that um that Junction um but also
linked to that and we've referred to it
previously is the samon Grange um site
which sits between point 10 and 11 on
that plan um and between 12 and 11 as
part of the um the conditions related to
The ssten Grange is a requirement to um
close off that road and turn the um
effectively reduce the number of
Junctions down on on number 12 so
delivery of this site is quite an
important or I would say very important
component of this s this part of the the
the Circuit Road Improvement scheme as
is reflected in the consultation
response from planning
policy okay thank you could we then um
look at your proof at
5.5 and what you do here is
identify policies that have been
identified as relevant within the
development plan and you go through
them um one by one
effectively in order to assess whether
or not um the scheme complies with those
policies and then you go on to consider
whether or not it complies with the
development plan read as a whole I think
we'll take the overall exercise is read
but could we go please specifically to
the policies that
um Mr Hester
mentioned as
um he had concerns in respect of
compliance with SP
2122 and
23 and you deal at 5.6.1
19 with the requirements of
um that policy could you just talk us
through please your view as to whether
it complies with sp21 and
why so SP sp21 is the Strategic housing
allocation site for the site um it
splits the site um and creates up to
development quantums for land north and
south shot andan
Road um within the policy there are
certain additional criteria that
proposals must meet uh when they come
forward in order to comply with that
policy um to try and simplify my
assessment of the proposal's compliance
with that policy um I've looked overall
at what the requirements are I've
separated out in the table that begins
at 5.
6.19 of my
evidence and looked in particular at uh
the the additional criteria set out in
the policy and how their proposals
Accord with them um just to address some
points that have come up as part of the
inquiry there's obviously a question
mark from the the council's side as to
whether the proposals are in accordance
with this policy given that they are for
up to 450
dwellings um in my view that they are in
accordance with that element of the
policy because the policy is blatantly
clear that is for allocating land up
to um in regards to public open space
unlike the up to that is phrased as a
minimum amount and I believe there's a
quote in the local plan inspector's
report that specifically refers to
minimum amounts in order to achieve high
quality design on
site um can you just pick up there
you've got a figure at page 28 in the
Box um of 5.22 hectares of open space
and do you recall when I asked Mr Hester
what particular part of SP 21's wording
did he identify any conflict with it was
that requirement for a minimum of 4.4
hectares of open space so can you just
deal with whether it complies and why it
provides the amount of open space it
does in my view minimum States the
minimum amounts If you overachieve
that's not a conflict with policy so by
providing 5.22 hectares it's in
compliance with policy um the 5.22
hectares is a reflection of the
requirements to provide things like the
heritage excl heritage buffers from the
list of buildings and also a reflection
of the fact that you have that surface
water flow pathway that runs through the
site and the requirement to ride over
all usable public open space as part of
a well-design scheme so I don't see that
there's a conflict with that element of
the policy by providing 5.22 hectares on
site okay thank you well there any other
points as I say that was the point that
Mr H Drew attention to were there any
other points you wanted to make specific
comment
about um no not on this but as a
reminder in relation to SP
47 um
sp22 then please and we can look at the
wording of the policy in CD
5.1
sum yeah you heard Mr Hester was
concerned that because the viability
appraisal appraised a particular scheme
that differed from the schar figures
there was non-compliance potentially
with the policy can you give us your
view in relation to that given that this
is an outline
scheme and just to check we're at sp23
sorry sp22 Ty size sorry my
mistake
um
I think this was picked up in one of
your initial um points to Mr Hester sir
um which is in relation to an outline
planning application and the relevance
of mix and type that aren't set um my
assessment of SP sp22 um is set out in
my um evidence but just to read from the
the policy itself proposals for Housing
Development will be expected to provide
an appropriate mix of market and
affordable housing card of SCH um in
this instance mix is not set mix would
be a reserve matter that would be dealt
with at Reserve matter stage um in my
assessment based on the um the work that
we've looked at it's clear that the
policy of the site can Accord with um
policy SP sp22 at Reserve matter stage
so at this point there is no conflict
with SP sp22 on the basis of this being
an outline planning
application thank you sp23 then
please the same
question SP sp23 is the affordable
housing policy sorry sir are you um
looking for I was gonna say I've just
seen a hand go up I think it's from Sir
Roger sir Roger we're in the sort of
formal part of proceedings now so I
can't sort of accept any interventions
or questions but there will be an
opportunity for questions of Mr ball uh
after cross examination which will be
tomorrow I just wanted to make that
clear because I saw your hand your hand
go up apologies um I I will endeavor to
be present tomorrow but I can't
guarantee it thank you
okay sorry for that Interruption Mr
Williams Mr ball continue no problem at
all you were just about to comment on
compliance or otherwise with the policy
sp23 of the local plan so SP sp23
obviously states that um residential
schemes for more than 10 units um the
council will seek 30% as affordable
housing um and there is an exception
caveat at the end of the policy that
states the above requirements will only
be reduced if meeting them would
demonstr make the proposed development
unviable um in this instance the
application included Financial viability
assessment work which we've already
discussed um throughout the um
determination of the application that
Financial viability assessment was
updated uh and in assessing whether the
proposals are in accordance or not with
the policy I've referred to officer
reports um and the finding of
officers it's 5.6.3 2 and 5.6.3 3 of my
evidence overall I mean I read this
policy fairly clearly there is a target
requirement for
30% this will be reduced or yeah reduced
if meeting it would dstate the develop
was unviable evidence was submitted as
part of the planning application that
was agreed by the council's independent
experts the proved that meeting that
policy requirement would demonstrate
make the development
unviable the council's decision notice
does not allege a breach of policy
sp23 I've not seen within the council's
evidence a breach of policy sp23
referenced in written evidence on my
view is is the same that policy sp23 is
not breached
thank you
and it's not a policy that's
featured in relation to the council's
evidence but could we look please at
policy SP this is just in your
proof um SP 47 and strategic
R will
5.6.7
to
concerned with the delivery of the road
schemes including the Link Road and in
relation to third party
concerns there's been a suggestion that
infrastructure was wrongly being
prioritized um above affordable housing
and I just wanted you
how does the combination of sp21 and SP
47 require those matters to be
addressed s sp21 contains the
requirement to deliver the on-site Link
Road SP 47 sets out strategic routes
within the plan uh and just for the
benefit of those that um don't have
access to the local plan um the policy
is broken up um within the opening
section of the policy it refers to a
policy's map and it aims to safeguard
lamb for the provision of key road
infrastructure part of that key road
infrastructure at point four is the shot
and Road manston Road hartstown Road
housing
site the caveats or not the caveats the
the the follow on text after those list
of safeguarded land States the following
strategic routs are sufficient in the
existing form to provide for the growth
of the plan so in preparing ing the plan
certain strategic routes were identified
including the road that runs through
this site and they are there to provide
the growth of the
plan um so there's been no sacrifice
these are policy requirements that must
be delivered on
site um if I could just move on slightly
and diverge away from third party
comments I think there was a suggestion
previously in the evidence of Mr Hester
that by providing 450 units um that we
are short changing the uh contribution
pot as it were by not paying our
proportionate contribution to offsite
Highway works now the link to this uh uh
for your
reference comes towards the end of
policy SP
47 which states the council expects all
new development to make a proportionate
contribution to the provision of this
key infrastructure this key
infrastructure is additional works
required off site to assist in the
functioning and capacity of the highway
highway Network um the County Council
has accepted a reduced quantity uh
contribution from this site on the basis
of 450 units because it stands the
reason with less units there is a lesser
transport impact that arises from this
development but not withstanding that
any requirements for making
contributions to pots applies to all
development it comes for forward in the
district so there is no loss to the part
overall okay thank you and
um just dealing with some final points
on Section 386 please in terms of the
principle of development in light of
some of the third party comments
relating to matters such as loss of
agricultural land for example what's the
role of
sp21 in relation to those sorts of impr
principle matters SP sp21 identifies the
site as allocated for residential
development in allocating the site for
residential development it establish
that the principle is
acceptable um to go one step back um the
local plan is accompanied by a proposals
map the proposals map incorporates the
site which means that it falls within
the urban boundary of Margate as defined
within the local
plan so principle is acceptable okay
thank you and section 5.7 of your proof
at paragraph sorry page
42 you set out your conclusions on the
development
plan um and you'll recall I had an
exchange with Mr Hester about the proper
approach to section 386 assessing
against the policies of the plan read as
a whole can you just summarize your key
conclusions on the development plan
please um well just as a header I
obviously carry this out because section
386 of the ACT is clear um you your your
starting point is the development plan
um through the preceding chapter I carry
an assessment of the proposals against
the important policies I
conclude um that having taken into
account all relevance or all important
policies that proposals are in
accordance with the development plan
there is no conflict um I think the
relevant um paragraph for your reference
sir is
5.7.2 two which is the overall
conclusion applying the flat balance as
under Section 386 I consider the
proposals generate significant benefits
that clearly outweigh the development
effect on landscape certain breeding
bird species significance in Heritage
assets it's therefore my evidence that
proposals Accord with the development
plan thank you and then you turn to the
nppf it's common ground that the Tilted
balance
applies um can you
just explain having looked at section
386 how you see the Tilted balance
fitting in um or what's the sequence of
considerations in relation to this
appeal um it's obviously my evidence is
that the proposals are in accordance
with the development plan if however um
you find that there is a conflict with
the development plan such the proposals
are not in accordance with that plan the
presumption in favor of sustainable
development is engaged by virtue of the
fact Council cannot demonstrate a
fiveyear land Supply and has failed the
housing delivery
test um those factors are agreed um I
refer to it in my evidence as a
procedural trigger um by virtue of the
five land Supply um that engages the
presumption and important policies are
deemed out to date that therefore takes
you to the second limb of section
386 which allows you consider other
material cons other material
considerations um the mppf is a material
consideration obviously on the basis
that um there is no fiveyear leline HDT
has not been achieved um your next
consideration would be the uh the tests
under and I always forget with the new
framework under paragraph
11d thank you very much the So-Cal
tilted
balance okay thank you just pick up here
I think Under The Heading of other
material considerations you've got a
brief section on third party
representations these were expanded upon
in some of the earlier sessions and I
just want to run through um obviously
drainage ecology has been dealt with
concerns were raised in relation to GP
services and provision can you just
explain the position reached with the
local planning
Authority um in relation to that and and
why uh as part of the planning
application uh the ccg issued a
consultation response uh in relation to
the application um that response
included um a request for a planning
contribution
um to secure additional facilities at
the the line
practice um in order to well from a
planning point of view we have to
mitigate our development's impact um the
the request from the ccg is what we have
to base um that planning contribution on
um providing that is secured through the
the legal agreements then um it is it is
seally making the development acceptable
from that
purpose thank you
loss of agricultural land the appellant
produced a position statement on that
can you just summarize the position
please um as part of our background work
we employed uh an agricultural land uh
and soil specialist who carried out
on-site testing to determine the soil
quality onsite um it's set out within
the position statements through their
on-site testing they determined
um
make sure I provide you with the correct
splits that uh 50% of the site was
subgrade 3A 49% of the site was subgrade
3B I.E not best and most versatile and
1% was non-agricultural
um also within the statement of Common
Ground um there is a reference to soil
quality
um and effectively although I can't find
it at the moment what it what it
effectively says is as part of the local
plan allocation process um the council
will have considered the loss of
agricultural land land uh in order to
meet its housing need um that loss has
been acceptable that loss has been found
sound the strategy of the plan has been
found sound as part of the examination
process
um I think it's the relevant policies e
e16 in the local plan let me just double
check
that I think it's 3.2 of the State
Common
Ground thank
you 3.2 yeah the the application site
comprises undeveloped Greenfield land
soil tests were undertaken by the
appellant which confirms that 50% of the
sites is 3A 49 subgrade 3B the loss of
agricultural land has been considered
and weighed against the need for housing
through the local plan process the
parties agree that policy e16 of the
plan provides an exception to sites
allocated for development under the
policies and and the general presumption
to safeguard best and most versatile
land the the exception applies to the
appeal proposals on site allocated for
developments okay thank you um also a
third party suggestion that the the
scheme is not an accessible location in
a way that would be overly car
dependent um well obviously we're uh
within the urban edge of Margate um I
would again refer to um the statement of
common ground
at
2.9 which refers to sustainable travel
choices accessible from the
site thank you final third party point I
think was a number of um speakers
referred to a concern of a domino effect
in relation to various matters if this
was granted planning per Mission your
view please on where that fits into
um the general approach of planning to
decisions in relation to an allocated
site um decisions must be made on their
Merit uh and each case must be assessed
on a case-by Case basis so this must
this application must stand on it on the
application and and the evidence before
it thank
you going back to your main proof of
evidence pleas section
seven you set out here at par
7.1.1 by bullet points
the benefits that you have identified
through the the
scheme can I it's common ground but in
relation to Heritage balance that's nppf
paragraph 202 what's
your view what's your conclusion as to
whether or not any heritage harm found
is outweighed by the public benefits of
the
scheme um I set this out
at just for your reference sir 8.1
point10 of my proof um as has been
previously discussed within the inquiry
U my view is the public benefits
outweigh the minimal Heritage harm or
the negligible Heritage harm that has
been assessed um however we can't um
turn our attention away from paragraph
202 of the framework um which is clear
that where development proposals lead to
less than substantial harm you must
carry out that public benefits wasting
exercise um in carrying out that waiting
exercise bearing in mind the the array
of benefits that come forward as part of
this proposal my conclusions were that
the public benefit test has
passed thank you and in terms of the
waiting that you give to the
various benefits if we turn to paragraph
8.3 or section
8.3 again won't ask you to read it out
but that's where you set out your
waiting to the various benefits that
you've identified is that is that right
that's correct uh and I would also add
um as well as identifying the the degree
of weight um I also provide some
commentary as to how I've arrived that
at that
weight and say can you just
perhaps give us your view you've
explained that under Section
386 you conclude that the in fact all of
the policies are complied with but
equally that the development plan red as
a whole is complied with now move beyond
that if you like into the Tilted balance
and assume that um there is a degree of
harm by reference to the affordable
housing provision being 15% rather than
30% how would you invite the inspector
to approach the Tilted balance in those
circumstances what goes on the harm side
and what goes on the The Beneficial
side um as you'll note within my
evidence sir um I have not identified a
specific harm by not fulfilling the 30%
oford
housing um the the process in relation
to policy
sp23 has been considered on the basis of
evidence policy sb23 obviously allows uh
viability evidence to be considered
where it is a
concern in this instance although it's
unfortunate that the scheme can't
support 30% affordable housing it still
leads to the delivery of 68 affordable
units at a time where there is
outstanding need on on my basis um I
think it's better to have affordable
housing come forward than no affordable
housing come forward um which would
which is what would happen if this
proposal was refused or or if the appeal
was dismissed no new housing would would
take place there'd be no um there'd be
no overall benefit on the basis that
pre-existing affordable housing need is
not a harm that's arising as a result of
this development this development
contributes to
addressing that need so it can only be
considered as a very significant
benefit thank you very much was there
anything else you wanted to say under
the The Heading of planning
balance uh no not at this point Thank
you and could we just then take up your
rebuttal just to identify the points
that are dealt with and you'll let me
know whether you have anything further
to say in light of the evidence you've
heard today the first point you deal
with in your rebuttal at paragraph
two
is concerns in relation to the provision
of 450 units and obviously earlier in
your evidence in Chief you explained the
site constraints and the response to
them is there anything you would like to
add to what you've already said by
reference to your rebuttal
evidence um no it's just really
emphasizing that um the expression in
policy um does not refer to it refers to
up to amounts and the the work that has
taken place in in preparing this
planning application Spann over a year
involves heavy influence from ory every
involvement uh from the planning
officers of the council and the district
council from the Consulting team so I
don't think it's fair to say that this
is the only show in town and more could
be fit on this site a very significant
amount of work was undertaken including
by professional officers within thanet
District
Council and the the the proposals are
very well considered and
conceived
thank you the next topic you deal with
is
sp22 and the mix again we've address
that but is there anything you want to
draw attention to under that
heading I think the only thing I would
point you to in addition on Sir uh would
be at
1.2.2
two of the
robot
which um is taken from the opening of
the 2016 schar in particular the first
part of that sentence the schar does not
set housing
targets
um
although it's more in relation to policy
sp23 but I think it's it's
worthwhile going there
um me just need to find it in my main
proof of evidence sorry to have to jump
around
doesn't come immediately to effectively
it was um I can try and find it for um
cross examination um effectively it was
a similar caveat in relation to
affordable housing um and it's in in
there somewhere that effectively says
that um affordable housing set out
within the local housing needs assess
does not is not a Target and it's based
on what can viably be provided on site
and in relation to the points you make
here in your rebuttal about
sp21 and
sp22 and as um the planning consultant
with conduct of this case through the
application and the appeal can I ask you
has the council through well since the
determination
of the application or through the appeal
process put to you um any different
layouts that it wished to see or any
changes it thought were required to the
parameters plan or any alternative
Financial viability appraisals that it
wanted to see run other than those in
the Dix and C note no it
hasn't thank you if you then turn to the
final
question in your rebuttal final topic on
page nine gladman as a
promoter I asked Mr Hester questions
about this and you set out how how
gladman works I think it might be
helpful for you just to give a summary
of how the role of gladman as a site
promoter Bears
upon um the assessment of viability for
a identified
scheme um so I'll I'll be careful so I
Don't Stray into valuation evidence but
um I set this out in response to um what
appeared to be a criticism within Mr
Hester's evidence about gladman and our
profit and the interaction with our
profit and an overall viability
assessment profit um
gladman is a is a is a land promoter um
the way that we work is promotion
agreements with land owners
as part of that promotion agreement um
although the terms are not set out in
evidence because they're not relevant as
part of the viability assessment we
agree a fee to take on the profit uh to
take on the risk of promoting the site
securing outline planning
permission and that fee would come out
at site sale um so our involvement in
quote unquote terms as part of viability
appraisal sits Hool within the euv plus
the existing use plus value of the site
um the landowner has brought us on board
to take on the risk of securing outline
Planning
Commission thank you very much is there
anything else you want to say in your
evidence in Chief Mr
B um no thank you very much thank you
and thank you
sir thank you Mr Williams and thank you
Mr Mr ball can I just ask one question
I'm conscious of time so I don't think
it will take too long but when the
master plan was drawn up was it drawn up
with a policy compliant housing mix in
mind and with the sort of and also in
terms of how
sizes nationally described space
standard Etc was that drawn up with a
view to sort of Meeting those policies
the reason asked that question obviously
I don't want to go back into talk about
viability uh because you're the planning
witness a viability expert but in terms
of Meeting those policies about housing
mix Etc is there a sort of confidence
that the master plan would deliver
that yeah um and I suppose this is this
is where comes the separation of
financial viability appraisal and and
policy um on um policy
sb22 um the master plan that was drawn
up um it goes through many stages of
Evolutions um and when you're coming
towards the end of that um we consider
what's called a approving layout which
is instru ed through um Architects that
work alongside house builders um and
that takes into account um the types and
sizes of housing just to make sure that
the the amount of development that we're
applying for could actually be secured
on site um so we are confident that um
that what is set out in the shmar can be
achieved on site um what feeds through
to the valuation as as has been made
clear in the evidence uh of Mr culry was
was an optimized scheme to secure the
highest level of affordable housing on
site okay thank you that's helpful thank
you uh that's the only question I've got
for for now um so that is the end of
your examination in Chief uh so thank
you for that and obviously we'll
continue tomorrow morning at 9:30 that
time is okay still for everybody with
your uh
cross-examination by Mr Upton so just
before we close tonight just in terms of
timetable uh bearing mind Friday's our
last day last scheduled day
uh just sort of thinking through the
timetable as best we can first question
for Mr Upson how long do you expect
you'll need for
cross-examination obviously
approximately I approxim was going to
say an hour but I'm conscious that for I
said that for Mr Cordy it took a bit
longer um so but I'm hoping by now the
issues are fairly clear but it's
um yeah I mean so it's should we say an
hour and a quarter yeah okay give
yourself a buffer on on okay so if let's
just think so that's that will take us
through let's just work us out in terms
of a timetable that will take us through
till say we kick off if there's any sort
of early stuff that needs to be resolved
or whatever housekeeping stuff that will
take us
to quarter to 10 quar quarter p 11 I
think so it's late in the day so I might
be getting this wrong quarter p 11 let's
say uh and then examination
reexamination any very hard to say
before the C examination
starts let's guess 15 minutes yeah okay
uh so so approximately half 11 and I
appreciate yeah it's it's difficult to
predict at this point but but half1
there might be some questions to break
so then we're going through till let's
say around about sort of quarter with a
break after the break quarter to
so that will be all
the witnesses dealt with and the formal
evidence which means there's a good
chance of
next is conditions isn't it
uh so conditions
before lunch there's a few points I want
to ask about the conditions from
experience inv variable that's going to
go on for an hour or so so that will
take us to
lunch the planning
obligation is going to
be difficult to say there's a few things
I want to ask but I need to sort of read
it again this evening as well so there
might well be more things but
say three4 of an
hour
um so can I just raise a point on do you
remember on when it was sent in on
Tuesday I said there was going to be a
re there was going to be a need for a
moving of the um review mechanism yeah
the agreement element to the
unilateral element and that has now been
done and the final versions
with a summary of how it operates has
been sent to miss Dutton
right okay let me just turn to
my email screen uh right the last email
I've got from mron was the updated
suggested list of conditions which I'm
grateful for so thank you for those but
no I've not yet got through the 106 and
looking at the wonders of this you can
tell who's not been working for last
hour so I think I don't think M's any
longer in the office or her office from
what I can see so I've not got that so I
will I mean I could probably look at
that over lunchtime I would hope so uh
because the I presume the
actual basis of the 106 or and the
unilateral is not significantly changed
from the draft that I received on
Tuesday in terms of the M I think the
drafts been tidied up there's been um
one or two minor changes that the County
Council had um
negotiated and they are they've provided
the letter I understand that they're
happy with the content of the
agreement um
and again I haven't I haven't read what
came into my email this afternoon but I
understand it's to do with
the move of the review mechanism into
the into the unilateral which has some
consequential changes for dispute
resolution for example
okay okay
well I've not got that that can that
will hopefully come through tomorrow
morning and I can review what I've got
this evening and in terms of any
questions that I've got and I can catch
up on anything tomorrow during the lunch
break if not then we'll have to just
make the appropriate time for it so that
brings us then on to the question of
closing submissions going back to what
we talked about during the opening in
terms of uh the two of you and Mr
Dickman having enough time to uh form
those Etc so is that something that you
think would be a reasonable possibility
to do
for Friday
afternoon is my first
question from my perspective say
yes
I'm working on that basis suly um
clearly I have to try and anticipate
what Mr Bull may or may not say but
um uh broadly speaking there's obviously
a little bit of time whil conditions
going that I'm can anticipate a little
bit where it's going so I'm certainly
hoping okay good thank you because I
don't want to have to sort of for you to
Mr Dickman as well you're going to be I
presume Mr Dickman you wants to do a
closing submission as well and I most
certainly so uh I suppose two questions
there would be um do we have to submit
that does that have to be seen by other
parties and secondly a rough estimation
on what your expectation will be for a
submission in terms of time
time uh well it it'll be up to you but
sort of they tend to be around about
what what are the expected closing
submissions for Mr Williams and Mr Upton
before I sort of predicted what they
might be
well as I'm sandwiched in between I'll
try and gauge the time and set it
according yeah I me it's up to you but
you know if there sort of 1550 minutes
then that's would be sort of similar to
the opening statement yes yeah yeah it's
whatever they be but obviously I don't
want them to be going on for a sort of
you
know hours and so they're normally sort
of Fairly concise but also they're very
helpful to me as the inspector in terms
of summarizing the cases of all the the
parties so they are a useful document
that's what I want to make sure there's
enough time for them to be to be done so
it it appears that with a good wind we
can complete by tomorrow orbe it a bit
later imagine I've got more lengthy
distance of travel than anybody else
here but anyway uh so I suspect we can
finish tomorrow and I'd much rather do
that than have to sort of go over into
next week and all the complications that
would cause and I think it sounds like
we can we can do that uh we also there's
obviously so we've got to discuss the
site
visit and we've got to uh any cost
applications as well so um all that has
to be fitted in so I think we can do it
does anybody think we can't do
it depends how late on Friday you're
prepared to sit but I mean one one
safety valve measure would be perhaps to
do the cost applications in writing
because you may want that in in writing
anyway but long as it's set to sort of
in a very short time scale it's just
it's one way of relieving the pressure
that's
really yes I'm I'm I mean I know that
all the guidance says that all the cost
should be dealt with actually during the
the actual inquiry time but I in the
past have left it in writing and that
seems to have worked reasonably well
that that is an option I don't know Mr
Williams you have any view on
that
um I I
will as sorry slightly Tongue Tied but
um because because the application
relates to the evidence rather than
anything procedural it will be it will
cross refer to the closing so I think
the cost application itself will be
succinct and can cross refer so I will
prepare that to be in a position to
deliver it tomorrow okay um I can
understand that you can't do these
things really until you've heard the
evidence and I can understand from
learned friend's point of view
um he's in a similar position in
relation to Mr ball tomorrow but I'm
going to work on the basis to try and do
both tomorrow if I can but I'm very open
to other suggestions in relation to
costs when we get to it okay okay thank
you uh that seems like that seems like a
reasonable way forward and finally with
the site visit I did I think mention the
possibility of next Tuesday for a site
visit do the main parties have any view
on whether or not that's going to be
possible for me to do it on Tuesday it
would be
Tuesday Morning uh late morning I
imagine mid morning to M mid morning to
lunchtime would be the slot I would
imagine I could uh I could I'd
preferably do it in I think Mr Black's
raised a hand so he would be attending
the site visit and organizing it for us
yeah if if I may sir I've been in touch
with the land owner and we're happy to
um um allow us to access the site as
when we we need to so but Tuesday
morning is is fine for me and I think
you know I've I've got a fair distance
to travel down to down to Margate uh so
uh be handy to know sooner rather than
later so I can arrange accommodation
Etc I have I have circulated a walking
list um which followed on from
circulation from Mr Hand earli in the
week uh to Mr Hand and also Mr
Livingston so we're just waiting for
comments on that so we can hopefully
offer that up tomorrow for you so in a
fully agreed form okay that will be very
useful thank you Mr Dickman just to say
um we we certainly will have somebody
there may be me but whoever it is H
obviously because we're locals we have a
good knowledge of the land as well okay
I know from an email that councelor
faren has already suggested that she
comes along as well so obviously you
don't want to sry say you don't want to
entourage obviously but we will I I
would much rather yeah not particularly
how we're going to be doing there gonna
be lots of quite a lot of walking around
and also I think from my point of view
it is easier just to look at things make
notes with a few people rather than
having about 20 people I don't think to
be honest with you it doesn't add
anything to anybody's case having lots
and lots of people there uh and the only
thing that you can sort of talk about
with me is pointing out things there'll
be no discussion of merits or anything
like like that and Mr Upton is Mr
Livingstone I don't know who will be
doing the site visit from the council's
point I see Mr livstone May comment I
think it there was certainly an option
Mr lion or Mr Hester but certainly
Tuesday as I understand is fine but Mr
lion May certainly have an
update thank you uh yes it's likely to
be Mr Mr Hester I believe he'll be out
of um out of isolation at that point um
so yes Tuesday morning is fine for us
sir okay that's good well let's firm
that up then as Tuesday morning I'll
think
about uh overnight about a time without
giving my location away I'll still have
quite a journey to get to that but I
probably will be able to do that in the
morning so anyway let me think about
that today and then I'll propose a start
time uh tomorrow before we close but uh
that sounds satisfactory So yeah thank
you for all your input in that
regard okay anything
else needs to be
raised no good well thank you again for
everybody for all your contributions
I'll adjourn for today and we'll
recommence tomorrow morning at 9
93 thank you sir thank
you